COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE THE
COVE IN NINETEEN MARIN C TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE MESSER
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
NOR TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL- TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE WOULD
MILLION MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WILL BE.
THERE WE WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. ON FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE ON THE PHONE OR
WATCHING. OF FROM OTHER PLACES
IN THE CAPITAL. YOU SHOULD NOTE
THAT THAT WE WILL ALSO ACCEPT
TESTIMONY IN WRITING. FOR
WISHING PROVIDE COMMENT JUST
BEEN TOLD NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN HELLO ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR EIGHT SIX
SEVEN SIX ONE SIX THREE. IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE ONE ZERO
ONE SIX FIVE FOUR FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. THIS IS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERN TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU'LL
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR-
CONNECTIONS OF MUTED. HOWEVER
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO.
HEARING PRO COULD HEARING IN
THIS CALL. THE SAME MANNER IS
CO. THERE MAY BE SOME. LAW FOR
PARTICIPANTS ARE AT INTO THE
NEW YEAR OF ALL TOOL IT TOOK.
PLAY PURISTS AND- SO ALL
INTEREST PARTIES CAN BE- THREE
TO THE CAN REGARDING LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I'M INSTITUTING TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY I WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR UP FRONT THEY'LL
PERMIT EACH SIDE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION DIP TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES BEACH PRIMARY WITNESS
WITH MINUTEST FIVE FOR TWO
MINUTES I WILL THEN ADDITIONAL
PREVENT EACH SIDE OF A MAXIMUM
OF FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES WHO MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. IF IT SHOULD EVER
BE MODIFIED DURING THE COURSE
THIS HEARING I WILL MAKE SURE
THAT EACH SIDE HAS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY EQUAL ABILITY. TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING.
BEFORE YOUR PRESS. ON THE
BILL'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. BUT
I'M COUNTS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR PURPOSES OF IS. A BURKE
HILLS AMBERG BOARD JANICE.
BARGES PRESENT. WE HAD A.
CABALLERO DID I HERE DID US SO
HE GONZALEZ YEAH GONZALEZ HURTS.
JONES JR HE LAYERED HERE LEHRER
HERE STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER. A QUORUM HAS A STEP.
THANK YOU HAVE A QUORUM. WE
HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS TODAY'S FOR
WHICH ARE ON CONSENT I WON NO
THAT FOLLOW NUMBERS S. B. C.
THREE TWO BY SEVEN OF MON HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND WILL BE HEARD IN
COMMITTEE TODAY THE ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ARE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB SEVEN TWO
FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN WITH
AMENDMENTS PROBLEM NUMBER
ELEVEN S. B. FIVE SIX FIVE BY
SENATOR JONES FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB SIX ZERO TWO BY
CENTER LAYER AND FINALLY FILE
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SIX THREE
EIGHT BY SENATOR HERTZBERG. IS.
THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATE LAYERED MOST
CAN. MAN SHE CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON THE CA CALENDAR
BURKE HI I'M BURKE AYE PORGES.
GORGEOUS I CAMBIADO. HI CAPITAL
I DID ALSO HI THE REST SO I CAN
SEE. HI GONZALEZ I HEARD. JOHN
HI DOWN THE AISLE HI WHERE
ISTER. WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER.
YES VOTE SO FAR ON CONSENT
THANK YOU WE'LL KEEP THAT
MATTER ON CALL- CENTER SKINNER
I SEE OR HEAR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- AND I. FOR SOME CAN HERE
ENTER OF THE FILE ORDER SO
SINISTER DO X. PROPOSED A
MEMBER IS ALSO NOW SOME PAGE
FIFTH COME NUMBER SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WILL LOOK
THE CAN MEMBER CLEAR THAT
WHISTLE. IDENTIFY IN. IS AND
THAT- MAKES IT- IT CLARIFIES AS
THE BILL HAD RICH INTO THAT THE
MISSED- BY A SURPRISE MY BE S.
FOR. THANK YOU SAYS SKINNER- SO
HERE YOU THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU- POLITIES JUST
CRACKING SOMETHING THE MOST TO
BE- MEMBERS SOME VERY VERY
PLEASE TO PRESENT SB SIX. YES
SIXTEEN IS THE ENTER. OF A BILL
S. SO. SEVEN SIX WHICH- WAS-
MIND LAST YEAR IN WHICH WAS
APPROVED BY THE ASSEMBLY WITH A-
I DON'T HAVE THE PHONE FOR ME
BUT FOR. FIFTY OR HIGHER ON THE
LAST OF SESSION BUT DUE TO THE
MITTEN DEADLINE THAT WE FACED.
ONCE IT GOT OVER TO THE SENATE
WE RAN OUT OF TIME TO TAKE IT
UP. SO WE BRING IT BACK WITH
THE HOPES THAT WE ARE DON'T HIT
THAT MIDNIGHT. AS WE DID LAST
YEAR. BUT WHAT SB SIXTEEN DOES
IS BUILD UPON. THE BILL I
DIDN'T TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW. WHICH
WAS SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AND
THAT BILL FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
FORTY YEARS OPENED CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLETE BLOCK. ON ANY PUBLIC
ACCESS TO. POLICE RECORDS. THAT
THAT BLOCK OR THAT- IT ABILITY
TO ACCESS. RECORDS EVEN
INCLUDED A CHIEF OF POLICE
COULD NOT GET RECORDS ON. A AN
OFFICER THAT THEY WERE
CONSIDERING FOR HIGHER. THEY
COULD THERE WAS ONLY LIMITED
THINGS THAT THEY COULD EVEN GET
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THAT
PARTICULAR OFFICER ANY NO OTHER
AGENCY HAD A HISTORY OF
COMPLAINTS OR MISCONDUCT IN A
CERTAIN SET OF THINGS. THE NEW
HIRING AGENCY WOULD NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE RECORDS- SO.
THE I INDICATED TWENTY ONE WAS
PASSED AND IT OPENED UP ACCESS
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN FORTY
YEARS TO A LIMITED SET OF
RECORDS. THOSE RECORDS BEING
SPECIFICALLY PROVEN SEXUAL
ASSAULT ON THE JOBS IN OTHER
WORDS AND IF AN OFFICER
COMMITTED SEXUAL ASSAULT ON THE
JOB. SECONDLY DISHONESTY
INVOLVING INTERFERING WITH A
WITNESS FOR TAMPERING EVIDENCE.
AND THIRDLY DISCHARGING A
FIREARM OR USE OF FORCE SO
THOSE WERE ARE THE THINGS THAT
WE NOW HAVE ACCESS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS ADD A FEW OTHER
CATEGORIES AND THE PRINCIPLE OF
WHICH IS THAT. LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO BE EFFECTIVE MUST HAVE THE
TRUST OF THE COMMUNITY IT
SERVES AND WHEN THE COMMUNITY
FEELS LIKE WE DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT OUR OFFICERS AND IF WE
MAKE CERTAIN COMPLAINTS WE HAVE
NO IDEA IF THOSE COMPLAINTS ARE
EVER INVESTIGATED WORK THE
OFFICERS EVER HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SO THE ADDITION THAT I WILL BE
PRESENTED TO NOW ARE ADDITIONS
THAT MOST PEOPLE FEEL ARE VERY
READ THING THAT ALL OF US
DESERVED KNOW ABOUT THE OFFICER
THAT SIR. SO THE ADDITIONAL
RECORDS THERE ARE SIX DAD'S ARE
GETTING SPEAKING ACCESS TO USE
FORCE SOME OF THE WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET A WORK ON SO.
FINDING OF HENRI- USE OF FORCE.
IT ALSO PROVIDES IF NORTH
OFFICER HAS A HIS OF. BIASED OR
DISK. ACTS AND AGAIN SYSTEM. WE
WOULD HAVE TO THOSE. THAT IF
THEY HAD A HISTORY OF CONDUCT A
LOS ARREST SEARCH. AND- IN
ANOTHER COUNTY OF DISHONESTY.
SO ALL OF THESE MUST BE
SUSTAINED FINDINGS- THE LAST
THING THAT THE BILL DOES. IS IT
ENSURES THAT. IF AN OFFICER
QUITS THEIR JOB LET'S SAY
THERE'S A SET OF COMPLAINTS
BROUGHT AGAINST THEM AND THE
AGENCY HAS JUST OPENED AN
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
COMPLETED AND THE OFFICER
CHOOSES TO AVOID. HAVING THE
COMPLETE LOOKED INTO TO LEAVE
THE JOB. THAT A NOTHER HIRING
AGENCY BEEN CONSIDERING THE
HIRING OF THAT OFFICER CAN CAN
AND WOULD REQUEST FROM THE
PREVIOUS AGENCY ALL RECORDS
RELATED TO THAT OFFICER. SO WE
DON'T HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
OFFICERS ARE JUST QUITTING IT
JUMPING OFF TO ANOTHER FORCE TO
AVOID HAVING THEIR MISCONDUCT
EVER REVEALED. SO THIS PROTECTS
ALL OF US IT PROTECTS OUR
AGENCIES SO THAT THEY KNOW WHO
THEY'RE HIRING. SO THAT'S WHAT
THE BILL DOES SPOKE SKEWS ME
THERE'S ONE OTHER COMPONENT AND
THAT IS ONCE FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE PASSED MOST JURISDICTIONS
AND AGENCIES COMPLIED WITH THE
LAW IN RELEASED THE RECORDS AS
THE BILL WRECKED. IT IN FORCE-
REQUIRED. HOWEVER THERE ARE
SOME AGENCIES WHO WANTED TO
HEAR DIRECTOR FEED FOR DOOR OR
CREATE OBSTACLES AND SOME OF
THE OBSTACLES THAT THEY CREATED
WERE TO CHARGE OUT REGIS PRICES
FOR THE REQUEST FOR TO GET
RECORDS. THERE WAS ONE
PARTICULAR JURISDICTION IT
TRIED TO CHARGE A FAMILY SOME
AT THAT THE INITIAL BILL WAS
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
REAP RECORDS THAT THEY
REQUESTED. SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS CLARIFY THEY CAN ONLY
CHARGE FOR THE COPYING JUST
LIKE OUR PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUIRES. AND THAT THEY MUST
RESPOND IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
IF THEY DO NOT RESPOND IN A
TIMELY MANNER THERE'S THE
ABILITY TO TAKE TO CHALLENGE
THAT IN COURT AND FOR THERE TO
BE FEES OR FINES LEVIED. BOB
BASED ON THEIR REFUSAL TO
COMPLY. WITH THE LAW. FOR PETER
RICH BILL SB HOURS YES FOR
TWENTY WAS QUITE CAN EVERY
ENFORCEMENT OF. THIS BILL SB
SIXTY SO LET YEAR'S SEVENTEEN
SIX I WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR MAJOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES LIKE ARE YOU ENTITIES
LIKE CORRECT. AND MADE SURE
THAT ALL OF THE RECORDS HERE
WERE SUSTAIN FINDINGS AND
ADDRESSED OTHER CONCERNS THEY
HAD SO I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY
THAT POOR ACT FOR EXAMPLE IS
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL. THERE ARE
SOME OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT STILL DON'T LIKE
THIS BILL BUT IS NOT NEAR AS
CONTENTIOUS AS FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE WAS. FOUND WITH THAT HI-
WOULD GO TO MY MAIN WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER- I BELIEVE WE HAVE- A
NATASHA MINSKER WITH SMART
JUSTICE AND SAFEST JOHNSON WITH
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES UNITED
FOR JUSTICE- ON THE PHONE LINE
SO. IF WE MIGHT START WITH A-
MISS MINSKER. GOOD AFTERNOON SB
SIXTEEN IS A MODEST PROPOSAL
THAT PRIMARILY ADDRESSES THE
PROBLEMS FAMILY MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC HAVE ENCOUNTERED
ACCESSING CONDUCT RECORD. FOR
FORTY YEARS RECORD COULD NOT
CONDUCT BY POLICE THE KEPT
SECRET AND HIDDEN FROM THE
PUBLIC. BETTER SKINNER BUILDERS
THE PUBLIC RIGHT TO KNOW. ABOUT
HONDA BY. ANY FAMILY MEMBERS
RECORDERS IN MEMBER OF THE-
REQUESTED WRECKED. AND
IMMEDIATE THEY ENCOUNTERED
CURIOUS WROCLAW. DEPARTMENT
DESTROYED I THINK OUR PERMITTED
TO DO UNDER LAW. BERMAN FUTURE
TURNING PRIVILEGE READ. ABOUT
STATEMENTS FROM WITNESSES. SAM
WERE CHARGED OUT OF DOLLARS FOR
FEES FOR RECORD STORED IN A
DIGITAL. THAT CAN BE DUPLICATED
WITH A FEW KEY. OFTEN- RESIGNED
TO BLOCK THIS MERGER OF RECORD
AND APART THE WAY JUST FOR
MONEY EVEN MORE THAN A YEAR
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE WAY TO
ENFORCE THE FOR THE IN HER LAW.
TO UNDERSTANDING OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND BUILDING TRUST
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES AND POLICE.
THIS INCLUDES SUSTAIN
COMPLAINTS OF PREJUDICE AND
BIAS BY POLICE. THE SAME
COMPLAINTS OF ILLEGAL SEARCHES
ARE AT. ON USE OF FORCE BY THE
POLICE THIS IS CRITICAL
INFORMATION FOR THE PUBLIC TO
KNOW HOW THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
OR TAKING MISCONDUCT COMPLAINT
SERIOUSLY AND OFTEN OFFICERS
HAVE A PATTERN OF MISCONDUCT.
SB SIXTEEN IS A MODEST PROPOSAL
THAT WILL ENSURE THE PUBLIC HAS
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION IS NEEDED AND IT
WILL HELP BUILD TRUST BETWEEN
POLICE AND COMMUNITY. ON BEHALF
OF BOTH SMARTER FOR CALIFORNIA
AND THE PROSECUTORS LINE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE YOUR EYES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
MINSKER OUR NEXT- SEE IF JOHN.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
OKAY I AM SICK THIS LOCAL BOBBY
JOHNSON UNCLE ABBAS GRANT. FOR
THE PAST TWELVE YEARS I'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTAILITY HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER. OKAY.
THANK GLADNESS JOLLY. OKAY
POLICE OFFICERS ARE VESTED THE
WITH EXTRA POWER. IN ALL TO
MONITOR THE USE OF THAT POWER
THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO KNOW WHEN
THEY ARE OVER THE LINE.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
SECRETIVE ST STE CONCERNING
TRANSPARENCY UPON THESE RECORDS
IN THE NATION. THIS IS MERRY
RECORDS OF POLICE OFFICERS THAT
HAVE USED DEADLY FORCE. IT'S
FAIR INJURY SEXUAL SAW SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED SOMEONE FOR LIFE ON
THE JOB HAVE BEEN KEPT SECRET
FOR FORTY YEARS. UNTIL TWENTY
NINETEEN WHEN SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE OR TWELVE BACK. A
PENSION OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE CRACKED THE DOOR OPEN.
TRANSPARENCY HOWEVER NOT
WITHOUT BLATANT PUSH BACK FROM
POLICING THEY JUST TO DROP THE
STATE. THANKS TO THE CALIFORNIA
COURTS THE RULING IN OUR FAVOR.
NOW IN THIS TIME OF RECKONING
WHICH IS A CRITICAL TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA POLICING AGENCIES TO
BUILD TRUST WITH THE COMMUNITY
THEY SERVE. WE CAN CLOSE
LOOPHOLES TO REAL TRANSPARENCY
WITH SB SIXTEEN. SB SIXTEEN
WILL GRANT ACCESS TO RECORDS
ABOUT POLICE OFFICERS WHO
ENGAGE IN BIASED OR
DISCRIMINATORY BEHAVIOR OR USE
THAT PHONE. FOR A REASONABLE
FOR. IT WOULD ALSO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR AGENCIES AND
INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS TO MANEUVER
AROUND THE DISCLOSURE REQUIRED
BY IT THE FOURTEENTH TWENTY
ONE. THE FOURTEENTH TWENTY ONE
FOCUSED ON COMPLETED
INVESTIGATION. SB SIXTEEN WILL
MAKE RECORDS PUBLIC IF THE
INTERNAL CARE BEST ADDITION
POTENTIAL MISCONDUCT HAD BEEN
COMPLETED BY THE TIME THE
OFFICER. PART THEIR POSITION
WHICH RIGHT NOW MANY LEAVES ONE
EIGHTY THREE TO GO TO ANOTHER
THEIR BY IMPORTING THIS
DISCLOSURE. SB SIX DIDN'T CLOSE
THIS LOOPHOLE IN OFFICE
DIRECTLY WOULD BE CARRIED WITH
THEM NO MATTER WHERE THEY GO.
FOR THE HIGH. THANK YOU HAVE A
IMPACTED TIME OF THE CALIFORNIA
TERMS UNITED THE JUSTICE
NETWORK WE URGE YOU TO PASS
FIFTY SIXTEEN SO OUR HEALING
CAN BEGIN THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON- ALL RIGHT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TURN TO THE
GALLERY- IF THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE GALLERY WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTEEN THEY SHOULD MOVE TO
THE MICROPHONE I DON'T SEE ANY
MOVEMENT. BUT NOW IT'S REAL
MOVED TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIXTEEN THEY
SHOULD MOVE TO THE MICROPHONE.
I DON'T SEE ANY. I DON'T SEE
ANY MOVEMENT TO THE MICROPHONE
IN ROOM ONE ONE TWELVE WILL NOW
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES- THOSE
OF YOU ON THE PHONE LINES. HI
WHAT WHAT WE PERMIT IS YOUR
NAME YOUR FILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND THAT
WILL APPLY TO OTHERS LATER ON
AS WELL. ALL RIGHT- MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD A TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES TO CONNECT THOSE
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR S. B.
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. IF YOU HAVE PREVIOUSLY
QUEUED UP FOR DIFFERENT BILL
YOU MAY REMOVE YOURSELF BY
REPEATING THE LAWN AND THEN
ZERO. HELLO FIRST IN LINE TO
NINETY THREE TWO NINE THREE
ALLIANCE OF. IT GOT ME. YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY I. ALL
RIGHT- MATTER NEXT TO MOVE. IT
WILL MOVE TO TWO NINETY NINE
TWO NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS ROBIN ALLEN. IT'S
NOT COUNCIL. AND I. THANK YOU
MODERATE WE'RE TAKING THOSE
HERE IN SOME OF POINT AND WE
WOULD ASK THOSE WHO ARE ON THE
PHONE TO YOU YOU'RE LISTENING
DEVICE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
FEEDBACK. SO MR MODERATOR THANK
YOU- AGAIN IF YOU WE ARE TAKING
SUPPORT FOR S. B. ONE SIX IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OR HAVE
A DIFFERENT BILL TO SPEAK ON
PLEASE REMOVE YOURSELF A PERSON
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WELCOME LINE
FOR FIFTY FOUR OR FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. L. GOT A- IT
WILL BE. WE WILL NEVER THE LINE.
TWENTY FIVE FOUR TWO. FOUR TO
FIVE IS DISCONNECTED LINE FIVE
OH FIVE FIVE ZERO FIVE YOUR
MIND IS OPEN. MAYBE CENTERS ON
BEHALF OF S. YOU CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THAT'S PLEASE. THREE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE SEVEN ONE. AND YOU'RE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS HELP WHERE CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORTER SB SIX. THANK
YOU. FIND. FIVE FORTY FIVE FIVE
FOUR FIVE. THANK YOU CAME WHEN
DEAN ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE.
THREE FIFTY ONE THREE FIVE ONE.
MAY THE BUDGET TODD I'M A WOMAN
BUSINESS OWNER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
LINE FOR SEVENTY THREE FOUR
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FINE FOR SEVENTY THREE DO YOU
HAVE A POSITION ON SB SIXTEEN.
FOR MORE ON THE LINE FOR TWENTY
ONE FOUR TO ONE NO ONE IS OPEN.
THE ON BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES CONTRACT SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
TEXAS THREE THREE FORTY SEVEN
THREE FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE UNDERLINED FIVE
FIFTY ONE FIVE FIVE ON YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIVE FIFTY
ONE ARE YOU IN FAVOR OF SB
SIXTEEN. YOU CAN MOVE ON THE
LINE THREE NINETY FIVE THREE
NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M SORRY I'M UNDECIDED. THIRTY
NEXT PLEASE. NINE TO FORTY FOUR
TWO FOUR FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVED IN LINE. THREE NINETY
NINE THREE NINE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE SEVERAL MORE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE AS WE ATTEMPT TO
GET THEIR LINE NUMBER PROVIDED
TO THEM.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. FIVE
SIXTY TWO FIVE SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. SIXTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. PLAN FOR
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR TOM
HICKEY ON BEHALF OF YOUR W.
TWENTY FIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BONTA
BLIND. TWO OH FOUR TWO ZERO
FOUR. GLORIA TREVINO AND I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT THE SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. NINE TO THIRTY FOUR
TWO THREE FOUR. YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE ONE TO THIRTY FOUR. WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE. FIVE TWENTY
FOUR FIVE TWO FOUR. I LINE FIVE
TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE LINE IS DISCONNECTED FOR
THE LINE THREE TEN THREE ONE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
THREE TEND TO WANT TO STATE
YOUR NAME AND POSITION. WILL
MOVE THE LINE FOR THIRTY FOUR
FOUR THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVIELINE FIVE SIX TWO
SIX FIVE SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
YES YES. OKAY I DON'T WANT TO
BE A VICTIM OF HOMICIDE I THINK
OAKLAND- AFTER THE PRIMARIES
AND YOU KNOW AFTER YOU MOVE TO
THE NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE FOR EIGHTY SIX FOUR
EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
WITH A NO ON THE- ALL RIGHT
LET'S NOT USE. SO NINE FIVE
TWELVE FIVE ONE TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIVE ONE TWO DO HAVE A
POSITION ON SB SIXTEEN. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE PRESS MODERATOR.
THANK YOU I DO SHOW SEVEN MORE
LINES WAITING TO SHARE THEIR
POSITION ON SB. SIXTY THE NEXT
CALLER. APOLOGIZE MISTER WE
HAVE SEVERAL IN Q. STILL- WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM WITH
THEIR LINE NUMBER IS.
THANK YOU
WILL TRY LINE FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
SITES ARE BEGINNING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORTED SB
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BORDERLINE FIVE NINETY THREE
FIVE NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON
MR MEMBERS BETWEEN THIS IS
BRITNEY BAR STUDY WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG PART OF
THAT THE SIXTEENTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE THREE OH EIGHT
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY CAROLINA'S
OPEN. FIVE THREE OH A IS YOUR
PHONE ON MUTE. BERMAN BONTA
LINE SIX SEVENTEEN SIX ONE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRIS PLAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE FIVE MORE IN Q. BLIND
FIVE FORTY FOUR NO FIVE
FOLKLORIST TAKEN THEMSELVES OUT
OF Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANK
YOU MR OF THE REST ALLIANCE
HAVE REMOVED THEMSELVES
OURIMBAH THANK YOU LET'S MOVE
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ARE A
PRINCIPLE OPPONENT ON THE PHONE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR. NOT THAT
I'M AWARE OF ALL RIGHT LET ME
ASK IN THE GALLERY I SEE
THERE'S SEVERAL INDIVIDUALS IN
THE GALLERY ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTEEN IN THE
GALLERY. SINGLE AND MOVING THE
MICROPHONE LET'S TURN TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. SIXTEEN.
SHE'D MOVED TO THE MICROPHONE I
SEE NO ONE MOVING THE
MICROPHONE. ALL RIGHT. SO LET'S
BRING IT BACK HERE THE CHAMBER
QUESTIONS I SEE NO QUESTIONS OR.
OKAY THIS LET LET'S GO TO PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTEEN WHERE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO WE JUST
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
STATEMENT. WE'LL START WITH
LINE FIVE EIGHTY FOUR FIVE
EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RON RAPP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION I'M ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SIXTEEN THANK
YOU THINK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
THE LINE. THREE TWENTY THREE
TWO ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE.
FIVE SIXTY SIX FIVE SIX SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN YES WE CAN.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO BE A
VICTIM OF HOMICIDE I OPPOSE.
ALL RIGHT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ALIGN THREE TWENTY THREE TWO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
KATHY O'GRADY BASKETBALL
CALIFORNIA I'M OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. PLAN. FOR
EIGHTY SIX FOUR EIGHT SIX.
TWENTY WITH ANY PAIN FROM
CHRONIC CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU- MISTER
MODERATOR- THIS IS SB SIXTEEN
SO WE HAVE TO BE CERTAIN THAT
THE FOLKS WHO ARE VOICING THEIR
OPINIONS ARE VOICING IT ON S.
B. SIXTEEN. GREAT GIPSON WANT
ONE ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
QUEUE. WE ARE TAKEN OPPOSITION
FOR SB SIXTY. WE WILL GO. NEXT
TO LINE FIVE SEVENTY ONE FIVE
SEVEN ONE NINE ONE IS OPEN.
THEY NEED TO FALL. BY UP HELLO
SENATE SIXTEEN BILL. THANK YOU.
FOUR NINE FIVE SEVEN EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MAX CARRY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION MOST IMPORTANTLY
MAINTAIN OUR MOST AMENDED
PETITION AT THIS TIME WELL I
THINK THE AUTHORS CONTINUE
COLLABORATION ON THIS CAN LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING TO
THE END. OUTSTANDING ISSUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OVERLAND
FIVE FORTY THREE IN FIVE FOUR
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. I OPPOSE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
EIGHT FOUR FOUR EIGHT FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN I UPLOAD I OPPOSE
THIS BILL DINO DONAHUE VALENCIA
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER AT THIS TIME I'M BERNARD
ALLIANCE IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS I SEE NO MICROPHONES
REYES- SUTTER SKINNER YOU CARE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU- CHAIR I'M
NOT SURE THAT SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUAL COLORS REALLY- KNEW
WHETHER THEY WERE SPEAKING TO
THIS PARTICULAR BILL BUT I WE
CAN LEAVE IT AT THAT- I
APPRECIATE THE POLICE CHIEFS
CALLING IN AND YES WE ARE
CONTINUING OUR CONVERSATIONS
THERE ARE A FEW- SECTIONS OF
THE BILL SUCH AS THE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS AND THE
LENGTH OF YEARS FOR RETENTION
THAT- IN THERE MAYBE A FEW
OTHERS BUT- THAT- THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ADDRESSED. AND I.
COMMIT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM SO THAT I HOPE WE CAN GET
THEM IN A BETTER PLACE BECAUSE-
THEY WERE SUPPORTIVE OF
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AND I WOULD
LIKE TO GET THEM THERE FOR
THIS. SO WELL I CAN'T GUARANTEE
IT I CERTAINLY WILL WORK ON IT-
I WANTED TO HAVE- JUST IN MY
CLOTHES REFERENCE THAT EVEN
WITH THE EXPANSION THAT THIS
BILL DOES THE NEW CATEGORIES OF
RECORDS THAT WE WOULD BE
ENTITLED TO IT STILL LEAVES
CALIFORNIA AND OUT LIAR
COMPARED TO MANY OTHER STATES
FOR EXAMPLE NEW YORK ALL
RECORDS RELATED TO POLICE
OFFICER ACTION ALL ARE NOW
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC
LEGALLY. GEORGIA OHIO FLORIDA
KENTUCKY WASHINGTON HAVE VERY
FEW RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT
RECORDS THE PUBLIC CAN ACCESS
CAL AS I'VE INDICATED
CALIFORNIA IS STILL AN OUTLIER
ADDITIONALLY THE EXPANSION ON
THE CATEGORIES OF USE OF FORCE
THAT THIS BILL ALLOWS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- UNDER. UNDER
CURRENT LAW. THE ONLY KINDS OF
USE OF FORCE THAT WE COULD GET
X. ACCESS TO ARE THOSE THAT
WOULD BE DEFINED AS DEADLY NOW
IF WE TAKE CARE OF THEIR
CHILDREN FOR EXAMPLE WHO IS
UNDER TRIAL NOW. D. WHAT'S COME
OUT IN THE PRESS IS THAT THEIR
JOB AND HAD A HISTORY. OF
VARIOUS USE OF FORCE. PAST
ALLEGATIONS NONE OF WHICH
RESULTED THAT I'M AWARE OF ANY
DEATHS. THE NONE THAT WERE
CHARACTERIZED AS DEADLY SO IN
OTHER WORDS WE WOULD NOT WE NOR
THE POLICE AGENCY IN IN- HIRING
DIRECTOR OF AN FOR EXAMPLE WE
WOULD NOT KNOW. HAVE ANY ACCESS
TO HIS PAST RECORD OF THE TYPES
OF USE OF FORCE THAT IS NOW
BEEN DEMONSTRATED THAT HE
WOULD. VERY COMMONLY USED. WHAT
SB SIXTEEN DOES IS GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO SEE WHEN AN OFFICER
HAS SUSTAINED FINDINGS OF
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE- AND
WITH THAT. I HOPE THAT YOU
WOULD GIVE ME- I THOUGHT. I WAS
GONNA- SIR MOTION SIR THE
RUSSELL MOST OF. SB SIXTEEN
BANSHEE COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL. OR IS THAT THE
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
PLAYED MOTION BY CENTER THAT I
SELL NOT THE MISSION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI. AMBER GUY BORJAS. NOT
VOTING AT ALL I CAMBIADO I DID
ALSO. DID I SO I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG JONES. NOT
VOTING LAYERED HI LAYERED HI
STERN. WHY CASKEY HI WHY CASKEY
I WIENER. YOU HAS SIX RIGHT NOW
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL VEGAS IS GONNA THANK YOU
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO SENATOR
PAN LET ME MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
HERE. BECAUSE THE UNUSUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH WE'RE
OPERATING HERE IN THE CAPITAL-
IN IN CONSULTATION WITH SENATOR
JONES WITH RESPECT TO S. B.
THREE NINE SEVEN WE'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING THAT IS- OUTSIDE
THE USUAL PROTOCOL. SB THREE
NINE SEVEN IS GOING TO BE TAKEN
OUT OF ORDER AFTER THREE
O'CLOCK SO WHATEVER BILLS BEING
PRESENTED THREE O'CLOCK WE'RE
GONNA CONCLUDE THAT BILL AND
NEVER GONNA TAKE UP SB THREE
NINETY SEVEN. AFTER THAT BILL
CONCLUDES- THAT'S TO THE
BENEFIT OF THOSE WHO ARE ON THE
PHONE MAYBE SOME OF THOSE WHO
ARE WAITING HERE IN THE CAPITAL
JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME-
DEFINITION AS TO WHAT WE THINK
THE AFTERNOON HOLDS IN TERMS
OF. TIME AND PROCESS. ALL RIGHT-
CENTER PAN THANK YOU FOR
WAITING. SB SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
CHAIR ON BURGER SENATORS- I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SEVENTEEN
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH AN OFFICE
OF RACIAL EQUITY AND RACIAL
EQUITY ADVISED ACCOUNTABILITY
COUNCIL IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC AND INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM HAS RESULTED IN POOR
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND DISPARITIES%
IN THE STATE. I DO WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF HERE DISHER
COMMITTEE YOU I THINK DID AN
EXCELLENT- SUMMARY AND WRITE UP
OF THE ISSUES THAT THIS BILL
IS- TRYING TO ADDRESS THE LONG
HISTORY OF- RACISM AND
DISPARITIES THAT WE'VE SEEN AND
NOT ONLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY AND THIS BILL IS LONG
OVERDUE AND AS A DOWN PAYMENT
TOWARDS STATE PLAYING A MORE
ACTIVE ROLE IN DISMANTLING OVER
THREE HUNDRED YEARS OF RACIAL
INEQUALITIES. IN ENDING
SYSTEMIC RACISM CENTER RESEARCH
IDENTIFIED RACISM IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS LEADING TO
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH DISPARITIES
INCLUDING INFANT MATERNAL
MORTALITY CRISIS HE'S
PREVALENCE LIFE EXPECTANCY AND
NOW COBIT MORTALITY. AND WELL
OUR STATE HAS MADE EFFORTS
TECHNOLOGY CONFRONT RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN RECENT YEARS
EQUITY IS OFTEN BEEN TREATED AS
AN AFTERTHOUGHT OR IS A SILENT
STRATEGY IT IS NOT ENOUGH JUST
TO DECLARE RACISM AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THE STATE NEEDS
AN INDEPENDENT BODY TO HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE BY EXAMINIG
CALIFORNIA'S POLICIES AND
BUDGET WITH THE GOAL OF
ACHIEVING RACIAL EQUITY AND
ENDING SYSTEMIC RACISM. THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH AN OFFICE
OF RACIAL EQUITY TO LEAD THIS
WORK IN A POWER TO STATE TO
IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENT RACIAL
EQUITY FRAMEWORK SB SEVENTEEN
IS SPONSORED BY THE ADVANCE
PARTY CALIFORNIA. COMMITTEE
COALITION GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE NEXT GEN POLICY
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES AND
SEIU STATE COUNCIL AND IS
SUPPORTED BY A WIDE ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING LABOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ADVOCATES
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZATIONS
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THE STATE
ANALYSIS HI HAVE AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND ADD CO AUTHORS
EXPECT WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS B. SEVENTEEN AND IN
SUPPORT I DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WHO I BELIEVE ARE IN THE
GALLERY. DANIELLE. LAFAYETTE
COMMITTEE MEMBER OF THE- AND
JAKE AT PAUL ADVISER WITH
COMING BURKE AND BURLING. HE ON
BEHALF OF THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR PAN IF OF MR LEVINE IS HERE
IF I WOULD ASK. THAT HE MOVED
TO THE MICROPHONE. IN NO NO
WITH DANIELLE LEFT YET AS WELL
I SEE MR LEVINE AND IF MISS OF
LAFAYETTE IS HERE IF SHE WOULD
MOVE TOWARD THE MICROPHONE AS
WELL. BUT INSTEAD OF PAYING THE
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED YES THANK THANK YOU.
HI THIS LEVINE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS TWO MINUTES CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. I AM HONORED TO
SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTEEN AS AN ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE ONE OF THE BILL'S
LEAD SPONSORS. CALIFORNIA IS
KNOWN WORLDWIDE AS A LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY FROM HAVING THROWN
OPEN ITS DOORS TO FREE SPIRITS
AND ENTREPRENEURS TO BEING A
WELCOMING HOME TO THOSE WHO ARE
DIFFERENT. BUT THE STATE ALSO
HAS A DARKER AND EQUALLY LONG
HISTORY OF PERPETUATING DEEP
RACIAL AND ETHNIC INEQUITIES
THAT PERSIST TODAY. TAKEOVER
NINETEEN FOR BUT ONE RECENT
EXAMPLE THE VIRUS HAS LAID BARE
INEXCUSABLE AND I'M JUST
DISPARITIES AND INEQUITIES IN
ACCESS TO BASIC RIGHTS SUCH AS
CLEAN AIR AND SAFE HOUSING.
ATTORNEYS OF COLOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPOSED TO
AIR POLLUTION AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEARING THE
BURDEN OF UNAFFORDABLE HOUSING
HAVE BEEN MORE VULNERABLE TO
RESPIRATORY DISEASE PREYED ON
FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES AND
THEIR CENTRAL JOBS. BUT EVEN AS
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE INJUSTICES
WE'LL OUT OF VACCINE ROLLOUT TO
OSSIFIED THEM FURTHER FOR
EXAMPLE QUALITY NO CALIFORNIANS
HAVE SUFFERED 47% OF COVERT
NINETEEN DEATHS. THEY HAVE ONLY
RECEIVED 23% OF THE
VACCINATIONS THESE BURDENS
HARDLY A COMPREHENSIVE
ACCOUNTING HAVE ALSO COMPOUNDED
THE WEALTH GAP THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN WHITE CALIFORNIANS AND
CALIFORNIANS OF COLOR. THESE
RACIAL INEQUITIES ARE NOT
SPONTANEOUS THEY'RE THE
PRODUCTS OF DECADES OF
GOVERNMENT POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT HAVE BOTH FAILED
TO ADDRESS THEM AND HAVE
AFFIRMATIVELY ADVANCED AND- NOW
GOVERNMENT HAS A CRUCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO LEAD THE
REPAIR. THAT IS THE WORK THAT
SB SEVENTEEN BEGINS IT PROVIDES
A THOUGHTFUL STRUCTURE FOR
GOVERNMENT TO IDENTIFY SOLVE
FOR AND ULTIMATELY DISMANTLE
RACIAL INEQUITY. SB SEVENTEEN
ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE OF
RACIAL EQUITY IT WOULD CREATE
AN INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY DRIVEN
FRAMEWORK AND A COORDINATED
APPROACH AMONG STATE AGENCIES
TO PROMOTE EQUITABLE OUTCOMES
AND TO USE DATA TO EVALUATE ITS
OWN PROGRESS. AS WE CONFRONT
THE FULL SCOPE OF RACIAL
DISPARITIES AND INEQUITIES BY
POCK CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE ON
A DAILY BASIS THIS BILL IS A
COMMITMENT TO GUARD AGAINST
THEM AND TO REVERSE THEM. I
WOULD BE PLEASED TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MR. LEVINE MISS
LAFAYETTE. I SEE MISS LAFAYETTE
MOVING TO THE MICROPHONE.
FLOOR'S YOURS WAS LAFAYETTE.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANIELLE
LAFAYETTE AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
SOUTH LOS ANGELES THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
MY TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTEEN DESPITE HOW MEDIA
PORTRAYS THROUGHOUT THE LATE WE
ARE GREAT AND FAMILY CENTER
COMMUNITY I'M A GRASSROOTS
LEADER WITH COMMUNITY COALITION
A SOCIAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATION
ANKLES PROCTOR SB SEVENTY. I AM
NATION AN ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON YOUTH LEADERSHIP AND
ECONOMIC APARTMENT. I AM HERE
TODAY TO UP WITH MY FATHER AN
HONOR MY FATHER LEON LAFAYETTE
JUNIOR WHO INSTILLED IN ME. THE
IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION AND
FIGHTING FOR JUSTICE MY FATHER
WAS A VIETNAM WAR VETERAN. WHO
SACRIFICE FOR THIS COUNTRY ONLY
TO RETURN FROM THE WAR IN FACE
DISCRIMINATION. HE ALSO CAME
BACK TO A WAR ZONE WITHIN HIS
OWN BACKYARD BECAUSE OF THE
RACIST POLICIES AND PRACTICES
LIKE THE WAR ON DRUGS.
REDLINING AND EDUCATIONAL
SEGREGATION. OUR FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN TORN APART BY THE MOST BY
THE SORRY OUR FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN TORN APART BY THE
MILITARIZATION OF OUR POLICE
FORCE WE ARE HOME TO ONE OF THE
HIGHEST HOMELESS POPULATION TO
THE STATE. MOST OF US ARE
SUFFERING FROM TRAUMA AND
CHRONIC STRESS. MY FATHER
EXPERIENCED ALL THESE
CONDITIONS WHILE ALSO SUFFERING
FROM PTSD BECAUSE OF THE WAR.
MY DAD HAD A CHANCE TO REACH
ITS FULL POTENTIAL HE WAS
ACCEPTED INTO AN ELITE
UNIVERSITY BUT ITS POTENTIAL
BLESSED MAX WITH WITH THE
RESOURCES HE NEEDED TO SUCCEED
DUE TO RACIST POLICIES. INSTEAD
HE WAS REPEATEDLY MET WITH THE
JAIL CELL FEDERAL O MERELY
PASSED AWAY. MY FAMILY I LIVE
WITHOUT HER EVERY DAY. I AM
ALSO HERE MY SO. BECAUSE I WANT
THEM TO HAVE A BRIGHT FUTURE
THAT I KNOW THEY ARE CAPABLE OF
GET OUR SCHOOLS. CONTINUE TO
UNDER CONTINUE TO BE UNDER
FUNDED CRIMINALIZE BLACK
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY OUR BOYS AS
A DAUGHTER AND AS A MOTHER THIS
IS EXHAUSTING AND UNFAIR. I AM
TIRED OF CONSTANTLY FIGHTING
AGAINST AND EXPERIENCING
RACISM. CALL THE NINETEEN HAS
ONLY MADE RACIAL INEQUALITY
MORE APPARENT AND WORSE. I ASK
YOU TO PASS SB SEVENTEEN TO
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY. THANK YOU. TAKEN AS
LAFAYETTE. OF ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE YOUR IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE MOVE THE MICROPHONE.
SAYING NO MOVEMENT TO THE
MICROPHONE MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD- QUEUE UP THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINE PROVIDE THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND THE
POSITION. ON S. B. SEVENTEEN.
AND LAYS IN GERMAN- IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO REVIVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN THIS B. SEVENTEEN.
THIS PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO PRESS THE
SEVENTEEN- I KNOW HOW. AND AT
THIS TIME IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO
HAVE ABOUT THIRTY IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT. BUT MR MODERATOR I'M
GOING TO TURN OVER THE GAVEL TO
CENTER BOARD JUST- I HAVE TO
PRESENT ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
CENTREBOARD JUST. LATER WE'RE
ON THOSE IS CLOSER TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES. WHERE ARE WE GOING TO
RECESS. THE ONLY ONE RIGHT NOW
FOR YOU.
THANK THERE WE GO.
MODERATOR WE HAVE A- NEW
INDIVIDUAL PRESIDING AS CHAI
SO- WILL BE MOVING ON TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE LIP
SERVICE CAN YOU TELL ME AGAIN
HOW MANY WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE.
YES AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN IN THE QUEUE.
THIRTY SEVEN. OKAY ALL RIGHT IF
YOU PLEASE PROMPT THEM TO A- OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVENTEEN LET'S BEGIN. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL START WITH NUMBER
TWO THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER SIX TWENTY EIGHT OF SIX
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE KEEP AN- MY
NAME TO MY MOUNTAIN ONE. TOTAL
NUMBER THE NUMBER IS THREE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JENNIFER LAURIE FROM
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO BE NUMBER THREE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND RELATE ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SORRY I'M-
I'M TURNING RIGHT NOW YEAH.
WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE-
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER. FIVE FIVE
FOUR FIVE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
COUNTY DOWN OFTEN REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. DO WE TELL THE
MODERATOR NUMBER TWO FIFTEEN
FOR THE WITH THE TELL HIM. THE
NEXT TO BE NUMBER SIX FIFTY ONE
SIX FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
SENATE BILL SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPEED SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
NEXT WE NUMBER FOUR TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER FOUR
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE ON TO NUMBER THREE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETY THREE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE'LL MVE
TO LINE IT SIX SIX SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE SIX SIX SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHO TO LINE FOR
TWENTY ONE OF FOUR TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE TO
LINE FOR EIGHTEEN FOR EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NOW MOVES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNT ALL OF THE HEALTH
EDUCATION AND ALSO TO TELL.
POLLUTION OR- CAN OU REPEAT
THAT I COULDN'T HEAR YOU.
MORNING COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
HEALTH AGENCIES AND ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRAT COALITION.
THE COURT. NEXT TO THE NUMBER
SIX EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS DALE BERMAN
WITH THE SOLEMN WHITE COUNCIL
AND HIESTAND IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
IT'S A MODERATELY NUMBER
UNIFORM THAT- CALLER THAT HE
MAY HAVE BEEN CALLING IN ON A
DIFFERENT BILL. ABSOLUTELY.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER SIX EIGHTY
FOUR OF PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY
MILITARY MEMBERS HOLD SCORED
WITH THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA
ENDURANCE SPORT. THE NEXT WE
HAVE LINE SIX SIX SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIX SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE NEXT OF THE NUMBER
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE AN EQUAL RIGHT
ADVOCATES STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A LINE OF
FIVE FIFTY FIVE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE NINE SEVEN. MOTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE- INFORM THAT COLOR THAT
THAT WAS A WRONG- BILL THAT
SHE'S REFERRING TO. ABSOLUTELY
AND- ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVENTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AGAIN SB SEVENTEEN.
SEVERAL. THE NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT IS FOR THE SB. THREE
NINE SEVEN. TIME AND THIS IS
FOR SB SEVENTEEN. NOR MISTER
MODERATOR I THINK WE MAY HAVE
TO REMIND FOLKS THAT WE ARE ON
S. B. SEVENTEEN I THINK WE'RE
GETTING A NUMBER OF CALLERS ARE
REFERENCING OTHER BILLS SO THIS
IS SENATE BILL SEVENTEEN IN THE
AUTHOR IS PANDA SENATOR PAM.
YES AND NO ONCE AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT ON S. B. SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN S.
B. SEVENTEEN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. OPPOSITION SO.
AT AROUND AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIX SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE NINE SIX SEVEN THREE
KM ST. FOR THREE NINETY SEVEN
AND MAY NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THE NEXT IN THE
QUEUE OF THE NUMBER FIVE SIXTY
SIX- PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. I OPPOSE SB
SEVENTEEN BECAUSE I DON'T
BELIEVE ACHIEVEMENT NEEDS TO BE
LEGISLATED EVERYONE WOULD JUST
YOU KNOW THANK YOU MA'AM REALLY
WATER IT. CAN YOU PLEASE- SEE
IF WE CAN MAKE CERTAIN THAT THE
COLORS ARE AWARE THAT WE ARE ON
S. B. SEVENTEEN- THAT IS BY
SENATOR PAN IN WE ARE IN THE
SUPPORT. OF PHASE OF PUBLIC
COMMENT. ONLY IF YOU WERE
SUPPORTING SB SEVENTEEN WOULD
THIS BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU
TO QUEUE UP. AND ONCE AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT OF S. P. SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO- THE NEXT
SO WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE WILL BE
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FOUR. THIS
GUY HAD. I'M OPPOSED TO S. B.
ALL. SEVENTEEN THE- NEXT NUMBER
WE HAVE IN QUEUE OF THE LINE TO
THIRTY THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER CURRENTLY IN THE QUEUE.
PLEASE CONTINUE MR. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO- LOU THE SUPPORT
PORTION OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT
FIVE FOLLOWING THE SAME PROCESS
WE'RE GOING HERE NOW FROM THE
OPPOSITION- IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION- WITNESSES OR TO ME-
IMMEDIATE IN PERSON OR REMOTE
OPPOSITION THIS BILL I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE. IS SEEING NONE.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SEVENTEEN. I
SEE A COUPLE OF INDIVIDUALS IN.
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ANY OF YOU
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
S. B. SEVENTEEN PLEASE APPROACH
THE LECTERN. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING THE LECTERN WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WAY TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATE YOU
COULD PLEASE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN TESTIFYING
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
SEVENTEEN LET'S BEGIN.
ABSOLUTELY AND NOW ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION- S. B. SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
SEVENTEEN. PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. A MODERATE IF YOU WHEN
YOU GET A TALLY IF YOU COULD
LET US KNOW. YEAH AT THIS TIME
IT LOOKS LIKE THE TWO OF ABOUT.
SEVENTEEN IN THE QUEUE. OKAY AS
WE DID BEFORE WE ALLOTTED
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL TO
THOSE EXPRESSING OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE LINE. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION OF OPPOSITION
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN BEGIN THE
QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
THREE OH FOUR THREE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE END OF
MORE THAN L. GENERATION MEXICAN
AMERICAN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THAT. THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AS NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL
MOVE ON TO NUMBER THREE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER OF THREE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TAPIO GRADING
COMPATIBLE CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
SB SEVENTEEN. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE THREE FIFTEEN THREE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MERCY A WILSON I AM A
CONCERNED CITIZEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SEVENTEEN CANNOT
LEGISLATE. AT ANY KIND OF MARIE
MONEY MANAFORT MA'AM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT WAS WE ONLY NEED
YOUR NAME AND POSITION AND
AFFILIATION THANK YOU. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER THREE THREE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MARK NO NGUYEN FROM
FOUNTAIN VALLEY AND I OPPOSE
SENATE BILL SEVENTEEN. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT OF THE LINES SIX
SEVEN SEVEN ONE SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS.
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVED TO LINE
FIVE SEVENTEEN FIVE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHELLE GONZALEZ NAIL
I REPRESENT MYSELF AS WELL AS
THE LINES TO PROTECT CHILDREN
AND WE OPPOSE SB SEVENTEEN. AND
MIND JUST FIVE POUNDS BILLS.
THE NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
SIXTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS ME LEVINE FIRST
GENERATION OF ASIAN AMERICANS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS HORRIBLE
BILL FROM SENATOR PAN. THE NEXT
WILL BE GOING TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL YES THIS IS JASON ANDERSON
WITH ATASCADERO CALIFORNIA ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. SEVENTY MIX
OF THE NUMBER FIVE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES I CAN HEAR YOU. OUR AYE
OPPOSED S. B. SEVENTEEN MY NAME
IS BERNADETTE XING IN FOSTER
CITY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT NUMBER THREE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JOANNE IS THE DOOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVENTEEN.
OUR NEXT OVER THE LINE SIX
FIFTY SIX SIX FIVE SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY THIS IS A
MARONITE DAY ON MONDAY MAY
GRANT FROM THE FROM MEXICO AND
I LIVE IN AN JOSE CALIFORNIA
NINE EXTREMELY OPPOSED THE SAYS
THE. SEVENTEEN NEXT LILLE
NUMBER SIX NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
IRENE HATFIELD IN AYE OPPOSED
SB. SEVENTEEN NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO OH FOUR TWO OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
GLORIA TREVINO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. SENATE BILL. SEVENTEEN
THE NEXT TO BE LINED THREE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THREE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE TO LINE OF FIVE
EIGHTEEN FIVE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE HAZELTON CENTER
IN CALIFORNIA NATIVE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. SEVENTEEN
SIX OF THE LINE TO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS ROBIN
ELLIS AT THE TOP IN MY COUNCIL
AND AYE OPPOSED SB. SEVENTEEN
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER SIX
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS CAROL APPEL A STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. SEVENTEEN NEXT OF
THE NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON WITH THE CHAIR INCOME
LEADING MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARCELLA CLARK I AM FROM CHINO
CALIFORNIA I AM AN IMMIGRANT
FROM SOME THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ABOVE THE DOOR IN CENTRAL
AMERICA AND I STRONGLY AND
FIRMLY OPPOSE SB SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WILL BE
FINE THREE HUNDRED THREE
HUNDRED PLEASE GOOD. HI MY NAME
IS D'ELIA- AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. SEVENTEEN. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER FIVE FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARLENA DO
PLANE FROM CAPITOLA CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
SEVENTY NEXT WILL BE NUMBER SIX
FIFTY SEVEN GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JULIA READ ALL I'M A NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB. SEVENTEEN EXCELL MOVED TO
LINE FOR TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS KAREN POWERS
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE NUMBER
SEVEN OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND IT IS ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVENTEEN MARTIN ADOPTED
ITS ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL SUPPORT SB
SEVENTY THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER SIX SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ACTUALLY FOR
SUPPORT AS WELL- VENGEFUL USE
ON BEHALF OF PREVENTION
INSTITUTE WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB SEVENTEEN.
HOMEOWNERS WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT- WE INFORM THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE IN THE QUEUE TO CALL
IN THAT THIS IS S. B. SEVENTEEN
SENATOR PAN WE ARE ONLY DOING
OPPOSITION- WITNESS-
TELECONFERENCE- STATEMENTS
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MONEY HELLO I
TELL L. CONSENT TO CREATE A
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. SEVENTY NOW MOVED
ON NUMBER SEVEN TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JIMMY G.
AND THE FIRST GENERATION
IMMIGRANT AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB. SEVENTEEN SIX OF THE
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS STACY
PASCAL FAMILY- AND MIXED RACE
FAMILY AND CITY OF SACRAMENTO
STRONGLY AND ADAMANTLY OPPOSED
TO SB SEVENTEEN. THE NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER SEVEN FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY LEVIN'S LINE
SEVEN FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. ALL
MOVED TO NUMBER SEVEN OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN MEMBERS JUSTIN MORAN OF
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH
THE PHONE LINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO ONLY FOR OPPOSITION.
OKAY AND WE'LL MVE TO NUMBER
SIX THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS A COUPLE CONTRA
MURRIETA CALIFORNIA AND- IT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY OPPOSE SENATE
BILL. SEVENTEEN NEXT WE'LL MOVE
TO LINE. TO WRONG WAY OPPOSE AT
LEAST. SEVENTEEN NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER SEVEN SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE I WAS IN
QUEUE TO SUPPORT AND WORKING
NOT CALLED ON SO MY NAME IS
MADELINE COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET MORE ON BUT OF THE OF
SAN AND- THANK YOUNG. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER FOUR TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LEON NEAL REGISTERED
NURSE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY
NAME IS GINNY PAIN FROM CHRONIC
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO NUMBER SEVEN TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I TOLD SUPPORT LINE RENDON
ANNOUNCED AND A HALF BUT
ADVANCE PROJECT HOW PART
BECAUSE AT SEVEN WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THE NEW IN MODERATOR
BECAUSE WE HAD SOME. ISSUES
EARLY. WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE SAID ASIDE SOME TIME SO
IF WE DO A CALL. THAT ARE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT- WE'RE TO ADD
GONNA ALLOW MAN I STILL AT THE
EDGING FIFTEEN MINUTE- FOR EACH
SIDE. IT'S TO SIGNAL.
ABSOLUTELY NO WE HAVE NUMBERS
THIRTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELEVEN
WITH THE FULL LAKE AND I AM
JEWISH AND I STRONG OPPOSE S.
B. SEVENTEEN. NEXT WE'LL MOVE
LINE. SEVEN PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO
SIR BRAMBLES ON THE OF THE
TEACHERS. WE ARE SUPPORT FOR
JUNIOR HIGH VOTE. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF FIVE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO TO NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS NICHOLAS MCCARTY SANDY
OF CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO SP SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY NUMBER TWO SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MICHELLE MARTINEZ ALKA CAL. THE
FIRST PERUVIAN AND IF OF THE
AND MIGHT. I STRONG OPPOSE AND.
SEVEN WELL NOW THEY'RE GOING TO
NUMBER THREE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CADENTIAL LISTER I OPPOSE. WELL
NOW MOVES TO LINE SEVEN FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THERE'S A
LOT. MOVE ON TO NUMBER FIVE
SIXTY SIX FIVE SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR WE CAN HEAR
YOU- I STRONGLY OPPOSE. I AM A
TAIWANESE AMERICAN AYE OPPOSED
THIS BILL THAT EVENTUALLY
PRETTY MUCH JUST CHANCE ALL THE
COMING MEMBERS. NAMES OF. AND
VISIT. THANK YOU. WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER FIVE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
WELL NOW MOVES TO LINE SEVEN
THIRTY SIX SEVEN THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
TINA O'DONOGHUE I AM AN IRISH
CHEROKEE AND I BROWN OPPOSE
THIS BILL. NEXA THE NUMBER SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CLAUDIA TAYLOR CONSTITUTIONAL
CITIZENS NEVADA COUNTY. HI
OPPOSE THIS BECAUSE IT'S FREE
TO DOUBTS. NEXT OVER THE LINE
SEVEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. NEXT
VS NUMBER SEVEN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEMBERS- IN THE CENTER
AREA WITH NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXA
THE NUMBER FIVE FORTY TWO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLAN FIVE
FORTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. WILL
MOVE TO NUMBER SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LIBBY SANCHEZ CI YOU.
PROUD COACH. IN STRONG OF THE
MEASURE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARE BARBER ORGIES AND
HE'LL TEACH CALIFORNIA OPPOSE
SB. SEVENTEEN THE- ANNEX OF THE
NUMBERS TO NINE PLEASE AHEAD.
YES HELLO- I NEED ANYTHING ON
YOUR A IN ON AM FROM COUNTY I.
MOTOR CAN YOU CAN THERE'S
THERE ARE NO FURTHER THE QUEUE
ASSEMBLY HIJINKS WE WISH WE
WOULD LIKE TO APOLOGISE THERE
WAS- THERE WERE SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. THAT OPPOSITION
WHEN INTO THE SUPPORT CATEGORY
AND VICE VERSA IF ANY
INDIVIDUAL WAS INDEED CUT OFF
CAN YOU PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR-
OPINIONS OF VIA EMAIL- TO
SENATE JUDICIARY WEBSITE IT
WILL TAKE THOSE INTO
CONSIDERATION ONCE AGAIN WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE TECHNICAL
HICCUP BUT I THINK WE HAVE-
MADE ALLOWANCES FOR THE EXTRA
TIME. SO WITH THAT. WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS. COLLEAGUES CENTER
GONZALEZ YES THANK YOU- SENATOR
BORDERS I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
SENATOR PAN FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THIS IS A WONDERFUL A
BILL IN MY OPINION CERTAINLY
MUCH NEEDED I'D ALSO LIKE TO
COMMEND THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
OR THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
ANALYSIS SO- CHIEF THE COUNCIL
THIS WAS A WONDERFUL JOB ONCE
ONCE AGAIN THE OTHER TIME THAT
I FOUND ANOTHERANALYSIS- JUST
RIGHT ON TARGET WAS THE- THE
ONE FOR REPARATIONS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN CALIFORNIANS AND SO
FOR THAT I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO YOU AS WELL AND- AGAIN.
SENATOR PAN I KNOW I'M A CO
AUTHOR BUT HAPPY TO CONTINUE
HELPING YOU GET THAT THIS
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU CENTER
WOULD HAVE. YEAH I'D LIKE I'D
LIKE TO CALL A- ALISON MEREDITH
IN THE FINE STAFF TO CHEESE
MADE ON- DETAILING. OUR
CHECKERED HIS THAT WE HAVE CAL
WITH THE MOVE BILL. ANY OTHER
MEMBER WISHING TO COMMON ON
THIS. SUTTER PAIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I THANK YOU AYE
AYE TO ACTUALLY WANT TO THE TO
DETER THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE ANALYSIS- I THINK- I WE CAN
GET CAUGHT OUT THERE TO READ IT
THIS SIDE ON THE BILL- I THINK
CERTAINLY MAKES THE CASE- FOR
THE IMPORTANCE SB SEVENTY IN
FACT I ENCOURAGE ANYONE PEOPLE
WHO SPOKE AGAIN. THE BILL TO
PLEASE RE OUR UNDER WHY WE NEED
THIS WHAT THE RESPECTFULLY ASK
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER.
AM THIS BILL HAS MOVED BY. WERE
CAL SKI. THE MOTION IS TO PAY.
AS AMENDED. BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. AMENDS PAGES
TWENTY FOUR THROUGH TWENTY SIX
COMMENT NUMBER FIVE CHIEF
COUNSEL CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS SB SEVENTEEN AS
STATED BY SENATOR PAN- BURKE.
GORGEOUS. NOT VOTING FOR BATTLE
I DID ALSO I WRESTLE GONZALEZ I
MONTHS OF I HERTZBERG BY HER BY
JONES NO JONES NO LAYERED ON
LET ICE. WAIT HI WAKE CAL SKI I
WIENER. RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE FOR
FIVE SIX ONE AND HOLDING A- YES
THIS SIX TO ONE THIS WILL BE
PUT ON CALL. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT I THINK- CHIU. I'M BURKE
HAD INDICATED WAS GOING TO BE A
CHANGEOVER IN ORDER THAT WE
WERE GONNA BE MOVING TO.
SENATOR JONES IS BILL. FIRST IS
THAT STILL THE REQUEST. RIGHT
AFTER THAT. SO WHAT SO WE'LL
STAY WITH THE FILE ORDER THEM.
OKAY. YEAH BERMAN FOR NOW THEN
THAT MEANS WILL BE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AND THAT'S
S. B. FORTY FOUR. SENATOR ALAN.
IS SENATOR ALAN.
ALLEN WAS HERE
BURKE. OKAY. COLLEAGUES WHEN WE
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
YOU
FOLKS TO PRESENT BILLS SO
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX COLLEAGUES S. B. FORTY FOUR
SENATOR ALAN. THAT ARE ALL IN
THE FLOOR'S YOURS WELL HI
EVERYBODY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HEARING THIS BILL SB FORTY
FOUR- WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
EXPEDITED SEQUEL REVIEW FOR TO
GREEN TRANSIT PROJECTS. ALSO
REQUIRES THE COURTS RESOLVE
RELATED SEQUEL LAWSUITS WITHIN
TWO TO SEVENTY DAYS. THE KNOW
THE SOONER THE THESE TRANSFORM
INVITE. BENEFICIAL TO PRICE CAN
COMPLETE THIS PROCESS. AND ARE
THE FASTER THE DISPLAY LESSON
POLLUTION INTO READING TRIPS TO
BY. AND VIA. IN ORDER GRANTED
THIS JACKSON OF UNDER THE BILL.
PROJECTS MUST A CAN WITH THE RE
CRISTINA BULL COMMUNITY
STRATEGY TRANSFER PLAN. THEY
HAVE TO OPERATE IT AS ZERO
EMISSIONS. AFTER GREENHOUSE GAS
AND WITHOUT USING A- IN THE
AFTERNOONS- OVERALL VEHICLE MY
TRAVELED IN THE QUARTER WITH
THE PRICE OP. YOU MAY AS BABY
FROM. BOB THE BILL IS EXACTLY
TO LIVE YEAR'S US SEVEN TO
SEVEN WHICH PASSED AWAY BY IT
WAS VETO BECAUSE OF CONTINGENT
UPON ANOTHER BILL. AND THE PRO-
FOUR TIMES BILL. I THAT DID NOT
THE GOVERNOR DESK- IT WASN'T.
OF A PROBLEM THE BILL IT WAS
JUST THAT WAS THERE- WHEN.
ANYWAY I'M THERE WE ARE. WITH
L. A. COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
MODERATE CAN YOU CONFIRM THAT
WE HAVE THEM BOTH ON THE LINE.
YES I DO SHOW BOTH OF THEM ON
THE LINE. ALL RIGHT. OKAY
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
MICHAEL TURNER FROM LA METRO
SHOULD PROCEED. THESE THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AS MICHAEL TURNER WITH
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY I'M LIKE TO CONVEY
OUR BOARD SUPPORT- FOR SB FORTY
FOUR AND THANK SENATOR ALAN FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL- AGAIN FOR
US- SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN WOULD
APPLY STREAMLINED ADDITIONAL
REVIEW PROCESS TO METRO'S FOUR
PILLAR PROJECTS BECAUSE OF THE
GREEN LINE LIGHT RAIL EXTENSION
A TAURUS THE WHAT THE WEST
SANTA ANA BRANCH LINE THE EAST
SIDE GOAL LINE EXTENSION IN THE
SAPULPA TRANSIT QUARTER
PROJECT. THESE FOUR PROJECTS
SERVE AS CLEAN TRANSIT
ALTERNATIVES AND CONNECTORS TO
REGIONAL MOBILITY FOR COMMUTERS
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WHICH IS THE MOST. CONGESTED
REGION IN THE NATION. WITH A
SEVENTY SEVEN METRO WILL BE
ABLE EXCEL THE PROJECT REVIEW
PROCESS BY APPLYING TO SHORTEN
LITIGATION PROCESS TO THE
TRANSIT PROJECTS ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS. AS SENATOR ALAN
MENTION ANY PROCEEDINGS MUST BE
RESOLVED WITHIN TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY DAYS. METRO UNDERSTAND
THAT ENSURING EQUITY IMPROVING
AIR QUALITY AND PROVIDING
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATIONS AND
ROBUST PUBLIC OUTREACH. ARE
ESSENTIAL TOOLS TO SUCCESSFUL
TRANSIT PROJECT DELIVERY
UNFORTUNATELY COSTLY LITIGATION
DELAYS AND DELAYS PROJECT
DELIVERY INSTALL THESE
IMPROVEMENTS FROM BEING
REALIZED. IN OUR BORDERS
PRIORITY THE TOLD. AND TO
ACCELERATE MOBILITY
IMPROVEMENTS AS WE PREPARE TO
HOST THE TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC GAMES
WHILE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
PROJECTS ARE NOT REQUIRED AS A
PART OF THE BID TO SECURE THE
OLYMPIC GAMES THEY WILL HELP TO
ALLEVIATE CONGESTION TO. DUE TO
THE GAME'S IMPROVE ACCESS TO
EVENT VENUES AND ALLOW VISITORS
TO ENJOY ALL THAT L. A. COUNTY
HAS TO OFFER. THESE BEFORE
PROJECTS WOULD DIRECTLY BENEFIT
BENEFIT FROM THE PAST A SENIOR
FROM THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL
ENTER NOT ONLY INTEGRAL TO THIS
PLAN THEIR KEY TO MEETING THE
REGION'S AIR QUALITY GOALS. AS
A MENTION THE PROJECTS WOULD
PRODUCE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
WOULDN'T REDUCE CONGESTION
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
GREENHOUSE EMISSIONS. I LIKE TO
THINK SENATOR ALAN FOR CARRYING
THIS MEASURES AND URGED THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR BEVAN
TELL EM MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
MICHAEL. TURNER ON THE LINE.
SUBMIT CHAIR. ALL ALL THE GOING
NEXT I'M NOT MICHAEL EXEGGUTOR
COULD HELP TRANS THE- BATTING
FOR TO AND JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M JOIN ME ALL DAY OF
BOYS TRANSACTION OF FOR
INTERNET CATCH. FORTY THE CARD.
AT THE BOTTOM LEGISLATION. AS
YOU MAY KNOW MY FROM. FIVE ROAD
AGENCY STATEWIDE. I. LOOTING-
MISTER CHAIR- ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSFERRED AUTHORITY YOUR JUST.
MISTER NO- THIS PUBLISHED AND
IT MEANS JUDGE REVIEW PROCEED
UNDER WHAT FOR VERY NARROW BAND
OF YOU'RE ON THE PICKS. PROJECT
DELIVERY OF THESE PROJECTS
WHICH TRANSFORM REGIONAL
ECONOMIES CREATE GOOD PAYING
JOBS AND CONSTRUCTION AND
TRANSIT OPERATIONS AND HELP
CATALYZE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY WE
KNOW OUR STATE NEEDS RIGHT NOW.
AS WE LOOK TO RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC I AM BILL TOWARD A
MORE SUSTAINABLE FUTURE AS AN
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE. A LONG
HISTORY OF SUPPORTING EFFORTS
TO STREAMLINE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS FOR TRANSIT
PROJECTS I INCLUDING A
SUPPORTING LAST YEAR'S NEARLY
IDENTICAL SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN I
AND AGAIN WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB FORTY FOUR TODAY
AND- TRIED OUT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVING BACK TO
THE SENATE GALLERY DO WE HAVE
ANY. WITNESSES HERE IN THE
SENATE GALLERY. SEEING NONE
MOVING TO ONE TWO. ANY
INDIVIDUAL WISHING FINDS. OF S.
B. FORTY FOUR. I SEE A FEW
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR- ANY OF
YOU WISHING TO. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR PLEASE
APPROACHES THE LECTERN. SEEING
NONE ARE THEY WILL MOVE ON TO
SPORT WITNESS WAITING TESTIFIED
VIA TELECONFERENCE MODERATE IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WITH WHICH WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FOUR WE CAN BEGIN AND
ALSO IF YOU CAN LET ME KNOW HOW
MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE.
ABSOLUTELY AND LATER GERMAN ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF
SB. FORTY FOUR. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE ABOUT SIX IN THE QUEUE.
PLEASE PROCEED. WE WILL START
WITH NUMBER FIVE THIRTEEN-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND YOUR
EMPLOYEE HERE ON A NUMBER ON
BEHALF OF THE NUMBER OF LINES
THAT ARE LISTED IN SUPPORT. SB
FORTY FOR FIRSTLY SELLING
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL RAIL
AUTHORITY DOES NOT COME. LOS
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI I BELIEVE
TO CLIENTS THAT WHICH- THANK
YOU. FOR NUMBER TO NUMBER SEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT SO SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE AHEAD. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN ROBINSON ARE YOUR TO
SHELTER LET. CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE. WRITTEN INTO A CORNER
HOURS ALSO AS CALTRAIN THE
CEMETERY ACCOUNT TRANSIT AND
WELL AS SOLANO TRANSFER TO
AUTHORITY. OR DIRECT VOTER CAN
YOU STILL MAJORITY THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
FIVE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EGGMAN MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL IN THE WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS
YOU'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT. SB.
FORTY FOUR. ANNEX WE NUMBER
FIVE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHOULD
SHARE MEMBERS CHRIS WILSON
REPRESENT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORTER SB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU. OUR MODERATOR CAN
YOU DO A DOUBLE CHECK TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS- WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR.
YES AND- LEADING JOHN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME OR NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR. THANK YOU HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FALL THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE FROM OPPOSITION MODERATOR
I BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
INDIVIDUAL. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ONE RICHARD
MARCUSSEN PLEASE FORGIVE ME IF
THAT IS INCORRECT. NO ACTUALLY
THAT'S COMPLETELY ACCURATE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS WHICH MARKS AND FOR THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WEEK IT IS
CERTAINLY NOT OPPOSED TO THE
TYPE OF PROJECT THAT CENTER
ALAN AND THE SUPPORTERS
ENVISION AS BEING. ELIGIBLE FOR
THE SPECIAL TREATMENT UNDER
ESPY FORTY FOUR. IN FACT WE
COULD STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT.
SEQUEL IS FREQUENTLY USED FOR
PURPOSES THAT ARE NOT RELATED
TO. ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS IN
FACT A NUMBER OF THE SUPPORTERS
OF BOTH LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS
AND ON THE CALL EARLIER TODAY.
SOMETIMES YOU SEE QUIT TO
EXTRACT CONCESSIONS FROM
DEVELOPERS AND PROJECT
PROPONENTS THAT ARE NOT RELATED
TO ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS. WE
CAN DOES OPPOSE LANGUAGE THAT
WE SEE INCREASINGLY SHOW UP IN
LEGISLATION LIKE SB FORTY FOUR.
UNDER EXISTING LAW THERE ARE
SUBSTANTIAL PENALTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH A CONTRACTOR
WHO FAILS TO USE THOSE SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE. HOWEVER
UNDER SB FORTY FOUR WITH A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT. THESE
PROJECTS ARE EXEMPT FROM THESE
PENALTIES WE THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A LEVEL PLAYING
GROUND FOR ENFORCEMENT OF
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE.
AND THE PENALTY SHOULD APPLY
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE EXISTENCE
OF A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT.
LIKEWISE AND POTENTIALLY MORE
CONCERNING FOR MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. UNDER
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT ON AN
SB FORTY FOUR PROJECT. THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER IS
PROHIBITED FROM ENFORCING WAGE
AND HOUR RULES. THAT ARE
FUNDAMENTAL TO THE PROTECTION
OF WORKERS ON CONSTRUCTION JOBS
IN FACT. THE KEY ADMINISTRATIVE
SUBMITTAL THAT IS USED BY
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND OTHERS TO
VERIFY THAT THE CORRECT WAGES
AND BENEFITS HAVE BEEN PAID
WHICH ARE SUBMITTED UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY. CONTRACTORS
UNDER APPEAL A ADDRESS BEFORE
THE FIVE OR SB FORTY FOUR
EXCUSE ME. DON'T HAVE TO KEEP A
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS IN
ADDITION TO DENYING THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ACCESS TO ENFORCE
THE LABOR CODE. WE THINK THAT
SB FORTY FOUR- IS A- A VALUABLE
ADDITION FOR. CONSTRUCTION BUT
WITH THIS THESE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL. WE K. AS OPPOSED TO
IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER MARCUSSEN AND JUST
TO CONFIRM MODERATOR THERE'S
NOT ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS
WISHING TO MAKE. A POSITION
STATEMENT- AT THIS TIME IS THAT
CORRECT NO OTHER WITNESS. YEAH
RIGHT THE. MODERATOR HOLD ON
ONE SECOND I THINK WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S
A SECOND OPPOSITION WITNESS.
AND MODERATOR IF WE DO HAVE A
KATE IN NEED OF FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN THE LINE ON
OPPOSITION. PLEASE- YOU WERE UP.
I DO SHOW SHE'S ON THE LINE-
CASE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE NUMBER HE NEED A
THE PROPOSAL I POLITICS I'M ON
A PLANE RIGHT NOW FULL MAKE MY
TESTIMONY BRIEF. CALVET DOESN'T
HAVE ANY POLICY ISSUES SO OR
OPPOSITION IS LIMITED TO THE
IMPACT OF THE HAVE ON THE COURT.
NOBODY KNOWS THE EXACT UPDATED
THE COLD AT NIGHT AND MAKES WE
ARE FUNCTIONAL UNFORTUNATELY
OPPOSED TO THE GIRLS MARK THE
MANAGER REMOVED THE TWENTIETH.
THAT I DID WAS LOOK LISTEN AND
TO GIVE US MORE TIME FOR WILL
THEY- THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU HAVE A SAY FLIGHT. ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO HERE IN
THIS GAL. ANY WITNESSES IN THE
SENATE GALLERY SEEING NONE.
ANYWAY MOVING ON TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE ANY. INDIVIDUAL WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SB.
FORTY FOUR. NO ONE IS
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE- IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FORTY FOUR
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO- ARE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WAITING
TESTIFIED VIA TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO FORTY FOUR. ANALISA MENTOR
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FORTY FOUR.
TO THE PIER- WE DO HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THE MOMENT. ALL
RIGHT. I WILL GO TO NUMBER SIX
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
POSTED PUBLIC RATED CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE SB FORTY FOUR. THANK
YOU MODERATE CAN YOU DOUBLE
CHECK TO MAKE CERTAIN THERE'S
NO WHETHER INDIVIDUAL WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB.
FORTY FOUR. YES ABSOLUTELY-
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
MORE IN OUR QUEUE. WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER SEVEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES DO YOU KNOW
O'DONOGHUE BALENCIAGA
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THEN
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR KEY OPPOSE. YEAH WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE- THE BILL NOW
MOVES TO LINE. SEVEN EIGHTY. A
LINE SEVEN EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES I AM MY NAME IS
ARGHA SHOPPER RESIDENT OF POINT
CALIFORNIA I'M IN OPPOSITION
NOT ONLY DID THIS BILL BUT TO
THE BUREAUCRATIC MATH THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WORKING
NAME. NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION PLEASE. AND WILL MOVE
TO LINE THREE OH EIGHT HE SAID.
NINE THREE OH EIGHT OF THE
ENERGY CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE. AND AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE-
PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK YOU.
HAVING COMPLETED THE PUBLIC
COMMENT BOTH OPPOSITION AND-
SUPPORTS WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMANI'D LIKE TO-
GRACIOUSLY ASK THE- OFFICE
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IF YOU WOULD
INCLUDE ME IN WHETHER SAID
PRINCIPAL KOHLER JOINTER
WHATEVER I CAN DO TO BE HELPFUL
I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT IF YOU
WOULD STILL APPLY TO ME AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU I'D
BE HONORED TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT
AND- PARTICIPANTS FELT. CENTER
WHAT KASKY. YES SIDE OF A
COUPLE OPPOSITION WHO HAS
RAISED A COUPLE OF POINTS-
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THIS BILL SB FORTY FOUR AND- SB
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN LAST YEAR IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THIS- LANGUAGE
THAT GIVES A FREE PASS UNDER-
THE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS
FROM THE PENALTIES THERE ARE
PROPOSED IN PUBLIC. CONTRACTING
I'M JUST. BUT THE LEAD AUTHOR
TO RESPOND HIS PLEASE THAT
OBJECTION TO THE BILL YEAH I'M
AN AUTHOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO-
ANSWER DIRECTLY OR INCLUDING
YOUR CLOTHES. WHATEVER THE
THIRD TEARS DISCRETION. PLEASE
GO AHEAD OKAY- HI IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I THINK THAT I THINK
THE SENATOR KNOWS- AND WHAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ON BILL AFTER BILL
AFTER BILL- I WILL SAY THAT. IN
THE CASE OF MAJOR TRANSIT
PROJECTS. THEY ARE AT AT THE
END THEY'RE ALWAYS DONE WITH
THE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS
SO- YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK THAT
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL HAS
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGES THE ON
THE GROUND FAX. ASSOCIATE WITH
THESE PROJECTS AND RESERVE THE
LAST YEAR'S BILL. MISTER CHAIR-
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS IN THE
STAFF REPORT. QUITE ELOQUENTLY
TALKS ABOUT THE- FUZZINESS
THAT'S CREATED WITH THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL WITH
REGARD TO THE- THE SEQUEL
REVIEW PROCESS WHETHER WE'RE
USING CALENDAR DAYS OR BUSINESS
DAYS JUST AND WE HAVE TWO LINES
OF APPELLATE COURTS HAVING TWO
DIFFERENT DECISIONS ONE OF THE-
THE CLEARING CALLS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO IS. SET HIM
AND PICK ONE OR THE OTHER- SO I
WOULD I GUESS IT'S MORE OF A
ADVICE IS THAT I WOULD ASK THE
AUTHOR CHOOSE ONE TO TWO SO
THAT IT SAYS THAT ALL EVERYBODY
IN THE GAME KNOWS WHAT IT IS
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT IF YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND AS CLOSE BUT-
THAT'S- A CONTINUING PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE. THANK YOU. CENTER
CABALLERO. YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY A FEW WORDS I MEAN TO SAY
THAT I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO BE.
ADDED AS A AS A CO AUTHOR BUT-
I HAVE BEEN HAVING SAID THAT-
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO AS THE
AUTHOR KNOWS TRYING TO DO-
SOME- SEQUEL REFORM AROUND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND IN PARTICULAR IN-
VERY POOR NEIGHBORHOODS AND I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO IT MOSTLY
BECAUSE- THE L. A. DELEGATION
AND IN THE ASSEMBLY. DOESN'T
LIKE SYKORA STREAMLINING OR OR
OR OR- THE EXPEDITED JUDICIAL
REVIEW- GIVEN THAT THIS IS FOR
L. A. AND MY GUESS IS THEY'LL
TAKE A VERY DIFFERENT VIEW OF
IT IN AND OUT THERE WILL BE A
PROBLEM BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THAT- I THINK THAT. THIS
IS A REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE OF THE
KIND OF THE SEQUOIA-
MODIFICATION THAT WE NEED TO
CONSIDER- I ON A BROADER BASIS
WHAT CAN BE BETTER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT THAN FOR US TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR VEHICLES
ND TAKING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND TO DO IT IN
OUR URBAN CENTERS IS EXACTLY
WHERE IT SHOULD BE DONE. AND SO
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT WE HAD
A WE HAD A LOOK AT THIS- AND
INSTEAD OF AN EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW WE SHOULD LOOK
AT IT AS AN ARM AND AN
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL- EXPEDITED
SECRET PROCESS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- AND- I. HAVE BEEN HAVING
SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH ONE OF
THE- ONE OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAS. CREATED MOST OF THE
SEQUEL LITIGATION IN IN MY
REGION AND THEY SEE IT THIS WAY
TOO THEY THEY HAVE FINALLY-
SEEN THE LIGHT AND THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN WE CAN NOT CHANGE
HOW WE DO SECRET BECAUSE
INITIALLY IN THIS IS. I WASN'T
AROUND WHEN SEAT BUT WAS WAS
PROPOSED AND I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF IT- BUT IT'S BEEN
MISUSED- IT WAS. BUT NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT IT WAS WHEN YOU ARE
GOING TO BE DOING CONSTRUCTION.
JEX IN ON LAND THAT HAD NOT
BEEN. DISTURBED FOR A
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT IN SO IN
ANY CASE I JUST WANTED TO- TO
MAKE MY WITH MY TWO CENTS WORTH
IT'S A FRUSTRATION OF MINE WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND I'M GONNA CONTINUE
TO WORK ON. ON WAYS TO BE ABLE
TO GET IT DONE BUT THIS THIS IT
SEEMS TO ME LIKE A RIPE AREA
FOR- SOME DISCUSSION IN ANY WAY
THAT I CAN BE HELPFUL I WANT TO
BE THERE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO-
SEVERAL BOARD JUST SAY NO YOUR
MICROPHONES UP CENTER BOARD
JUST THANK YOU FOR CHAIRING THE
COMMITTEE IN MY ABSENCE YEAR
COMPENSATION WILL BE.
APPROPRIATELY INCREASED. WITH
THAT CHAIR PAY FOR VOICE ABOUT
TEARS DON'T GET PAID ANYTHING
EXTRA ANYWAY CENTRAL. I MUST
SAY- TERM IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU
BACK WE HAD SOME. UNUSUAL
SERIES OF A DISTURBANCE IS BUT
LIKE ALWAYS WE GET THROUGH
THEM- I KIND OF WONDERFUL ON A
COMMENT THAT WAS. I DON'T KNOW
IF IT WAS MR PIMENTEL OR MISTER
TURNER. ONE OF THIS AND TO
WONDER THE TO SUPPORT WITNESSES-
ONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS MADE A
COMMENT THAT SEACOR IS MISUSED
IT IT FACILITATES LAWSUITS IN
CAN CREATE SOME UNNECESSARY
DELAYS. IN NOT TO OVERSTATE THE
OBVIOUS BUT I THINK THOSE ARE
THE TRUISMS THAT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHERE THEY'RE DEALING WITH A
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT OR THEIR
CITY OR COUNTY EMPLOYEES
DEALING WITH LAND USE. SO I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
DESIRE TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE
SEEK WHAT WORK MORE EFFICIENTLY
AND MORE EFFECTIVELY MORE
TRANSPARENTLY. I THINK AT SOME
POINT IN TIME WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO ALSO AGAIN HAVE THE
COURAGE TO DEAL DIRECTLY WITH-
THE UNDERLYING LEGISLATION AND
NOT NECESSARILY JUST ALWAYS
WORKING AROUND IT. BUT WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR LEGISLATION
BECAUSE I THINK. IT IS. IT IS
IN. I THINK WE'VE A POLTERGEIST%
IN THIS BUILDING. THERE'S A
LOOK AT IT WITH A BUT I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT ON THIS- THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
TO MAKE SINGLE WORK FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU CENTER BOARD IS A SINGLE
OTHER MICROPHONES- SURROUNDED
LIKE CLOSE. TO PROCEED THE
COMMENTS AND- SO WE WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU AT YOUR END OF
THE DAY THIS IS THIS IS. YEAH I
APPRECIATE CENTER COPIERS
COMMENTS ESPECIALLY AT YEAH
WHAT WHAT COULD BE GREENER.
THAN GETTING MORE. TRANSIT
PROJECTS ONLINE FOR PEOPLE TO
GET AROUND TOWN. ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IN A SAFE
AFFORDABLE CLEAN MANNER- IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR OUR PREPARATIONS
FOR THE OLYMPICS BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE. UP AND
DOWN THE STATE- WE EVERY TIME I
GO YOU KNOW OF OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD I I'M JUST. SOMETIMES
SADDENED BY HOW MUCH BETTER
THEIR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS ARE- WE GOT A LOT OF
CONSTRUCTION WE WANT WE WANT TO
BUILD OUT OUR OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE HERE. IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA'S OUR PEOPLE
CAN GET AROUND- AND DO IT
EFFICIENTLY AND CAME IN A IN A
IN AN ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
MANNER THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE WITH THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE IT WHEN SUPPORT. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU THEIR MOTION. CYNICAL
MOST THE BILL. BELICHICK
COUNCIL YOUR CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS THE SB FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ALLEN WITH MOTION BY
SENATOR CORY IT'LL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. NUMBER
GUY BURGESS BURGESS I CAN BE AT
ALL I HAVE YOU KNOW I DID ASAL
HI THE REST SO I GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG I'D JONES. JONES NOT
VOTING. LAYERED HI LAYERED I
STERN QUAKE OWSKI HI WAKE
HOUSEKI I WIENER. YOU HAVE
EIGHT ZERO FOR NOW REGULAR
PEOPLE ON CALL BABYSITTER ALLEN
VERY FUN NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO- CENTER JONES IS BILL
SB THREE NINE SEVEN BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH SB THREE NINE SEVEN
NINE I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
THOSE IN THE GALLERY WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE THOSE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WAS TO TESTIFY. I ALSO NOTE
THAT THERE ARE MANY ON THE
PHONE WITH TO TESTIFY- PLEASE
REST ASSURED THAT WHAT
WHATEVER- PERIOD OF TIME WE
PROVIDE TO SUPPORT WE WILL ALSO
PROVIDE TO OPPOSITION IN EQUAL
MEASURE BOB WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST MOVE TO THE PRINCIPAL
WITNESSES WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
AND NEVER GONNA MOVE TO THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY AND LEND
THEIR SUPPORT. AFTER THE
PRINCIPAL WITNESSES TESTIFIED
EACH HAVING TWO MINUTES THEN
THOSE WHO ARE ALSO HERE ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY- MAYBE GIVE
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
AND THAT'S IT UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE OF- BOTH TIME AND
TECHNOLOGY CONSTRAINTS THAT'S
WHAT WE CAN AFFORD SO- CENTER
JONES HAVING SAID THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT FROM YOUR
DESK OR FROM THE PODIUM OF
PRISON FOR MY DESK THAN I CARE
TO SHARE. THANK YOU SEVEN JONES
ROAD YEARS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY SEVEN ESTABLISHES.
THE RELIGION IS ESSENTIAL ACT.
IN SUPREME JUST. ON TEN VERSUS
NEWSOME LIBERAL JUSTICES
STARTED THEIR DESCENT BY
STATING. QUOTE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT REQUIRES THAT A STATE
TREAT RELIGIOUS CONDUCT AS WELL
AS THE STATE TREATS COMPATIBLE
SECULAR CONDUCT IN QUOTE THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES
REQUIRE THE STATE TO TREAT
RELIGION AS THE SAME AS ANY
SECULAR ESSENTIAL SERVICE. THIS
BILL UPHOLDS THE RIGHT TO
WORSHIP WITH FELLOW BELIEVERS
ANY CHOSEN HOUSE OF WORSHIP AS
AN ESSENTIAL PART OF LIFE.
WHERE DO YOU GO TO CHURCH
SYNAGOGUE TEMPLE SHRINE MOSQUE
OR ANY OTHER RELIGIOUS SERVICE
YOU GO TO SHARE YOUR BELIEFS
VALUES AND LOVE OF LIFE WITH
YOUR FELLOW PRACTITIONERS AND
YOUR FAITH LEADERS. PRACTICING
A RELIGION IS SOMETHING THAT
CROSSES ALL PARTY LINES RACIAL
IDENTITIES DEMOGRAPHICS
CULTURES AND LIFESTYLES. YOU'LL
FIND HOUSES OF WORSHIP IN THE
MOST POVERTY STRICKEN
NEIGHBORHOODS OF CALIFORNIA AND
YOU'LL FIND THEM IN THE
WEALTHIEST ENCLAVES OF OUR
STATE. YOU'LL FIND THEM IN
DOWNTOWN URBAN CENTERS AND YOU
WILL FIND THEM IN MIDDLE OF
FARM COUNTRY IN THE SUBURBS AND
IN THE INNER CITIES YOU WILL
FIND THEM. EVERYWHERE TAKING
AWAY THE RIGHT TO ATTEND YOUR
CHOSEN HOUSE OF WORSHIP TO
PRACTICE WHATEVER RELIGION YOU
BELIEVE IN. AND TO SHARE THAT
EXPERIENCE WITH YOUR FAMILY
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS PEOPLE OF
EVERY WALK OF LIFE. IN OUR
STATE. TODAY WE WILL SHARE
TESTIMONY FROM TWO OUTSTANDING
SCHOLARS FOCUSING ON THE BASIC
PREMISE. THAT RELIGION IS
ESSENTIAL. NOT JUST FOR OUR
SPIRITUAL WELL BEING BUT ALSO
FOR OUR PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH. YOU WILL ALSO HEAR THAT
OUR GOVERNMENT THROUGH ITS
ACTIONS HAS ENTRUSTED OUR LIVES
IN SAFETY TO LARGE RETAIL
CORPORATIONS. YET THAT SAME
GOVERNMENT HAS REFUSED TO TRUST
FAITH LEADERS TO PROTECT US.
MEMBERS IF WE TRUST THE CEOS
AND MANAGERS OF BIG BOX STORES
TO ENSURE WE SOCIALLY DISTANCE
IN THEIR STORES. AND WHY WOULD
WE NOT TRUST THE RABBIS IMAMS
PRIESTS AND PASTORS. SURE WE
SOCIALLY DISTANCE IN OUR HOUSES
OF WORSHIP. I'M HONORED TO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES ON THE LINE TODAY
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY AS MANY
INDIVIDUAL SUPPORTERS BOTH HERE
IN THE CAPITAL AND ON THE PHONE
LINE. THAT MADE TIME TODAY FOR
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. FIRST
YOU'LL HAVE DOCTOR J.
BHATTACHARYA AN MD AND PHD IN
IN ECONOMICS. WHO IS A
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AT THE
STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND A
RESEARCH ASSOCIATE AT THE
NATIONAL BUREAU OF ECONOMICS
RESEARCH. THEY WILL HAVE A
GREAT SHOP IN THE LEGAL COUNSEL
FOR THE ALLIANCE DEFENDING
FREEDOM. A CENTER OF
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY. MR NOT
SURE WE'RE READY FOR THAT
WITNESSES IF YOU ARE THANK YOU
SENATE JONES IS- DR PADA
CHARLES IS HE HERE OR ON THE
PHONE LINE. BOTH A KEY
WITNESSES ARE ON THE PHONE ALL
RIGHT. SO MISTER MODERATOR IF%
DR PADA CIARA IS AVAILABLE IF
YOU TO HIM UP. AND IF NOT
DOCTOR PRODUCTS ARE THEN- MR
TELFORD. BUT I REMEMBER. I DO
SHOW THAT- MISTER JOHNSON IS ON
THE LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN ALL
RIGHT LET'S LET'S START WITH MR
JOHNSON. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME HI MY NAME IS
GREG CHAPLAIN I'M A LICENSED
ATTORNEY. AND LEGAL COUNSEL
WITH ALLIANCE DEFENDING
FREEDOM. THE WORLD'S LARGEST
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
DEFENDING RELIGIOUS LIBERTY. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. THE
BILL PROTECTS THE RIGHT TO
CALIFORNIANS TO WORSHIP AND TO
EXERCISE THEIR FAITH ESPECIALLY
IN DIFFICULT TIMES. AND IT DOES
THIS WHILE STILL ALLOWING THE
STATE TO REQUIRE COMPLIANCE
WITH MUTUAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
THE COMMISSION APPROVED THE
BILL FOR THREE REASONS FIRST
WHICH IT IS IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIANS AND WORSHIP
SERVICES ARE INTEGRAL PART OF
THE EXERCISE OF RELIGION.
SECOND POTENTIALLY DURING
CRISES WE TO PROTECT THE FREE
EXERCISE OF RELIGION BECAUSE
APART FROM BEING A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT. RELIGION IS ALSO A VITAL
SOURCE OF SUPPORT TO PEOPLE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. THIRD
CALIFORNIANS NEED THIS BILL MAY
NEED IT NOW. FOR MOST OF THE
PAST YEAR COUNTY CHURCHES AND
PEOPLE OF FATE SUFFERED
VIOLATIONS THAT THEIR RIGHT TO
EXERCISE RELIGION. THERE WERE
MORE COURT CASES ALLEGING
VIOLATIONS OF FREE EXERCISE
RIGHT TO CALIFORNIA THAN ANY
OTHER STATE. AND THIS IS
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
RESTRICTIONS DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
THREE OF THEM WERE SPECTACULAR
CONTENT THAT POSED COME
TERRIBLE WRITTEN. A CHIEF
JUSTICE ROBERTS NOTED THE STATE
DETERMINATION THAT THE MAXIMUM
NUMBER BUT HEARING THAT COULD
SAFELY WORSHIP WHEN THE MOST
CAVERNOUS CATHEDRAL ZERO.
REFLECTED AN INSUFFICIENT
APPRECIATION OF THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE INTERESTS
AT STAKE. SO WHEN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH RESTRICTS CHURCHES ON
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH IS GOING TO
STOP IT BUT UP TO THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO REMEDY
THE PROBLEM BY NOTHING CONCRETE
PROTECTIONS. THIS BILL RICHARD
THE STATE WILL RESPECT THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT THE TAKEN
THREE CHURCHES AT LEAST AS WELL
AS SECULAR BUSINESSES THE
PAYLOAD OPEN. ADJUSTING CAN
CONFIRM HER DEFENSE THE COURT'S
LATEST DECISION. SENATOR JONES
JUST SAID THE FIRST AMENDMENT
REQUIRED THAT IT BE ST LOUIS
CONDUCT AS WELL AS THE PATRIOTS
COMPATIBLE SECULAR CONDUCT. SO
EVEN IF YOU DO NOT ASCRIBE TO
RELIGION OR IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE THAT COMMUNITY WORSHIP
SERVICES ARE NECESSARY.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT. AND ASIDE FROM
THAT VERY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION THE CONSTITUTION
ITSELF ATTACKED THE FREE
EXERCISE OF RELIGION AS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. IN THIS BILL
PROTECT THAT DELIBERATE I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I. URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHILDHOOD- MODERATE DR- BUT A
CHAU. ON THE ON THE LAW. I DO
SHOW THE ON LINE YOUR LINE OPEN.
HI THIS IS JAY ABOUT IT. DR GO
AHEAD WHAT WE CAN HEARING THAT
YES WE CAN GO AHEAD AT. OKAY SO
GOOD BECAUSE I CAN GIVE MY
TESTIMONY DONE. SO I I'M- I'M
DOCTOR GAVE A SHARIA I'M A
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AT HERE
STANFORD UNIVERSITY- I'M
TALKING IN FAVOR OF THE
RELIGION AND SHELLAC- I'VE BEEN
DOING IT ALL COVERED RESEARCH
INCLUDING MULTIPLE PUBLISHED
PAPERS ON COLD AT THIS ARE
PROBABLY BECAUSE OF IT THE FACT
LOCKDOWN. AND ALSO A CO AUTHOR
OF THE PAPER INTO DECORATIONS
FROM A LOT OF BACKGROUND IN IN
A PUBLIC POLICY AT THAT BEEN
TESTIFYING AS AN EXPERT WITNESS
ON MULTIPLE CASES INVOLVING
CHURCHES INCLUDING AT THE TWO
THAT HAVE GONE TO THE SUPREME
COURT BUT THAT THAT- WOULD HAVE
COME DOWN IN FAVOR. OF CHURCH
OFCHURCH OPENING- SO. AM
STRONG IN OF THIS. FOR A-
LITTLE. AND FOR. THREE MADE
THREE. FIRST IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SCENE. AND WORLD HEALTH.
GUIDANCE ON RELIGIOUS OR-
DURING AND- BOTH OF THEM
AMPLIFY. THE OF- PRIVILEGES.
AND PERMITTING RELIGIOUS
WORSHIP DURING CONDUCT- THAN
SAY THAT- THAT TRADITIONALLY
CLOSED- YOU OR TOWARD. MARSHALL
BECAUSE DOOR OR A SHINING
ACTUALLY BOTH. THAT AT THE GATE
AND THE SOCK REPORT. FREE
RELIGIOUS WORSHIP- SECOND- AND
THIS IS THE MOST POINT. IF
CHURCHES WOULD TO SAY. AND
PUBLIC HEALTH COULD MORE WHICH-
TO HAVE SAFE WORSHIP- AND IT'S
NOW THAT THE IN MANY CHURCHES
PUBLIC HEALTH- JUST CLOSE THE
PUBLIC A LOCAL PUBLIC BASICALLY
JUST CLOSES THE CHARGING DOWN.
BOB AND DOESN'T ALLOW WORSHIP
INSTANCE CREATED A SITUATION
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF CONFLICT
WHEN THERE DOESN'T. NEED TO BE
IN FACT A PUBLIC IT IF. SURE
TEAM ARE STILL PUBLIC HEALTH
COULD WORK THE CHURCH'S FOR
STATE PORTION TO. LIKE PUBLIC
REPORTS WERE OTHER. BUSINESS
TALKED OPERATE SAFELY DURING
AND AFTER. FINALLY MOST
IMPORTANTLY CHURCH ATTENDANCE
IS A KEY PART OF THAT WHILE
LIVE LIFE FOR MANY MANY PEOPLE
ON THE STREET FOR SYNAGOGUES
AND MOSQUES AS WELL. OBVIOUSLY
IT'S PROTECTED THE PERSON FOR A
REASON- THEY THEY ARE ESSENTIAL
AND SHOULD BE DEEMED ESSENTIAL-
AND THEN THE GOVERNMENT THE
TOLL COULD DO THAT. OUR EFFECT
VIOLATING LEGISLATING WHAT
ACTUALLY- PROTECTING PEOPLE
FROM THE PANDEMIC IT IN WAYS
THAT THEY COULDN'T. BE
MEDICATED WITH STOP WITH. BUT
STILL SORT OF- BUT NOW THE UP
BACK IN THE TITLE OF THE SOCCER
THANK YOU YOUR PATIENCE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. ALL
RIGHT. SO WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVE
TO THE GAL- I SEE IT THERE ARE
IN THE GALLERY YOU WOULD IN A
SOCIALLY DISTANCE FASHION MOVES
TO THE MICROPHONE YOU CAN LINE
UP- OVER SIX FEET APART. WHEN
YOU TESTIFIED BOTH HERE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE AND ON THE PHONE
LINE. IF YOU PROVIDE YOUR NAME.
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. YEAH IF YOU GO BEYOND
THAT UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO CUT
YOU OFF AND ALSO IT IMPINGES ON
THOSE WHO ARE- HERE AS WELL AS
ON THE PHONE LINE TO TESTIFY.
SO IF WE GIVE THE FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD APPROACH MICHAEL GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
JAMES WHEELER I'M A RESIDENT OF
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I LIKE FOR
YOU TO JOIN ME AND- THE SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINE
SEVEN PLEASE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. HEY STEVE L.
COLE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
NEXT HI MY NAME IS CINDYPICKENS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK WE HAVE ONE MORE HERE IN
THE SENATE GALLERY. NEVER GONNA
TURN TO ROOM ONE TWELVE SO IF
YOU LINE UP IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
GO AHEAD MA'AM. MY NAME IS
KRISTEN FRANCE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU MA'AM.
ALL RIGHT. NOW TURNING TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE- IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
IF YOU GO AHEAD. STATE YOUR
NAME OR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. YES GINA GRAYSON WITH
REAL IMPACT CO SPONSOR OF SB
THREE NINE SEVEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. JUDY RAWSON
AFFILIATION WITH DESTINY CHURCH
AND I SUPPORT THREE NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. BOMER BENNETT
A MEMBER OF DESTINY'S CHURCH
NOT STRONG SUPPORT THREE NINE
SEVEN THANK YOU. EIGHTEEN
BROYLES CONSTITUTIONAL ATTORNEY
WITH THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
LAW AND POLICY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I AM A
LOSER DANDO RESIDENT ROCK IN
CALIFORNIA A CHURCH CHAPLAIN
AND I SUPPORT SB THREE NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR. JONATHAN
KELLER PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL- RESIDENT OF
FRESNO CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF
CAMPUS BIBLE CHURCH AND A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR GORGEOUS
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB THREE NINETY
SEVEN AND THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES- IN THE BILL THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE THERE WE GO GO AHEAD
SIR. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY%
NAME IS MICHAEL CARRINGTON AS A
FORMER DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
FEDERAL TASK FORCE ON FAITH
BASED AND COMMUNITY INITIATIVES
I STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS BRAD
WYCLIFFE'S- A RESIDENT OF GOLD
RIVER CALIFORNIA. I REPRESENT
MYSELF MY FAMILY ALMOST FOR
GENERATION CALIFORNIA AND-
NECESSARY BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS KATHY HODGE-
RESIDENT OF ORANGE BOWL
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS SCOTT BIRD IT'S KIM THE
PRESIDENT OF KINGDOM BUILDERS
WHICH IS A REGIONAL
ORGANIZATION OF CHRISTIAN
BUSINESS LEADERS AND WE
STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF I
COULD ASK THOSE AROUND ONE
TWELVE JUST KEEP THEIR MASKS ON
WHEN THEY TESTIFIED. GO AHEAD
SIR. MY NAME IS TANNER BELL AND
I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL FOR
EVANGELICALS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE AND IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WISHING TO TESTIFY
ON SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
SEVEN. SEEING NONE WE'RE GOING
TO TURN TO THE PHONE LINES NOW-
MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES AND
WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE. ALL
RIGHT. SO FIFTEEN MINUTES RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR IN FOR THOSE
ON THE PHONE WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE OF FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
TELEPHONE TESTIMONY CONSISTING
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION IN THE
POSITION OF THE BILL AND FOR
THOSE WHO OPPOSE WILL PROVIDE
THE SAME TIME ALL RIGHT MISS
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD TO THOSE
UP AND- IN SUPPORT. AND LATER
ON IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT OF THREE NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND CHAIR AT THIS TIME I DO
SHOW- WE DO HAVE OVER A HUNDRED
IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME AND- WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER FOUR TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A LINE FOR TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OF FOR TEN POSITION ON
A MUTE. HELLO GO AHEAD MA'AM.
YEAH MY NAME IS KAREN POWERS
I'M CALLING FROM DOCTOR BILL
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINE
THOUSAND THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE YOU. WELL NOW MOVE
THE LINE TO FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KIRAN
REYES AND I REPRESENT ARE THE
CO SPONSORS JUDEO CHRISTIAN
CARCASS IN THE SOUTHERN LIKE
COUNCIL AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
BE LINE SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM LESLEY
LAWSON FROM GOLD RIVER I AM
SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINE SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER SIX TEN
SIX TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREG
BURGER KING THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL- COULD SPONSOR
OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT OF THE
CREEK THREE NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THAT THE
THREE. I'M A RESIDENT OF YUBA
COUNTY AND I'M I WAS ON THE
RECORD AS WE ALL THREE NINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO NUMBER SIX TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SHANNON
ERICKSON AND THE DESTINY CHURCH
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE AND
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NEXT IS GOING
TO BE NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY NINE
PLEASE- ED. DEFINITELY NOT YES
SAYS HE WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
MY NAME IS VERONICA SOLD AND I
AM A RESIDENT YUBA COUNTY
MARYSVILLE AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT SENATE BILL THREE NINE
SEVEN THANK YOU CAN YOU. NEXUS
NUMBER FOUR FORTY FOUR FOUR
FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS COREY LANDRY AND I
AM A RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO%
COUNTY AND I IMAGE ALONG THE
COURT. SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER FIVE THIRTY ONE- FIVE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DOUBLE THE AFTER SUN I
REPRESENT ACT MONTEREY BAY AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS GOING TO BE THE NUMBER
FIVE FIFTY FIVE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS DOCTOR ARE
HANDSOME THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
PSYCHOLOGIST REPRESENTING THE
CATHOLIC MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ORANGE COUNTY CHAPTER OF WHICH
I'M ON THE BOARD WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND SB THREE
NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER TWO NINETY NINE
TO NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ROBIN ANALYSTS AND
DELETE IT WITH THE SONG LIKE
CANCEL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOTED A NUMBER SIX
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VICTORIA
SOMETHING WITH REAL IMPACT AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU. NEXT IS
GOING TO BE NUMBER SIX EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
JENNIFER PERRY MEMBER OF
BAYSIDE CHURCH SUBSCRIBER TO
CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE WIFE
MOTHER PREMARITAL COUNSELING
MARRIAGE MENTOR STRONGLY
SUPPORTSB THREE NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU. NEXT IS GOING TO BE
NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. POURED OUT MY THE
ROSE GARDEN. HEARING YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS JEFF
VERY REAL LINDA CALIFORNIA AND
I WANT TO VOICE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT IS
GOING TO BE NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DENISE PAINTER CRIME
CALIFORNIA I TEN CALVARY CHAPEL
CHINO HILLS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE NINE SEVEN.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS GOING TO BE
NUMBER SEVEN TWELVE SEVEN
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES ANY
HARRINGTON PROFESSOR CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS THE. IT IS THE- DROP IN
THE QUEUE WE CAN GO TO NUMBER
FOUR SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU HI MY NAME IS
MONEY SELEGILINE A CHRISTIAN-
UPDATED AGAINST IN SOMEWHERE
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS TO BE NUMBER
TWO SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN GO
AHEAD YES. BOB CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN GO AHEAD. OKAY HI MY
NAME IS DETERMINED TO I'M A BIG
FAN OF THE GOOD SHEPHERD
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB THREE NINE SEVEN THANK YOU.
NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER EIGHT
TWENTY- PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER THREE NINETY SIX THREE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THREE NINETY SIX POSITION- YOU.
HI MY NAME'S DARCY ROEMER FROM
BACK OF OWN I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW GO TO
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THE DAM AND INGRID. STRONGLY
SUPPORTING THREE NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU. NEXT IS GOING TO BE
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD OF. I SURE DID I
HAVEN'T CHECKED YOUR MOM HAVE
WHITE WINE- THREE EIGHTY SIX.
LET ME SEE IN THE MILITARY
RIGHT NOW. MISTER MODERATOR GO
AHEAD OF THE NEXT CALLER. WILL
MOVE TO LINE THREE OH EIGHT-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COUNTY CAPITAL
GAINS. FROM COURT IT'S BEEPING
AND- THANK YOU. WELL NOW GO TO
NUMBER FIVE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES GO AHEAD. AT THAT CAN YOU
GET YOUR TALKING TO ME YES GO
AHEAD OKAY OKAY THANK YOU- YES
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE NINE SEVEN I COME FROM
FOSTER CITY THE PEOPLE ARE
WILLING TO DIE FOR THEIR GOD
THEIR BELIEVE FOR THE RELIGION
I DID STAY ON THE AND THE
CENTRAL. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS HEY SHOWN CALL
PASTOR OF GOOD SHEPHERD
PRESIDENTIAL WHICH IN GENERAL.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THREE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS DEBORAH SCOTT TO
WITH CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO HILLS
AND REAL IMPACT AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ACTUALLY
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO I'M TIRED
CHAMBERS- I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THREE NINETY SEVEN I'M
AFFILIATED WITH MONTEREY BAY
ASK FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT OF THE NUMBER EIGHT
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
A LIAR WITH CATHOLIC FAMILY
ADVOCATE BINDER THAN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB. THREE NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU GOD BLESS THANK YOU.
NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER FIVE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS LISA DISCO
SOUND OR PICTURE CONTRA COSTA
SECTION CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO
HILLS IN VERY STRONG SUPPORTER
THAT'S BETWEEN NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. I WILL NOW GO TO
NUMBER EIGHT OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARJORIE
MCNEELY IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE NINE SEVEN THANK YOU GOD
BLESS. THANK YOU. NEXT IS GOING
TO BE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
GERRY ORTIZ AND I INTEND TO ADD
CALVARY CHAPEL AND P. AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT SB THREE NINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. HELLO GO TO
NUMBER SIX FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS CAMERON
I THINK FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
THREE NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
GO AHEAD ALL. YEAH MY NAME'S
KUMAIL CALLED GRASS VALLEY AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
THREE NINE SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELL NOW GO TO LINE
FIVE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOBBIE ANDERSON OF THE MARRIAGE
DANCE FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF RELIGION IS
ESSENTIAL ACT. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FOUR FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS BRENDA ALL THAT I AM STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. HELLO NOW GO TO NUMBER
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS BERMAN BAPTISM
PATRICK ELLIS A COMMUNITY THANK
CHILD AND ARMSTRONG. ORDER IT'S
NEAT THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT SO WE'LL GO
TO LINE SEVEN NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I'M ROBIN TO GARY
AND I'M AN AMBASSADOR FOR
CHRIST AND I GO TO COVER CHAPEL
CHINO HILLS NINE MINUTES THE
PORT OF THREE NINE SEVEN.
PUBLIC YOU GUYS. THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER THREE FIFTY
SEVEN THREE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JOANNE IS
THE DORK FROM YUCAIPA
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW GO TO NUMBER
EIGHT THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SERLING THIRD GOLD RIVER
CALIFORNIA YOU COULD FOR SB
THREE NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS WILLIAM LEE. ARE YOU HEAR ME.
YES MY NAME IS STANLEY I'M A
MEMBER OF LIVING WATER BAPTIST
CHURCH IN CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE NINE SEVEN.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE LINE
THREE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS THERE ANY
DATA- ROMAN CATHOLIC FROM THE
ARCHDIOCESE OF LOS ANGELES I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU AND GOD
BLESS. THANK YOU. THE NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER TWO SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GET. BECAUSE HE- THANK
YOU. WE WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BARBARA KASKI AND I'M
AFFILIATED WITH DESTINY CHURCH
IN A RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL NOW THE NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS NICHOLAS MENOTTI
CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR- WE ARE
NOW GOING TO BRING IT BACK
HERE- WELL ACTUALLY GOING TO
BRING BACK TO OPPOSITION BUT
LET ME REMIND THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE PHONE WHO HADN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO VOICE THEIR POSITION.
THAT WE WILL RECEIVE AND READ
YOUR TESTIMONY SUBMITTED ON THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE SO NOW LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE I BELIEVE
ONE PERSON ON THE PHONE LINE
AND AN OPPOSITION CAT THE
BURKE- HELP OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. HIS CAPTOR BURKE
ONLINE. YES I AM AND I'LL GO
AHEAD ALL RIGHT. MISTER MISTER
MISTER CHER MEMBER KATHY BURKE
THE TO HELP OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA. I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND
WE'RE STILL IN THE COMPLEX
ISSUES INVOLVED. CAN DISEASES
SPREAD IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND
THE NEXT PANDEMIC MAY OR MAY
NOT INVOLVE A RESPIRATORY VIRUS
AND IT MAY OR MAY NOT INVOLVE.
CERTAIN SERVICES ESSENTIAL EACH
OF THESE DIFFERENT. DISEASES
SPREAD ACCORDING TO TWO MAIN
FACTORS FIRST THEIR OWN
INTERNAL CHEMISTRY AND HOW THEY
WORK AND THEN SECOND DESPITE IS
ALSO. DETERMINED BY HUMAN
BEHAVIOR. AND ANALYSIS OUT
WORSHIP AT BEING SEATED IN ROOM
FOR AN HOUR WE'RE SHE CAN'T BE
TREATED THE SAME WAY STORAGE
TREATED WHERE PEOPLE MOVE
AROUND GET THEIR BUSINESS DONE
AND WILL. BE THE REST ARE JUST
NOT THE SAME. A RESPIRATORY
VIRUS IT'S NOT THE SAME AS A
BACTERIAL INFECTION THAT MAY BE
SPENT BY TOUCH. EACH TO THESE
DIFFERENT AND THAT WAS WHY
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES MADE.
ACROSS TIME. THERE IS ALREADY
AMPLE PROTECTION FOR WORSHIP
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA LOCKING
IN THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION. THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO ALTER WHAT IS A
FINE BALANCE BETWEEN INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTY AND PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
WE THINK IT'S DANGEROUS TO HELP
THE BALLOT AS FAR AS THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL. AND
ALTHOUGH THEY WERE UNABLE TO
CALL IN TODAY DUE TO THE BUSY
PHONE LINES AND ALSO CONVEYING
THE OPPOSITION OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE POSITION
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. LET'S NOW TURN TO
THE GALLERY IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE
NINE SEVEN. I SEE NO IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION THREE
NINE CIVILIZATION ROOM ONE
TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE. I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP THREE
NINETY SEVEN- SMALLER LET'S
TURN THE PHONE LINES NOW.
ABSOLUTELY ENDLESS GERMANS ON
THE PHONE LINE IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINETY
SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND I'M SURE
THIS TIME MICHELLE ABOUT EIGHT
IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT. WE CAN
BEGIN. WILL BEGIN WITH NUMBER
FIVE SIXTY SIX- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
OKAY WELL THERE WAS A TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY I WASN'T CALLED UP
ACTUALLY FOR IT- THE ONLY THING
THAT IS NOT ESSENTIAL IN
SACRAMENTO HAT THE VIRUS.
THANK YOU MA'AM. FIVE ALL RIGHT
IF WE COULD TURN TO THE NEXT
CALLER. ABSOLUTELY NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER THREE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. COULD YOU RUN THE NFL
KIND OF OUR RACE OR OR
INSURRECTIONIST I'LL PULL THIS
BILL. I'M SORRY NEXT CALLER.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER THREE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS TO
THE CONFUSION- I CALLED EARLIER
PRESSED ONE ZERO AND WOULD
NEVER GIVEN THE NUMBERS ACCOUNT
MA'AM WHAT'S YOUR MAILING YOUR
AFFILIATION YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. OKAY I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THE AT THE MARINA FOR MEDS
NEED TO SELL CORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
THREE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
A MOVE TO NUMBER FOUR THIRTY
FOUR THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I'M CAROL SCHRADER AND I
KNEW STRONG SUPPORT OF BILLS
THREE NINETY SEVEN I NEVER GOT
AN OPPORTUNITY TO- RIGHT LET'S
LET'S LET'S MOVE THE NEXT
CALLER THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER SEVEN TWENTY FOUR-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE. NUMBER
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT LET'S MISS
MAHREZ MOVE THE NEXT CALLER.
ABSOLUTELY WILL MOVE ON TO
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FIVE- FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO.
YES GO AHEAD CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES MY NAME IS CAROLINE THIS
STRONG AND- FROM DESTINY
CHRISTIAN CHURCH ROSA
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB THREE NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE'RE WE'RE NOW ON
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE NINETY
SEVEN IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
NINETY SEVEN I WILL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL IN
OPPOSITION. ABSOLUTELY NEXT IN
THE QUEUE IS NUMBER SEVEN
THIRTY SIX- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE WILL MOVE TO NUMBER
EIGHT TWENTY SIX- EIGHT TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY SIX THIS IS
A PART HAWKINS I REPRESENT MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED UNITED
PENTECOSTAL CHURCHES IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE ALL
STRONGLY FAVOR OF THIS BILL
I'VE GOT IN THE- THANK YOU VERY.
IF THEY ON TO NEXT. IN A- TO
THE BILL. HENCE THE LEGISLATURE
MILEY IS JUMPING. ZERO IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION. AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. I WILL GO TO LINE FOR
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU ARE YOU IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE EIGHTY
THREE NINETY SEVEN. ARE YOU IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE NINETY
SEVEN. AND INTERROGATORY A
THREE NINE LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT CALLER IN OPPOSITION. THEN
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION ONLY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. OKAY
WOULD BE OF ONE CHEWING UP
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT. GOOD A
NUMBER SEVEN TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BARBER OR CAGE THANK YOU HOW
ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION CALLER. I
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. ONCE AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION ONLY ONE ZERO. I WE
DO HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE- WE
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER NINE OH
EIGHT NINE OH EIGHT ZERO AND-
COMBINE IN SUPPORT N. S. B.
MITCHELL ARE UNANIMOUS IN. ARE
YOU IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
MISS MODERATE WAS WHAT THE NEXT
CALLER. ABSOLUTELY THE NEXT ONE
IN THE QUEUE IS NUMBER FOUR
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CALLER NUMBER FOUR THIRTY
YOU IN OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE
NINE SEVEN. THE PORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SIX WE HAD.
THANK YOU NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
SIX ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE NINETY SEVEN. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES ARE YOU IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE NINETY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR JERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES ARE YOU
IN OPPOSITION. TO THREE NINETY
SEVEN. LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO BE EIGHT
SIXTY THREE SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD CALLER NUMBER EIGHT.
EXISTENCE. THREE NINETY SEVEN.
OKAY WE TURN YOU IN ARE YOU
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE NINETY
SEVEN. YOU DON'T TREAT PEOPLE
THAT WAY FOR SB SEVENTEEN US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU
WOULD MISTER MODERATE MOVE ON
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THERE I KILLA NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHTY ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE NINETY SEVEN. I AM IN
SUPPORT. CAN I WRITE MUCH JUST
MODERATE IF YOU MOVE ON THE
NEXT CALLER. I THINK WE'LL TAKE
ONE MATCH AT ALL AND IF THE
CALL IS NOT IN OPPOSITION THEN
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BRING IT
BACK TO THE CHAMBER. ABSOLUTELY
NURSES NUMBER SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE. YEAH CALLER NUMBER SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE ARE YOU IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE NINETY
SEVEN. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK HERE THE CHAMBER I SEE
THAT CENTER BOARD JUST SAYS IS
MIKE UP. SO THE BARGES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. COLLEAGUES.
IN MY OPINION THIS IS NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE KIND OF TAKE A
STEP BACK YOU CAN APPRECIATE
THAT. THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN
ISSUE. I DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS
A THEOLOGICAL ISSUE EITHER IN
NOR IS IT LIMITED ENTIRELY TO-
COVERT RELATED POLICY. IN MY
OPINION THIS IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO WRAP OUR ARMS AROUND.
IN A SEMI POSTCODE- THE
SITUATION AS WE GRAPPLE WITH
WITH HOW WE CONDUCT OURSELVES
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AS WE'VE WE ALL KNOW.
CONGRESS SHALL MAKE NO LAW
PROHIBITING. THE EXERCISE OF
RELIGION OR PEACEFUL ASSEMBLY.
AND NO STATE SHALL MAKE OR
ENFORCE ANY LAW. THAT DENIES
THE EQUAL PROTECTION OF THE LAW.
I SUBMIT TO YOU COLLEAGUES THAT
I BELIEVE THIS IS A FIRST
AMENDMENT CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE.
THAT INVOKES EQUAL PROTECTION
PROTECTIONS. LET'S GO BACK TO
WIN THE PANDEMIC BEGAN. WE
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE VIRUS HE
TOOK TIME FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
ITS PATHOLOGY. WE BEGIN TO
APPRECIATE THAT- IT WAS
TRANSMITTED BY CLOSE PERSONAL
CONTACT AND THAT OF COURSE GAVE
RISE TO THE HEALTH PROTOCOLS OF
THE MASK MANDATE. THE
DISTANCING AND- THE HAND
WASHING AND- THE DISALLOWANCE
OF ATTENDING CERTAIN ACTIVITIES.
BUT OVER TIME WE BEGIN
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN HEALTH PROTOCOLS. THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR A REASONABLY
SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR THOSE THAT
WANTED TO PARTICIPATE. IN
CERTAIN ACTIVITIES. NOW I'M A
CHURCH GOER MY FATHER'S A
CHURCH GOER MY NINETY ONE YEAR
OLD FATHERS A CHURCH GOER. AND
HE I DON'T THINK EVER REALLY
MISSED A DAY OF CHURCH OR
SUNDAY IN HIS LIFE. BUT WHEN
THIS PANDEMIC HAPPENED GIVEN
HIS- MEDICAL CONDITIONS IN
UNDERLYING SITUATIONS. I DIDN'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE TAKING A TRIP
TAKEN TO CHURCH AND I MYSELF
DIDN'T GO TO CHURCH. FOR A
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME AND I'M
AN AVID TO CONGREGATE AT SAINT
GEORGE GREEK ORTHODOX CHURCH IN
FRESNO CALIFORNIA. BUT I
BELIEVE IN SCIENCE AND I
BELIEVE IN DOUBT AND I BELIEVE
ON LEARNING FROM EXPERTS. I WAS
A PROFESSOR FOR OVER A DECADE
NINE I HOLD THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE SUFFICIENTLY SCHOOLED
AND EDUCATED IN RESPECTIVE
DISCIPLINES THAT THEY TELL ME.
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES YOU SHOULD AVOID OR
AT LEAST UNDERTAKE TO MITIGATE
THE RISKS THAT ALL LISTEN TO
THEM. SO I DID NOT GO TO CHURCH
FOR A WHILE. AND I BELIEVE THAT
WAS THE RIGHT COURSE OF ACTION.
BUT THEN SOMETHING CHANGED WE
BECAME BETTER AWARE OF WHAT THE
PATHOLOGY OF THE VIRUS ONCE. IN
HOW WE COULD STILL PARTICIPATE
ON A LIMITED BASIS. WHETHER IT
BE GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE
TO HOME DEPOT OR- INTERACTING
WITH OTHER FOLKS. SO WHEN
CERTAIN RULES WERE PUT FORWARD
THAT DISALLOWED. CONGREGANTS
FROM ASSEMBLING ON CHURCH
GROUNDS. I WOULD ASK MYSELF
WHAT IS MY CHURCH DOING TO
PROTECT THESE INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE CAT COUNTY LAW AND
STATE LAW WE'RE DISALLOWING
CERTAIN ACTIVITIES. BUT I
DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THERE WAS
SUFFICIENT SOCIAL DISTANCING
THAT IT WAS OUTSIDE. AND ALL
THE RELEVANT PROTECTIONS AND
PROTOCOLS ARE PUT INTO PLACE.
YET INDIVIDUALS AND MOSQUES
TEMPLES AND CHURCHES WERE NOT
ALLOWED FOR- TO BE OPEN FOR
BUSINESS. THAT'S WHY BRING UP
THIS ISSUE OF. THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY. OF WHAT
OCCURRED AND WHY THIS IS NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE INSIDE A
RELIGIOUS ISSUE. IF WE BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
ASSEMBLE. THEN WE NEED TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE FIGHT FOR THAT
RIGHT ON THE SOLE CONDITION.
THAT WE ARE ABIDING BY THE
PREVAILING HEALTH PROTOCOLS. SO
AS A MATTER OF EQUAL PROTECTION
THE QUESTION THAT WE MUST ASK
OURSELVES. WERE THESE CHURCHES
FOR THESE MOSQUES OR THE
SYNAGOGUES. PRACTICING THE
PREVAILING HEALTH DIRECTIVES OF
THE STATE THE CDC OR THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES IF THE ANSWER WAS
YES. BUT I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
A RIGHT TO ATTEND. UNDER THOSE
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES. SO I
THINK THIS BILL TALKS ABOUT.
WHETHER GOING TO CHURCH OR
MOSQUE OR TEMPLE IS AN
ESSENTIAL ACTIVITY. I ASK
MYSELF IF CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
ARE CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL IN
AMERICA THAN BEING ABLE TO
ATTEND THESE ACTIVITIES ON THE
SOLE CONDITION BUT THEY ARE
ABIDING BY THE PREVAILING
HEALTH DIRECTIVES. THAT THAT IS
A CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
ESSENTIAL ACTIVITIES. I'M NOT
SURE HOW YOU CAN GET AROUND
THAT I WANNA BE VERY CLEAR MY
COLLEAGUES. I DID NOT SEND MY
FATHER TO CHURCH BECAUSE I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE VIRUS. I
DID NOT SEND MY FATHER CHURCH
FOR MY FAMILY IF THERE WERE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THERE WAS
NO SOCIAL DISTANCING THERE'S NO
MASK WEARING AND THERE'S IT
WASN'T OUTDOORS BUT ON THE
CONDITION THAT IT WAS. IT WAS
CONSISTENT. WITH THOSE
PREVAILING AUTHORITY DIRECTORS
I COULD NOT SEE A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN GOING TO HOME DEPOT.
AND GOING TO CHURCH. AND THAT I
THINK IS WHAT THIS ISSUE IS
ABOUT TODAY. IS THAT IF WE
BELIEVE THAT CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS OF RELIGION AND ASSEMBLY
IN THE EQUAL APPLICATION. OF
THE LAW. WE MUST FIND OURSELVES
IN THE LEGAL DIRECTION THAT IT
THAT THAT GOING TO CHURCH OR
MOSQUE OR TEMPLE. IS A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
ACTIVITY. THAT'S WHY COLLEAGUES
AT ASK YOU. MAKE CERTAIN YOU
DON'T GET SEDUCED BY THE
PARTISAN NATURE OF HOW THIS
ISSUE HAS ARISEN IN THE MEDIA.
THIS IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION NOT A THEOLOGICAL
QUESTION. THANK YOU SIR
BURGESS- CENTER HERTZBERG IS
YOUR MICHAEL. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. I COMPLETELY AGREE.
WITH MY COLLEAGUE. THAT THIS IS
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION. THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
PARTISANSHIP IT HAS TO DO WITH
THE SAKE RIGHTS. ENUMERATED THE
FIRST AMENDMENT OF THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION. CONGRESS
SHALL MAKE NO LAW WHETHER IT'S
FREE SPEECH FREE PRESS ASSEMBLY
OR RELIGION NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT. BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY HOW
THE CONSTITUTION'S BEEN
INTERPRETED. SIMPLE EXAMPLES
JUSTICE HOME SAID YOU CAN'T
YELL FIRE IN A CROWDED THEATER
WE HAVE RIGHT FREE SPEECH.
DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO SAY FREE
SPEECH HE'LL FIRED A CREDITOR
NO BECAUSE IT CREATES A CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER. TO TEST
WHETHER IT'S RELIGION OR
ASSEMBLY. OR OUR- SPEECH. IS
BALANCED BY AND POLICE POWER AS
WE TRY TO CREATE A WORKABLE
GOVERNMENT. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE RIGHTS ARE HELD
IN THE HIGHEST. SACRED NATURE
OF WHICH THEY ARE INFORMED AND
OUR CONSTITUTION BUT THERE IS
ALSO A BALANCE. SO NOW YOU HAVE
AN EXECUTIVE FACED WITH AN
EXTRAORDINARY EMERGENCY. THE
QUESTION IS OF COURSE UNDER
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES THEY
HAVE TO EXERCISE STRICT
SCRUTINY IN THAT REGARD. NO
QUESTION BUT A STRICT READING
OF WHAT WAS ARTICULATED HERE
AND WHAT'S ARTICULATED THIS
BILL IS THAT WERE BASICALLY
TURNING OVER THE POLICE POWERS
DETERMINATION OF WHAT SHOULD
AND SHOULDN'T DO TO THE COURTS
WERE ELIMINATING EXECUTIVES
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT THEIR
POWER IS TO MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS OF ALL OF US
SAID THERE'S AN OUTBREAK OF
LEPROSY. IF THERE'S A SHOOTER
THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT IT
HAPPENS TO HAVE A CHURCH AND WE
WANT TO IMPOSE A CURFEW BECAUSE
WE WANT TO PROTECT. PEOPLE FROM
GETTING SHOT AND THEY SAY WELL
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
RELIGIOUS OR I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO ASSEMBLE IN WHATEVER MY
ORGANIZATIONS COULD BE THE
QANTAS CLUB I'M SORRY THE
GOVERNMENT HAS A POLICE POWER.
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND IF
YOU IF YOU ANALYZE THE CASES I
HAVE READ IN. ATTENDED VERSES
NEWSOME IT CAME DOWN APRIL
NINTH I THINK THAT THE GUIDANCE
BASICALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS
ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS IT SEEMS
TO ME IN READING THIS CASE. IS
THAT IT'S REALLY A FACT BASED
CASE THAT THE EXECUTIVE RDER
SHOULD HAVE MORE CLEARLY
ARTICULATE GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THIS RELATES TO FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS OF ASSEMBLY OR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS OF RELIGION.
IT SHOULD HAVE MORE CLEARLY
ARTICULATED THIS BUT IN ESSENCE
WHAT JUSTICE. KAGAN SAYS JOIN
WITH. R. J. BRYER JUST TO SORT
OF MY ORDER. SHE TALKS ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHETHER THERE'S A RISK
OR NOT. IN IN LOOKING AT THE
COURT AND THEY MAKE THREE
POINTS FIRST WHEN PEOPLE GATHER
IN SOCIAL SETTINGS THE
INTERACTIONS ARE LIKELY TO BE
LONGER. THAN THEY WOULD BE IN A
COMMERCIAL SETTING AND LOOKING
AT THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
TAPPING THE COMMERCIAL CONTEXT.
PERSON ASSEMBLY WHETHER IT'S
RELIGIOUS OTHERWISE SECONDLY.
RIVA HOUSE ARE TYPICALLY
SMALLER AND LESS VENTILATED.
THAN COMMERCIAL ESTABLISHMENT
THIRD SOCIAL DISTRICTS AGAIN
MASS WEARING ARE LESS LIKELY IN
PRIVATE SETTINGS IN ENFORCEMENT
IS MORE DIFFICULT. IN OTHER
ORDS SHE TOOK THIS THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO DO THE
DIAGNOSTIC IN THAT REGARD. BUT
THE PRINCIPLES REMAIN THE SAME.
IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO RUN A
GOVERNMENT. IF YOU STIFF IF
YOU'RE TERM PROTECTION OF THE
CONSTITUTION. AS SET FORTH IN
THIS MEASURE WAS SO STRICT.
THAT IT LITERALLY NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENED YOU'D BE TO
FEARFUL. THAT YOU COULD NOT
ENGAGE THE POLICE POWER TO DEAL
WITH. WHATEVER THE ISSUE WAS
BECAUSE YOU'RE TOO WORRIED THAT
THE STRICT INTERPRETATION OF
THE LAWS WRITTEN WOULD
ELIMINATE YOUR ABILITY DO SO.
SO YES THESE ARE SACRED RIGHTS
BUT THEIR BALANCE FOR ALL OF US
IN SOCIETY BECAUSE WE LIVE
TOGETHER WE WORK TOGETHER WE
LIVE IN TH SAME COMMUNITIES.
TO BE ABLE TO WORK TO MAKE IT.
UNDERSTANDABLE IN A WORKABLE
WAY THIS IS A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT AFFECTED ALL ELEMENTS. OF
THE YOU THAT YOU SEE THAT
STATES BUT THE GLOBE. AND SO
THAT REGARD. I THINK THAT- THAT
THIS MEASURE YES- PROPERLY
CHARACTERIZED BY MY COLLEAGUES
AND FRESNO. IT I TAKE A
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATION. AND
WOULD NOT SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. HOT SEEING
NO OTHER MY- THAT ARE ALL.
SENATOR BOARD JUST MOVES THE
BILL. SENATOR JOHN SECURE CLOSE.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DO WANT TO THANK
BOTH THE- THE SENATOR IN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
OPPOSITION FOR THEIR WELL
THOUGHT OUT AND- RESPECTFUL
COMMENTS. MISTER CHAIR I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THAT- I THINK
YOU'VE VERY FAIRLY. CONDUCTED
THE HEARING AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR DILIGENCE IN- LISTENING TO
THE SUPPORTERS. OF THE BILL-
I'M GONNA THINK ALSO THE ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT TESTIFIED TODAY
THAT HAVE WAITED A LONG TIME TO
BE ABLE TO SHARE THEIR VOICES
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. WE
RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS- SO THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR
FROM JUST A SELECT PORTION OF
THEM TODAY AND THAT SEVEN
THOUSAND. IS ACROSS THE STATE-
WHEN WE INTRODUCED THIS BILL. I
WAS OVERWHELMED WITH MEDIA
REQUESTS AND- COMMENTS FROM ALL
OVER THE STATE. AND WHAT ARE
OUR INTENTION IS TO COMMUNICATE
IF YOU'RE CONSTITUENTS REACH
OUT TO OUR OFFICE AT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THAT
COMMUNICATION FROM YOUR OWN
CONSTITUENTS. I HAVE A COUPLE
FINAL THOUGHTS BEFORE WE VOTE
NOW FIRST AS WE KNOW THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT HAD TO INTERVENE
TWICE. IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS
WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S. WHEN THE
GOVERNOR SOUGHT TO COMPLETELY
SHUT DOWN HOUSES OF WORSHIP THE
SUPREME COURT RULED THAT WHILE
THE GOVERNOR CAN IMPOSE.
REASONABLE SAFETY RESTRICTIONS
AND LIMITS. I GOVERNOR CANNOT
ARBITRARILY PADLOCK CHURCHES
SHRINES TEMPLES MOSQUES AND
SYNAGOGUES. EVEN THE DISSENTERS
IN THESE DECISIONS BELIEVE THAT
THE GOVERNOR CANNOT ARBITRARILY
TREAT RELIGION DIFFERENTLY THAN
SIMILAR SECULAR ACTIVITIES. AS
JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR WAS QUOTED
THE- EARLIER- QUARTER AGAIN.
QUOTE THEY MAY RESTRICTED
TENDENCY TO HOUSES OF WORSHIP
SO LONG AS COMPARED WILL
SECULAR INSTITUTIONS FACE
RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE AT LEAST
EQUALLY AS STRICT. END QUOTE.
THIS SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR IT
AFTER THE RULING IN FEBRUARY
THE COURT HAD TO STEP IN AGAIN
ON FRIDAY NIGHT AND RAIN IN OUR
GOVERNOR THIS TIME FOR IN HOME
PRIVATE RELIGIOUS GATHERINGS MY
POINT IS THAT WHILE I BELIEVE
THE COURT GOT THESE RULINGS
RIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT A
FUTURE GOVERNOR DURING A FUTURE
EMERGENCY DOESN'T I TRY THIS
AGAIN. WE NEED TO GUARANTEE THE
RIGHT TO PRACTICE ONE'S
RELIGION. IN STATE LAW. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY SEVEN WILL DO
THIS SIMPLY. DECLARING THAT
RELIGION IS ESSENTIAL AND
SHOULD BE ON EQUAL FOOTING.
WITH ALL OTHER SERVICES AND
INDUSTRIES. DESIGNATED AS
ESSENTIAL DURING AN EMERGENCY.
SECOND WE HAVE SEEN THE
FRIGHTENING STATISTICS ABOUT
THE AFFECT GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWNS
IN ISOLATION ARE HAVING ON OUR
FAMILIES OUR FRIENDS AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS. FEELINGS OF
DEPRESSION ARE REPORTED TO BE
UP AS HIGH AS FORTY TWO
PERCENT. ANXIETY IS UP FOURTEEN
PERCENT. DRUG OVERDOSES ARE UP
5017% BINGE DRINKING IS UP 14%
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AS FAR AS WE
KNOW IS UP NINE PERCENT. NUMBER
SIX V. BEGINNING TO SEE MORE
AND MORE REPORTS IN THE AND THE
NEWS MEDIA A TEEN AND YOUTH
SUICIDE- AND ATTEMPTS. I COULD
GO ON AND ON. BUT WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNMENT ORDERED
SHUTDOWNS HAVE EXASPERATED
THESE NUMBERS. ARE ALL OF THESE
INCREASES DUE SOLELY TO THE
CLOSURE OF HOUSES OF WORSHIP OF
COURSE NOT. IT HAS CERTAINLY
BEEN A CONTRIBUTING FACTOR FOR
MANY. ALL THIS BILL ASKS IS FOR
THE PEOPLE OF EVERY COLOR. READ
GENDER AGE REGION LIFESTYLE AND
POLITICAL PERSUASION. ABLE TO
ENGAGE IN THEIR FREEDOM TO
PRACTICE THEIR RELIGION WITH
THEIR FELLOW PRACTITIONERS. WE
HAVE A RIGHT TO SAFELY SHOP IN
A CROWDED BIG BOX STORE SURELY
WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO SAFELY
ATTEND RELIGIOUS SERVICES. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
STRAIGHT FORWARD AND CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT MAJOR THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL- BENNETT CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU'D CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY SEVEN
BY SENATOR JONES WITH A MOTION
BY SENATOR BOARD YES THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION-
BURKE NO. AMBERG NO PORGES.
FORGES I CARRY IT ON NOT
PUTTING. IT ON NOT VOTING DID
ASAL. GONZALEZ. NO GONZALEZ NO
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG NO JONES HI
JONES I LAYERED NO BLARED NO
STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI NO WAY
CASKEY NO WIENER. HE PUT THE
BILL ON CALL TO FIVE SO FAR ON
CALL OKAY. BILLS ON CALL. WE
NEXT MOVED TO CENTER LEVELS
BILL SB THREE THREE ONE. SENATE
LABOR THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
STRUCTURE GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT
TO FIRST THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
MUCH APPRECIATED SENATE BILL
THREE THREE ONE ALSO KNOWN AS
THE SILENCE NO MORE ACT EXPANDS
THE PROHIBITION ON
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS ALSO
KNOWN AS NDAS IN SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS INVOLVING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SEXUAL ASSAULT
SEXUAL DISCRIMINATION TO COVER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
INVOLVING. ALL FORMS OF
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION
THIS BILL ALSO EXPANDS THE
PROHIBITION ON OVERLY BROAD
CONFIDENTIALITY AND NON
DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSES IN
EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENTS TO COVER
WORKERS WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
SIGN THESE TYPES OF CLAUSES AS
PART OF A SEVERANCE PACKAGE. AS
YOU MAY REMEMBER I AUTHORED AND
THEN GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED INTO
LAW SB EIGHT TWENTY ALSO KNOWN
AS A STAND ACT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SB EIGHT TWENTY
SPECIFICALLY BANNED
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS TO
CASES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SEX
DISCRIMINATION. IMPORTANTLY THE
ACT ALSO PERMITS THE CLAIMANTS
REQUEST CONFIDENTIALITY IF THEY
SO CHOOSE. NOTHING THIS
HISTORIC LAW THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZE THAT SECRET
SETTLEMENTS OR HELPING TO
PERPETRATE HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENTS BY ALLOWING
COMPLAIN TENDS TO BE SWEPT
UNDER THE RUG. OF COURSE SECRET
SETTLEMENTS PLAY AS MUCH OF A
ROLE IN PERPETUATING WORK
DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT AND
BIAS BASED ON RACE ETHNICITY
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AGE
DISABILITY AND RELIGION.
BECAUSE HERE TO COMPLAIN TENS
OR CAPS THE COMPLAINTS ARE KEPT
SECRET AND THOSE WHO RAISE THE
COMPLAINTS ARE EFFECTIVELY
SILENCED. MEMBERS IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE FOR ANY EMPLOYER
TO TRY TO SILENCE A WORKER
BECAUSE HE OR SHE WAS A VICTIM
OF ANY TYPE OF HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION DISCRIMINATION.
SB THREE THREE ONE WILL EMPOWER
SURVIVORS TO SPEAK OUT IF THEY
SO WISH SO THE PERPETRATORS CAN
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND WE CAN
HOPEFULLY PREVENT ABUSERS FROM
CONTINUING TO TORMENT AND ABUSE
OTHER WORKERS. LASTLY I'M
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THAT WILL MAKE CLEAR THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT PREVENT AN
EMPLOYER FROM INCLUDING A
RELEASE OF CLAIMS AND A
SEVERANCE AGREEMENT. IT DOES
NOT PREVENT AN EMPLOYER FROM
PROHIBITING THE DISCLOSURE OF
ANY AMOUNT OF PAID. ANY AMOUNT
PAID ANY SETTLEMENT OR
SEVERANCE AGREEMENT AND IT OF
COURSE DOES NOT PREVENT AN
EMPLOYER FROM PROHIBITING THE
DISCLOSURE OF TRADE SECRETS
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION OR
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION THAT
DOES NOT INVOLVE UNLAWFUL ACTS
IN THE WORKPLACE. HERE WITH ME
REMOTELY TO TESTIFY TO SHARE
HER OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS
THE FORMER OSAMA. N. AS WELL
PETER BROOK IN THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU SIR
LEYVA- MISS OZTUMER THE FIRST.
TWO MINUTES FOR EACH OF YOU.
MISS OSAMA IF YOU ARE. THE
CLOSURE GET. SHARE AMERICAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY MY ENTIRE CAREER HAS BEEN
AS A TAX PUBLIC POLICY
OFFICIALS USUALLY ENGAGING WITH
OFFICES LIKE YOURS ON BEHALF OF
LARGE COMPANIES LIKE GOOGLE
FACEBOOK AND PENTRE. BACK MY
LAST WORK TRIP BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC SHUT DOWN PROBLEM ALL
WHAT COULD BE SEATED FOR THAT
WORK AYE LAD ON HEALTH
MISINFORMATION. THAT WAS JUST
DAYS BEFORE PINTEREST LAWYERS
PRESENTED ME WITH A HIGHLY
RESPECTED THE NDA THAT WAS
MEANT TO KEEP ME SILENT ABOUT
THE RACE AND GENDER
DISCRIMINATION AND RETALIATION
CLAIMS THAT I AGREED QUIETLY
OVER THE PREVIOUS YEAR. WHEN I
EVENTUALLY DECIDED TO COME
FORWARD PUBLICLY I ALONG WITH
THE COURAGEOUS FORMER COLLEAGUE
NAMED ERICA COMMUNITY BANK. DID
SO WITH THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
WOULD BE COVERED FOR
DISCLOSURES RELATED TO GENDER
BASED DISCRIMINATION UNDER AT
EIGHT TWENTY WHICH WERE SO
GRATEFUL TO SENATOR LEYVA FOR
OFFERING DURING THE ME TOO
pBLACK WOMEN WE COULD NOT
DISENTANGLE OUR RATE FOR MY
GENDER WHICH MEANT THAT MENTION
OF THE RACE DISCRIMINATION WE
IN DEREK COULD RESULT IN LEGAL
RETALIATION. NO OTHER WORKERS
SHOULD BE IN A POSITION WHERE
PART OF THEIR IDENTITY ISN'T
COVERED WHEN IT COMES TO
DISCLOSING EXPERIENCES. OF
DISCRIMINATION. AND HE IS LIKE
THE I NO CLUE BUT TO SIGN OUR
USED BY. ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WORKERS UP ON TO MENTALLY
AMERICANS EACH RIGHT. IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC HOW MANY
WORKERS CAN REFUSE TO SIGN ONE
OF THESE AGREEMENTS. AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE INCOME OUR
HEALTH INSURANCE FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES. WHAT'S
WORSE IS THAT COMPANIES DON'T
EVEN NEED TO AND BE ABLE TO
KEEP THEIR PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION SAY. THAT INFO IS
ALREADY PROTECTED TO THE EAST
OF CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS
EMPLOYEES MIGHT FIND WHEN
THEY'RE HIRED. FINALLY THIS
BILL MY DAUGHTER GREEN. COULD
ALSO BENEFIT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY BY INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY FOR SHAREHOLDERS.
UNLESS INDIVIDUALS SPEAK UP
SHAREHOLDERS ARE OFTEN KEPT IN
THE DARK ABOUT MISCONDUCT AT
THE COMPANIES IN WHICH THEY
HAVE A FINANCIAL STAKE. SB
THREE THIRTY ONE AM
DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT BUT MY. HOPE IS THAT IT
WILL AND THE- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS OSAMA MISTER RICH IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- I'M AN EMPLOYMENT
ATTORNEY IN OAKLAND. OVER THE
COURSE OF MY CAREER I
REPRESENTED EMPLOYERS PUBLIC
ENTITIES AN EMPLOYEE. IN A
VARIETY OF EMPLOYMENT DISPUTES
REVIEWING AND NEGOTIATING
SETTLEMENT AND SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS AS A AS A LARGE PART
OF MY PRACTICE- I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIAN
PLANET LAWYERS ASSOCIATION. AND
IT MISSES SOME OF THE TOURNEY-
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB THREE
THREE ONE WILD NON
DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSES AND SEVEN
SCREAMIN. HAPPY COME MORE
COMMON OVER THE PAST FEW
DECADES THEY HAVE LITTLE SOCIAL
VALUE AND WHY SHOULD.
CALIFORNIANS LOOK FOR A SAFE
PLACE TO WORK UNABLE TO GATHER
INFORMATION ON GLASS DOOR FOR
EXAMPLE. BECAUSE FRMER
EMPLOYEES ARE TERRIFIED OF
PUBLICLY THING TRUTHFUL THINGS
ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES OF
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION.
IN FACT RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
THE AVAILABILITY OF NON
ANONYMOUS INFORMATION GLASSDOOR
ACTUALLY INCREASED AFTER SB
EIGHT TWENTY. RESTRICTED THE
USE OF SECRET SETTLEMENTS. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT OPPONENT OF SB
THREE THREE ONE ARGUE THAT THE
BILL WILL DISCOURAGE EMPLOYERS
FROM PAYING SEVERANCE TO
WORKERS AND I HAVE TO NOTE THAT
A SIMILAR ACCUSATION WAS MADE
ABOUT SB EIGHT TWENTY THAT WITH
THAT IF YOU TAKE AWAY THE NDA.
PARTIES WON'T BE ABLE TO SETTLE
CASES AND I CAN SAY THAT IN MY
EXPERIENCE THAT IS NOT THAT HAS
NOT HAPPENED. WHEN NDAS WERE
TAKEN OFF THE TABLE THEY JUST
NO LONGER BECAME A PART OF THE
NEGOTIATION. WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT THE TRUE VALUE IN A
SEVERANCE AGREEMENT AND RELEASE
THE CLIENT NOT. HE CHRISSY
PROVISION. A RELEASE AVOID THE
POSSIBILITY OF MONTHS OR YEARS
OF LITIGATION THE POTENTIAL AN
ADVERSE JUDGMENT. FURTHER I I'D
ARGUE THAT THE SECRECY
PROVISIONS ARE EFFECTIVELY
ENFORCEABLE- IN MY THIRTY YEARS
OF LAW PRACTICE THE ONLY
ENFORCEMENT ACTION I. CAN
REMEMBER BEING AWARE OF WHAT'S
DONALD TRUMP'S CLAIM AGAINST
OUR BEGAN AGAIN. NO RATIONAL
PLAYERS TO TWENTY FORCING NON
DISPARAGEMENT CAUGHT DOING SO
COMPLETELY PUBLICIZED. THE
ALLEGED DISPARAGING COMMENTS
BUT WE KNOW IS THAT THE TRUE
VALUE IN THESE PROVISIONS AS
THEIR INTERIM FACT AWAY TO
INTIMIDATE EMPLOYEES THE THING
STYLE AND EVEN ABOUT UNLAWFUL
DISCRIMINATION OR HARASSMENT.
IT'S NOT ONLY HURTS WORKERS
ENDANGERS PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
PUBLIC GOOD AND DOES A
DISSERVICE TO LAW ABIDING
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE COMPETING FOR
EMPLOYEES IN THE JOB MARKET WE
URGE THE TWENTY TO VOTE YES ON
SB THREE THREE ONE. THANK YOU
MR AGAIN IF YOU WOULD STICK
AROUND HERE- UNTIL WE TAKE
OTHER SUPPORT OPPOSITION- I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT YEAH OF COURSE. C. NOLAN
NELSON MCGARY- IN SUPPORT IF
YOU'D TURN TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
NO ONE IN ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR- IF THOSE
LAWRENCE SUPPORT WOULD QUEUE UP.
WILL TAKE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
MISTER MODERATOR AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT IT
IS ONE TWO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO PLACE
A LINE IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT IT IS
ONE NINE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
IF THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT. LET'S NOT TURN THE
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND THAT-
MISS ASHLEY HOFFMAN. IT IS IN
OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT
CENTER LABEL. I BELIEVE THAT
THE CHAMBER IS NO LONGER IN
OPPOSITION BUT SHE HAVE A MAY
HAVE A STATEMENT SHE WANTS TO
MAKE A ALL RIGHT IF MISS
HOFFMAN IS ON THE LINE. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD OPEN FOR
HER. THANK YOU THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS ACTUALLY
HOPPIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
I WANT TO START BY THINKING
FOUNDER LEYVA AND HER STAFF AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS- JUST
BECAUSE LOOKING AT A COUPLE
DAYS AGO WE ARE PRESENTLY
REVIEWING THOSE AMENDMENTS WITH
OUR MEMBERS. AND WILL ISSUE A
LETTER NOTING ANY CHANGE IN OUR
POSITION APPROPRIATE- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY I DO NOT
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF WE HAVE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION IT IS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT MISTER
MAYOR ON THE LINE THANK YOU IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU WOULD TO THEM UP PLEASE.
AND AGAIN IF THERE IS ANYON
WHO'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP A
PROPOSITION IT IS ONE DIDN'T
ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO LINES
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET ME TURN TO THE GALLERY I
THINK I DID TURN THE GALLERY
THERE'S NO IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION AND JUST TO BE SURE
ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE
CHAMBER- LET ME GO TO MISTER
BROKEN FOR JUST ONE MOMENT-
MISTER REGAN IS STILL WITH US.
OR OR CENTER LEVEL NINE AM TO
TAKE THIS QUESTION. PROBABLY
THE ATTORNEY WOULD BE BEST
SUITED TO ASK THE QUESTION. ALL
RIGHT SO- MR RUBIN. I REALIZE
THERE'S A DANGER EXTRAPOLATING
FROM LIMITED EXPERIENCE OF THE
GENERAL CASE IN MY LIMITED
EXPERIENCE THAT- THE- LEVERAGE
POINT WITH RESPECT TO NON
DISPARAGEMENT AND NON
DISCLOSURE IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
VALUE THAT THE VICTIM. MAY BE
GIVING UP IN I UNDERSTAND- THIS
BILL IS THAT IT IS STILL
POSSIBLE TO NEGOTIATE A NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT AT SOME
POINT IN TIME IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT IN IT I MEAN I
THINK THOSE. THEY'RE GOVERNED
BY ONE THOUSAND ONE YEAH RIGHT
IT WOULD POINT IN THE PROCESS
FROM POINT OF INCIDENT TO
RESOLUTION CAN YOU ENTER INTO A
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENT. WHILE
IT ACTED SO WITH THIS THIS BILL
FILLS A GAP THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW YOU
KNOW WE HAVE WE HAVE BUT THE
LEGAL PARADIGM THAT SAYS YOU
CAN'T HAVE. NDA AS A CONDITION
OF EMPLOYMENT AND WE ALSO HAVE
A PROCEDURE- THANKS THE SENATE
AWAY THIS BILL A TWENTY THAT.
THAT DRESSES- NONDISCLOSURE
PROVISIONS IN THE COUNTRY THE
SETTLEMENT BUT WHAT WAS MISSING
HERE IS- A. A- A PROVISION THAT
DEALT WITH NONDISCLOSURE. I
AGREEMENTS NON DISPARAGEMENT
CLAUSES THAT WERE BEING IMPOSED
ON WORKERS KIND OF AT THE AT
THE POINT OF SEPARATION OF
EMPLOYMENT AND SO NOW AT THAT
POINT UNDER UNDER THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION. BUT BACK KIND OF
PREVENT PROVISIONAL BE UNLAWFUL
UNLESS THERE WAS. AB A
COMPLAINT ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLAINT A COURT COMPLAINT OR
AN INTERNAL- COMPLAINT HAS BEEN
FILED- IN WHICH CASE WE WOULD
REVERT TO THE PROTECTION OF-
OF. THE ONE THOUSAND ONE. OKAY
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT I HAVE
NEGLECTED TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES IN TERMS SUPPORT I WILL
DO SO JUST SECOND BUT I JUST
WANT TO FOCUS FOR SECOND ON ON
NON DISCLOSURE IT BUT POINT
BETWEEN AN INCIDENT. AND THE
RESOLUTION CAN YOU. HAVE A
PROVISION THAT PROVIDES FOR NON
DISCLOSURE. WELL YOU CAN HAVE A
PROVISION PROVIDING FOR. YEAH
SO WHEN YOU THINK NONDISCLOSURE
YOU MEAN A NON DISPARAGEMENT
CLAUSES OR PROVISIONS THAT YOU
CAN'T DISCLOSE ANYTHING ABOUT
THE- SO THERE'S DEFINITELY IN
THE WORKPLACE NINE. I DON'T
WANT TO GET THE PUBLICLY BUT IS
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT. FILE ITEMS HERE ONE
IS A NON DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT
WITH THIS PROVISION AGREEMENT
SAYS YOU CANNOT DISCLOSE THE
TERMS OF THE SETTLEMENT. AND
THEN THERE'S ANOTHER. CONCEPT
AND THAT'S NON DISPARAGEMENT
WHERE YOU CAN'T DISPARAGE THE
OTHER PARTY. SO IN SEPARATING
THE TWO- IT SOME POINT BETWEEN
INCIDENT AND RESOLUTION YOU CAN
NEGOTIATE A NONDISCLOSURE
PROVISION AGREEMENT POLICE TO
SARS I UNDERSTAND IS THAT RIGHT.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY YOU KNOW
WHAT POINT BETWEEN INCIDENT AND
RESOLUTION CAN YOU NEGOTIATE A
PROVISION THAT PROVIDES FOR NON
DISCLOSURE. WELL SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF THERE WAS A COURT COMPLAINT
FILED THERE WAS A MINISTER THE
COMPLAINT FILED THE DEPARTMENT
SHAREPOINT IN HOUSING- YOU
COULD- YOU COULD GET THE IF YOU
WERE. YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU
FOLLOW THE PROCEDURES AND ONE
THOUSAND ONE- YOU YOU CAN BE
YOU CAN BE PREVENTED ONCE YOU
FILE THE MINISTER COMPLAINED
THE COR COMPLAINT YOU CAN BE
PREVENTED I'M- FROM HAVING A-
NONDISCLOSURE PROVISION IF. IF
THERE IF THE RESOLUTION IS
HAPPENING BEFORE THAT. YOU
CAN'T RIGHT SO THAT NOBODY WAS
MY QUESTION FORTY ONE THOUSAND
ONE YEAH SO PRIOR TO FILING A
COMPLAINT YOU CAN PROVIDE FOR
NON DISCLOSURE BUT ONCE YOU
FILE THE COMPLAINT IT IS
ILLEGAL TO HAVE A RESOLUTION
INCLUDES A NONDISCLOSURE
PROVISION IS THAT. ACCURATE
RIGHT OKAY. NOW LET'S TURN TO
NON DISPARAGEMENT IT WHAT POINT
IN THE SEQUENCE OF EVENTS THAT
JUST DESCRIBED FROM INCIDENT
THROUGH RESOLUTION CAN YOU
NEGOTIATED NON DISPARAGEMENT
AGREEMENT- PROVISION TO
AGREEMENT. RIGHT SO THAT THE
BILL UNDER THIS BY IT. YEAH
UNDER UNDER THIS BILL- IF YOU
HAVE A- A SEVERANCE AGREEMENT
WHERE THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
COURT ACTION FILE THERE'S
NOTHING. PAKISTAN NOT TENDERED
INTERNALLY TO THE COMPANY YOU
CAN'T HAVE A NON DISPARAGEMENT
CLAUSES IN. IN A SEPARATION
AGREEMENT BOTH IN AGREEMENT
WHERE THE EMPLOYEE KIND OF AS A
ROUTINE MATTER OF SEPARATING IT
HANDED A SEPARATION AGREEMENT
AND FIND THAT. AND DOESN'T HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO- CITY
COUNCIL AND HADN'T FILED
INTERNAL GRIEVANCE REGARDING B.
B. UNLAWFUL CONDUCT IN THE
WORKPLACE OR HAVE THEM CALL THE
COURT COMPLAINT THAT THEY CAN'T
BE BOUND BY A NON DISPARAGEMENT
CLAUSES THE PEERS AND THE- AND
YOU BRING THE- SO. FOR NON
DISCLOSURE YOU CAN NEGOTIATE
NONDISCLOSURE FTER A COMPLAINT
IS FILED BUT NON DISPARAGEMENT
YOU CANNOT AFTER A COMPLAINT IS
FILED IS THAT RIGHT. WELL AFTER
YOU KNOW AFTER A COMPLAINT
AFTER SOME AND AFTER SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE OR COURT
COMPLAINT FILED ON NON
DISCLOSURE SIDE. YOU CANNOT YOU
CANNOT- HAVE A I NINE OKAY
GALLAGHER SECTION SEMI
COMPLICIT AYE AND I RIVERS YOUR
CRITICAL RIGHT BUT I REVERSED
IT. RIGHT YEAH OKAY. AND SO IN
TERMS OF. THREADING THE NEEDLE
HERE FOR A CLIENT THEN AGAIN I
UNDERSTAND THE PUBLIC GOOD THAT
IS ATTENDED TO THIS MEASURE BUT
IN TERMS OF THREADING THE
NEEDLE- IN ADVISING A CLIENT
WITH RESPECT TO NON DISCLOSURE
AND NON DISPARAGEMENT IS THAT
BASICALLY THE STANDARD OF CARE
SO THAT YOU HAVE TO ADVISE A
CLIENT WHEN A CLIENT COMES IN
AS TO WHAT THEIR RIGHTS AND
REMEDIES ARE. EITHER BEFORE OR
AFTER THEY FILED A COMPLAINT
AND WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES ARE
IN TERMS OF NEGOTIATING EITHER
NON DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSE OR A
OR A NON DISCLOSURE COSTS. YEAH
I THINK I THINK IT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH
A CLIENT ABOUT AND IT'S USUALLY
NOT NECESSARILY THE PERSON
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHEN HE
COMES IN THE DOOR BUT AT SOME
POINT ONE RESOLUTION AS- IT
CONTEMPLATED THEIR- DISCUSSION.
THAT WE HAD. ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF FILING. A COURT
OR ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLAINT-
AND I MEAN THAT THAT THOSE ARE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING NOW IN YOUR SB EIGHT
TWENTY AND HAVE BEEN FOR THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS- AND SO YOU
KNOW YOU YOU HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS ARE FILING AN
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD ACTION.
ON SETTLEMENT BUT YOU KNOW I
WOULD KIND OF JUST REVERT BACK
TO MY EXPERIENCE- THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND OVER THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS NEGOTIATING SEVERANCE
ENTITLEMENT AGREEMENT. AND THAT
IS THAT IT'S REALLY AGAIN IN MY
EXPERIENCE IT'S ABOUT THE
RELEASE OF CLAIMS THAT THE
VALUE THAT'S BEING PAID. BY THE
EMPLOYER. IS FOR THE IS FOR THE
RELEASE I'M NOT FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY. FIVE I I'M
PUTTING ASIDE KIND OF BUT YOU
KNOW YOU WANT TELLING ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF SETTLEMENT ISSUE
WHICH- YOU KNOW. IS A DIFFERENT
ISSUE WHICH REALLY ISN'T
AFFECTED BY ANY OF THE BILL
THAT THAT SPOKE SPANISH BUT- IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW NONDISCLOSURE
OF EVENTS IN THE WORKPLACE. I
DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT OF THE
CONSIDERATION OF BEING PAID. HI
KAREN SO LOOK FOR THOSE ON THE
PHONE WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION HERE AND.
IN JUST A MOMENT I'LL I WANT
TO. UNDER SO. THE TERM OF
STANDARD PRACTICES OF CARE THE
EMPLOYMENT LAWYER WHEN SOMEONE
COMES IN WOULD THEY FALL BELOW
THE STANDARD CARE STANDARD
PRACTICE IF THEY DON'T ADVISED
THAT CLIENT OF THE CONSEQUENCES
OF EITHER FILING A COMPLAINT OR
NOT FALLING COMPLETED AND HOW
THAT IMPACTS POTENTIAL
SETTLEMENT. YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW THAT I WOULD I WOULD FRAME
IT AS FALLING BELOW THE
STANDARD CARE IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW I'D BE
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH A
CLIENT ABOUT BUT I MEAN I COULD
PROBABLY FILL A BUCKET LIKE
THAT WITH A HUNDRED DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT WE TALKED LEVINE
ABOUT BUT- YOU KNOW ONE OF THEM
PROBABLY WOULD BE WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF. PILING UP A
COURT COMPLAINT WOULD BE.
ENTITLEMENT BUT YOU KNOW AGAIN.
I THINK YOU KNOW. THE WAY THAT
ONE THOUSAND ONE STRUCTURE HAT
BEAT THEM. IF THE EMPLOYEE EVEN
AFTER FINAL COURT COMPLAINT
BOARD MINISTER. TWENTY FEEL
IMPORTANT TO KEEP THEIR OWN
IDENTITY CONFIDENTIAL. THEY CAN
REQUEST CONFIDENTIALITY UNDER
THAT UNDER THAT. THANK KNOW
SORRY BUT THIS ISN'T EVEN
ACTUALLY SEEN AS A SIGN OF GOOD
IT'S CONTAINED IN THE BILL I
JUST THINK WE'RE CREATING A
CHALLENGE TO MAKE SURE THAT
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS NEEDLE ARM IS I THINK
CHALLENGING TO BE THREADED AS
BETWEEN NON DISPARAGEMENT
NONDISCLOSURE AND AT WHAT POINT
THE LAW BECOMES OPERATIVE IS TO
WIN YOU CAN NEGOTIATED NON
DISCLOSURE WHEN YOU CAN
NEGOTIATE NON DISPARAGEMENT BUT
THAT'S NOT MY- RESPONSIBILITY
SO- THANK YOU FOR THAT-
EDUCATION LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES FIRST FOR SUPPORT
IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE
ONE NOW WOULD BE THE TIME TO
QUEUE UP I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET EVERYONE WHO'S. PREPARED
TO TESTIFY ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT. ABSOLUTELY ONCE AGAIN-
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND SURE THIS TIME IT
DOES LOOK LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT-
TEN IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT.
WILL FIRST MOVED TO NUMBER NINE
FIFTY NINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MISTER CARE
NUMBERS SCRIPTED RESPONSES
POLICY ADVOCATE THE WASHINGTON
ON LAMPARD REMAINS STRONG
SUPPORTER OF MEASURES. SIX NEXT
PLEASE BUT NEXT TO BE NUMBER
FOUR SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I WAS A PART OUR WASHING HANDS
THEN ON BEHALF OF COLOR OF
CHANGE AT THE CORE SB THREE
THIRTY BLESSING. THANK YOU.
CLOSE NEXT TO BE NUMBERS SIX
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT YEAH THE BILL FOR THIS.
SIX SEVEN ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES GO AHEAD YEAH SO WE CAN
HEAR YOU YEAH YOU HAVE TO. BE.
POSTMODERN EXCLUSION. ABSOLUE
MOVED A NUMBER NINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER NINE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINES OPEN. AN
YES CALLER NUMBER NINE FORTY
FIVE GO HEAD. HELLO NINE YEARS
AGO HADN'T HAD HIM AS A- AND
THE FORMER SOFTWARE ENGINEER AT
A LARGE COMPANY AND SUPPORT
YOURSELF THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
OUR NEXT AVAILABLE NUMBER NINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JUDY LORE AND AS A
FORMER. COWORKER I ALSO
STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER NINE THIRTY
TWO IS GOOD. HELLO THIS IS
ERICA SHE NEEDED BANKS FOUNDER
SHE FELL AND FORMER PINTEREST
EMPLOYEE AND I AM STRONG THE
PART OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS NUMBER NINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MADDIE TO ME NOW AND
THE FEMALE TECH EMPLOYEE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THE NUMBE OF THE
NUMBER NOT THREE NINETY SEVEN
THREE NINETY SEVEN THE GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KENNETH SO
AND I'M HONORED TO PROVIDE MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU. WILL NOW GO TO
NUMBER FIVE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT'S CATHERINE
CAMPBELL OF CALIFORNIA
PROTECTIVE PARENTS ASSOCIATION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THREE THREE ONE THANK YOU. NEXT
TO NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY THREE
PER MONTH NOW AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
SEVENTY NINETY ACRE LINES OPEN.
MOVED A NUMBER NINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
BRIAN AND I'M THE CEO FOUNDER
AND JEFF WORK IN HR EXECUTIVE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER FIVE
SIXTY SIX- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'LL MOVE THE NUMBER
THREE OH ONE THREE OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
RENDON CALLUM AND I'M CURRENTLY.
AND I STRONGLY SO THANK YOU.
HELLO NOW MOVED TO FOUR SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY
ATTACK ON BEHALF OF THE
COSPONSORED FOR SB THREE THREE
ONE ALL RIGHT ADVOCATE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND EARTHY AND
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER NINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A HOLLOW
LANE CALLING ON BEHALF OF TECH
EQUITY COLLABORATIVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE ONE.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
THREE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICHELMAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PROJECT CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR HOW MANY ELSE THE
ONLY OTHER CALLERS ARE LINED UP
IN SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU CAN I
KNOW WE LOOK FOR OPPOSITION
BOTH IN THE GALLERY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE AND FOUND NONE ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO. S. B. THREE
THREE ONE. AND NOW HERE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AGAIN OPPOSITION ONLY
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME- WE HAVE ABOUT SIX IN THE
QUEUE ALL RIGHT. I WILL START
WITH NUMBER NINE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A. B. SANTOS
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT HAVE BEEN REAL
PROBLEMS WITH THE PHONE LINES
TODAY THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS ALSO IN THIS
PLACE STRONG SUPPORT THIS IS MY
ENTIRE A MEETING WITH THE
NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT LAW PROJECT.
REPORTER SB THREE THREE ONE.
THANK YOU. I WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER SIX SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME THEIR OLSEN I'M
FROM THE LATINO MEDICAL STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. I
THANK YOU. NEXT IS NUMBER NINE
FIFTY SEVEN- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FONG YES GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS THE BABYLONIA AND I'M A
FORMER TECH WORKERS CURRENT
HARVARD LAW STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXUS NUMBER FIVE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD. I
OPPOSE BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY
YOU CAN IMPROVE THE SITUATION
AND IT'S SHAMEFUL YOU GUYS KEEP
LETTING THOSE UP. THANK YOU
MA'AM ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
MOST MODERATE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION YOU PLEASE
TURN THEM UP. YES NEXT IN THE
QUEUE WE HAVE NUMBER FIVE TEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM AGAIN I'M
A BLACK WOMAN INTACT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
RIGHT THANK YOU. THIS MODERATOR
ANYBODY NOT EXIST ON THE PHONE
LINE. WE HAVE ONE MORE IN THE
QUEUE- HENCE NUMBER. SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT. I ALSO DID NOT
GET TO VOICE MY SUPPORT SO VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORTING. THANK YOU
THREE BUT ALSO THE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR. I ONCE AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NONE IN THE QUEUE- PLEASE
CONTINUE ALREADY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF WE'RE GONNA NOW TURN TO
THE CHAMBER I SEE SENATE WHITE
HOUSE USE MICROPHONES UP YEAH
MISTER CHAIR I LIKE TO ASK THE
AUTHOR OF THE- THE ADVOCATES IF
I UNDERSTAND THE BILL'S GOING
TO YOU KNOW PROHIBITS- THE NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS THAT.
AFFECT UNLAWFUL HARASSMENT OR
BEHAVIOR RETALIATION AND AS
WELL AS HE'S- THE SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS FROM RESTRICTING-
SOMEBODY'S ABILITY TO TALK
ABOUT UNLAWFUL ACTS THAT WERE
CONDUCTED IN THE WORKPLACE. AND
THE BILL IN FRONT OF US TALKS
ABOUT THAT IN THE FIRST SECTION
LOOK WHEN I GET TO SECTOR
SECTION TWO I GUESS IS TO BE-
FOR BIG BE. LITTLE SEE LITTLE
LITTLE TO SEE IT TALKS ABOUT
INFORMATION ABOUT UNLAWFUL
ACCESS THIS DISCUSSION THAT
THEY HAVE AND AT ONE THIRTY
THREE IT TALKS ABOUT
ELIMINATING. I MEAN INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION AND THIS IS OR
ANY OTHER UNLAWFUL OR
POTENTIALLY UNLAWFUL CONTACT.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
LEGALLY MEANS. I THINK I KNOW
WHAT I'M AWFUL BECAUSE IS TEN.
NON UNLAWFUL CONDUCT I'M IN THE
NON DISPARAGEMENT AGREEMENT
WHAT WORKS WHAT WOULD THAT
INCLUDE OR NOT INCLUDE SENATOR
AKOWSKI I BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
IT THE TO THE CHAIR SURE- THAT
THAT MEANS THAT SOMETHING THAT
IS UNKNOWN AT THE TIME AND IT
COULD BE UNLAWFUL BUT IF FIVE
MISTER RECKONED WOULD LIKE TO
ANSWER I WOULD DEFER TO HIM. MR
RUBIN ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YEAH
SO IT CAN I CAN I JUMP INTO THE
PETER AGAIN YES PLEASE. YEAH I
SO I BELIEVE I DON'T HAVE A
LINE ITEM- VERSION WHERE IT HAS
THE LINE NUMBERS FROM THE SIDE
BUT I BELIEVE. WHAT THE CENTERS
REFERRING TO IS ACTUALLY A
PROVISION THAT THAT- BEING
AMENDED ALREADY- THAT HER LEYVA
HAS PROPOSED WHICH WHICH REALLY
JUST. CONVERT THAT- THE
LANGUAGE ENTER RIGHT TO
REASONABLE BELIEF. SO ATTRACT
EXISTING WHISTLEBLOWER STATUTE-
ONE OR TWO POINT FIVE ANOTHER
STATUTES IN CALIFORNIA TALK
ABOUT. IN A POLICE REASONABLE
BELIEF. ABOUT I'M CONDUCTIVITY
HAVE TO BE RIGHT BUT THE
EMPLOYEE HAVE TO HAVE A
REASONABLE LEAF- IN ORDER. FOR
TO FALL WITHIN THE PROTECTED.
YEAH ASSEMBLY CASKEY THAT'S
OKAY THANK YOU FOR READING FOR
NOTHING ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE I
SEE NO OTHER MICROPHONES UP-
ALL RIGHT SIR LEVY CARE CLOSE I
DO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR ALL I REALLY WANT TO
THANK MR ROUTE CAN FOR BE ABLE
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS WHEN
WE DID SB EIGHT TWENTY THESE
WERE THE MANY OF THE SAME
QUESTIONS OF THE OPPOSITION
ALICE AND I APPRECIATE THAT HE
WAS ABLE TO GIVE YOU THE
ANSWERS THAT YOU NEEDED TODAY
AND ALSO TO HEAR FROM HIM THAT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
THOUGHT WOULD BEAR OUT IF EIGHT
TWENTY BECAME LAW. HAVE NOT
ACTUALLY DONE THAT AND HAVE
ACTUALLY PROTECTED MOSTLY WOMEN
IN THEIR WORKPLACES SO THIS IS
JUST A NATURAL EXTENSION THREE
THREE ONE SILENCE NO MORE IS
THE- EVERY EXTENSION OF EIGHT
SB EIGHT TWENTY I ALSO WANT TO
THANK MS SHE MISSES. HIM IS OF
SO MUCH FOR COMING FORWARD AND
TELLING THEIR STORY NONE OF US
REALLY KNOW THE COURAGE IT
TAKES TO DO THAT AND IF THEY
HADN'T BEEN WILLING TO COME
FORWARD I WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY PRESENTING THIS BILL SO I
THINK THEM FOR THEIR COURAGE
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING
THIS TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK IF
IT GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY
AND CHANGING THE WORKPLACE UP
AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
LINE I AGREE WITH YOU I THINK
IT TAKES A GREAT. DEAL OF
COURAGE TO COME FORWARD ATTY. I
WAVING THIS GIVING UP THIS
RIGHT ACTUALLY HAS A COST AND
THAT COST. THE SOCIETAL GOOD
IS. OF PARAMOUNT BUT THERE IS A
COST I THINK TO THE- FUTURE
VICTIMS BUT THAT THAT'S NOT OUR
JOB OUR JOB IS TO WORRY ABOUT
IN MY VIEW SOCIETAL GOOD SO.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL- IS
OUR MOTION. SENATE GONZALEZ
MOVES THE BILL. MENTIONED
CANCER CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
THAT SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
WHEN BY SENATOR AT LEAVE ON
MOTION BY SENATOR GONZALEZ-
DATE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE HI
UMBERG AYE BURGESS. CABALLERO
HI. I DID ALSO. HERTZBERG I'D
JONES. LAYERED HI LAYERED I
STERN WHITE CAL SKI WHY CASKEY
AYE WIENER. IF SIXTY ZERO SO
FAR THANK YOU PUT THAT ON CALL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. NEXT I SEE SOME OF THE
MALL WHO'S ONLINE- CERTAIN
AMOUNT THIS BILL WAS ORIGINALLY
ON CONSENT IS NO LONGER ON
CONSENT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU CHECK AND SENATORS.
SB SIX THIRTY THREE GIVES NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING CO SIGNERS
IMPORTANT INFORMATION PROTECTS
CONSUMERS FROM FRAUD WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING MORE STABILITY TO
BUSINESSES. THIS BILL REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY TO TRANSLATE. AND PLACE
ON THEIR WEBSITES AND NOTICED A
CO SIGNERS THIS NOTICE WILL BE
TRANSLATED INTO BY THE FIVE
MOST COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGES
IN CALIFORNIA AND BE PUT ON A
SINGLE WEB PAGE. THE NOTICE
MUST ONLY BE PROVIDED CO
SIGNERS WHEN THE BUSINESS KNOWS
OR HAS REASON TO KNOW THE
COSIGNER DOES NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH. THE DISCLOSURE PUTS
THE COSIGNER ON THE NOTICE THAT
THEY ARE LIABLE FOR THE
CONTRACT AND DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE BUSINESS TRANSLATE THE
ENTIRE CONTRACT. THIS NOTICE
WILL PROVIDE THE COSIGNER WITH
THE ESSENTIAL INFORMATION BUT
ALSO PROTECT THE BUSINESS BY
GIVING THEM A TOOL FOR
ENFORCEMENT TO COMBAT PLANES
FROM CO SIGNERS OF THE CONTRACT
IS. AN UNENFORCEABLE BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT UNDERSTAND THEIR
OBLIGATIONS. TODAY ON THE LINE
WE HAVE AYE DADDY CONDO KAISER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND DESIREE
NEW IN ORDERS FROM THE JUSTICE
AND DIVERSITY CENTER OF THE BAR
ASSOCIATION OF SAN FRANCISCO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
PLEASE THANK YOU CENTER THE
MALL- OF MISCONDUCT GEYSER IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE. PLEASE
PROCEED. I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME
ALRIGHT WE CAN GO AHEAD. GREAT
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
MY NAME IS DANIELLE KENDO
KREIDER AND I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION. A COALITION OF
FOURTEEN LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS FROM AROUND THE STATE.
WE THINK BOTH THE AUTHOR IN THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION FOR THE
TIME THEY SPENT WORKING WITH
CLICK ON THIS BILL. SB SIX
THREE THREE AMEND CIVIL CODE
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO BY REQUIRING
THAT A NOTICE BE PROVIDED TO A
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING COSIGNER.
AS THE SENATOR INDICATED IN THE
NOTICE WILL BE POSTED ON BC AS
AGENTS PUBLIC WEBSITE WHERE IT
CAN EASILY BE ACCESSED BY
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE YOU CO
SIGNERS. CURRENTLY MORE THAN
44% OF CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS
SPEAK A LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH. WELL EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES A CONTRACT THAT'S
NEGOTIATED IN SPANISH TAGALOG
CHINESE VIETNAMESE OR KOREAN TO
BE PROVIDED TO THE PERSON WHO
WOULD BE TO GO SHE THAT THAT
CONTRACT. THE SAME PROTECTION
IS CANCELED OUT FOR CO SIGNERS
WHEN THE BORROWER ACTS AS A
TRANSLATOR FOR THE COSIGNER.
GROCERS ARE FREQUENTLY NEEDED
IN CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS A
COMMON EXAMPLE INCLUDES COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO REQUIRE A PARENT
TO CO SIGN ON HOUSING OR YOUNG
ADULTS WHO NEEDS MOM OR DAD TO
HELP THEM BUY THEIR FIRST CAR.
AND IN THE EVENT THAT THE
ORIGINAL PARTY TO THE
CONTRACTORS THAT ARE NOT
TRUTHFUL OR HAD NOT THE FILTER
REQUIREMENTS IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT THE COSIGNER BE MADE AWARE
AT THE TIME THE SIGNING OF
THEIR FINANCIAL LIABILITY. THE
PURPOSE OF SB SIX THREE THREE
AND TO GIVE THE COSIGNER FAIR
NOTICE THAT THEY ARE
UNDERTAKING FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS AND THAT THEY
SHOULD INVESTIGATE THE TERMS OF
THEIR CONTRACT. SB SIX THREE
THREE PROTECT NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING CALIFORNIANS FROM
FRAUD AND MISREPRESENTATION.
AND IT PROTECTS BUSINESSES FROM
ENTERING AGREEMENTS WITH
PARTIES WHO CANNOT CONSENT TO
THE TERMS. LESS GIVING
BUSINESSES MORE CONTRACT
ENFORCEMENT POWER. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IDENTITY. THANK YOU MISS KIND
OF KAISER- MISS WHEN OR IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE. YES THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DESIREE WENT LARGE AND
I AM THE SUPERVISING ATTORNEY
AT THE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
PROJECTS THAT THE JUSTICE NEVER
SEE CENTER AT THE PARK THE
TEACHING OF DIFFERENT
DISCOUNTS. MY CLIENT CODE ONE
NATURALIZE MONOLINGUAL CITIZENS
WERE TLD BY HER EMPLOYER THE
CAR DEALERSHIP PEOPLE. HURT YOU
NEEDED HER TO FIND SOME PAPERS.
WHERE AND THE DEALERSHIP EVERY
AT THE CONFERENCE AND HIGHER
LEAN MUCH. WHAT SHE ASKED HER
WHERE SHE WOULD HAVE TO PAY AND
THE CONTRACT. HE SAID NOW. WHEN
YOU CLEAR THE TREES THE METAL
PAYMENTS AND PAYING ONLY. THE
QUESTION CALL CONNECTION. GO ON
START. AND NOW IT HAS THE FIRST
ONE THAT SHOULD CONTRACT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CARLAND.
LAST YEAR. THREE TO FIVE FOUR
WHICH- SUPPORTED MISTER. AND
EVENTUALLY PASSED THE FIRST
AFTER PROVIDING CALIFORNIANS HE
FINANCE RIGHT. I SIX THREE
THREE. NOT BUILT BY A LOT NINE
SPEAKING FOR. TO MAKE AN
INFORMED CHOICE. BECAUSE COULD
MANAGER EQUALLY FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE PROJECT ON WHICH
THEY CO SIGN. GETTING TO COOK
BETTER NOTICE OF THE FACT THAT
THE BASIC NECESSITY.
TRANSACTION WHERE CONSIDERED
NECESSARY BUSINESSES ARE BEST
POSITIONED TO COMBAT FRAUD.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY HELPFUL AS A
TOOL TO PROTECT SMALL
BUSINESSES. WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO CREATE THEIR OWN
YOU KNOW IF. IT'S THE STATE
LOCAL SUPPLY THE NOTICE AND
TRANSLATION. SB SIX THREE THREE
THE BIPARTISAN IT SHOULD BE TO
CONTACT. THE SHARING MUTUAL
FRIENDS. BECAUSE IT'S VERY
LITTLE BURDEN FOR BUSINESSES.
ENSURE THE BED ALL PARTY LINE
CONTRACT ACTUALLY CENTER
TURNED. IN A FOURTH NINETEEN
YOU PERCENT OF A GREAT BENEFIT
BUT SIMPLY UNDERSTANDING. THAT
THEY WILL HAVE LEGAL AND
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS. BECAUSE
IT HAS NO IMPACT ON THE PRIMARY
BORROWER. AND THE BUSINESS CAN
STILL SEEK RECOURSE AGAINST
THAT PARTY. THIS BILL IS
NARROWLY TAILORED TO ADDRESS
ONLY BE ANGRY AT THAT PRICE. HI
THERE. I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR SENATOR LAMONT. AND THE
COST CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION FOR THE CONTINUE
DIALOGUE. I'D BE WHAT WORK
CLOSER TO NEUTRAL GROUND AND IN
CALIFORNIA. EQUAL FINANCIAL
RIGHTS. FOR MINORITIES. WE ARE
DRIED UP. THANK YOU MISS WHEN
NORTH ALL RIGHT WELL LET'S TURN
THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN THE
WILL TO TEST I SEE ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISHING TO. OF MISTER
MODERATE LET'S TURN THE FOLLOW
RUNNING ON A LOT WE SHOULD
TESTIFY SOME. OF THE BEST SIX
THREE. AND IF YOU'RE SUPPORT OF
S. SIX THREE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
B. CURRENTLY OF ABOUT FIVE IN
THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT. WE WILL
START WITH NUMBER NINE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MATT GREENBERG ON BEHALF OF
BAD STATIC LEGAL SERVICES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX THIRTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER FIVE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT BECAUSE THE
LAST THING WE NEED IS THAT THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE TO PAY FOR
PEOPLE THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT THE NEXT TO BE NUMBER
NINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS MICHAEL BARNES
CALLING ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
COUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SIX THREE THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HI GO AHEAD. VETERANS
SILICON VALLEY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB. SIX THIRTY THIRTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN- IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. THAT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE- PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. NOW LET'S TURNED
OPPOSITION I SEE A NO LISTING
OF PRINCIPLE. OPPOSITION I SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE
KNOWN IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- IF
THERE IS ANYONE OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
TWO MINUTES OF YOUR THE
PRINCIPAL OPPONENT- THIS MATTER
IS A WONDERFUL NINE. AND IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
THIRTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. YOU KNOW THERE'S
OTHERS CURRENTLY IT LOOKS LIKE
TO IN THE QUEUE PARTY THANK YOU
WOULD YOU OPEN THE FOLLOWING
PLEASE. WE WILL START WITH
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE DIFFICULTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION FIRST I HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE IT'S NOT OUR STYLE
TO. SEND TO YOU LATE
OPPOSITION- WE HAD UNDERSTOOD
OUR CONCERNS WOULD BE ADDRESSED
UNFORTUNATELY THEY WERE NOT- AS
YOU KNOW THE CURRENT CONTRACT
MUST BE PROVIDED IN ANOTHER
LANGUAGE IF THE PERSON INVOLVED
IN THE TRADE OR BUSINESS
NEGOTIATION THAT LANGUAGE.
SENATE BILL SIX THREE THREE
CHANGES THAT STANARD IN
REQUIRED AT THE SPECIFIC
DISCLOSURE IF THE PERSON
INVOLVED KNOWS OR HAS REASON TO
KNOW THAT THE PERSON WHO WILL
NOT RECEIVE THE GOODS IS NOT
PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH- ASK FOR
LEASE CONTRACT THAT IS OF
COURSE THE GUARANTOR THE
PENALTY FOR FAILING TO PROVIDE.
A DISCLOSURE IN THE RENTAL
CONTACT AS RETENTION OF THE
LEAST FOR RENTAL HOUSING THE
LANDLORD MAY NEVER SPEAK OR
MEET THE GUARANTOR AND YET
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
ELEVATED STANDARD OF CARE-
THEREFORE THERE'S NO OR SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN STANDARD WOULD BE
USED AGAINST THE LANDLORD THE
LANDLORD FAILED TO PROVIDE THAT
DISCLOSURE BASED MERELY ON THE
ASSUMPTION ABOUT THE
PROSPECTIVE TENANT. YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS THE
NATURE RENTAL HOUSING IS VERY
LITIGIOUS OF CURRENT PANDEMIC
WE'VE SEEN UNETHICAL PENDANT
ATTORNEYS WHO'VE UTILIZED
LEGALLY AMBIGUOUS CLAIMS
AGAINST PROPERTY OWNERS TO
STALL OBJECTIONS ORDER FOR THE
LANDLORD TO PAY THE TENANT TO
LEAVE. AND WHILE WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO OBJECTION TO
PROVIDING THE DISCLOSURE WE
HAVE RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED
THAT THIS DISCLOSURE BE
INCLUDED ONLY WHEN THE PERSON
WHO ENGAGES IN A TRADE OR
BUSINESS SPECIFICALLY THE
RENTAL HOUSING PROVIDERS
NEGOTIATE PRIMARILY IN ONE OF
THESE LANGUAGES. HAVE BEEN THE
CLEAR STANDARD FOR MANY YEARS
AND WE ASK THAT IT REMAINS THAT
WAY- IN THIS SITUATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING OUR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU MISS
CARLSON- OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ONE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITE.
PLEASE PRESS. ZERO WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE- WILL GO
TO NUMBER FIVE SIXTY SIX THANK
YOU HAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN GO AHEAD. OKAY I
THINK I JUST VOTED FOR THE
COURT BUT I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
PLEASE ADDRESS THE LANDLORD BY
THE CONCERNS IT'S ONLY FAIR
THAT THEIR CONCERN NICORETTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE I MISSED
MODERATOR. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER- IN OUR QUEUE-
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT- LET'S BRING BACK THE
CHAMBER I SEE NO MICROPHONES
REYES- CEREMONY DO CARE CLOSE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT THE CLOSE SIGNER- THE
AND- IN NO WAY THIEF THE
PRIMARY SIGNER IS NEGOTIATING
IN A DIFFERENT LANGUAGE OR IN
AN LANGUAGE- EIGHT DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT THIS IS ABOUT A CO
SIGNER. IF THE LANDLORD DOES
NOT HAVE. ANY EVIDENCE THAT THE
COSIGNER DOES IS SPEAKS A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH THE
THEY ARE NOT OBLIGATED TO OFFER
ANY TYPE OF DISCLOSURE AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT SHOULD JUST BE
MADE CLEAR WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION- TO
FURTHER CLARIFY. WILL YOU KNOW
OF THIS PARTICULAR ASPECT BUT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT CO SIGNERS
AND NOT THE PRIMARY SIGNERS.
THANK YOU SAN RAMON DOES THEIR
MOTION SIR EARLIER MOVES THE
BILL. OF MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF
YOUR CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
THAT SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY
THREE BY SENATOR LEE MON AND
MOTION IS BY SENATOR LAYERED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION OF SORRY. THE
FACT SORRY- AMBERG BYE NUMBER I
HAVE FOR JUST. NOT VOTING COVEY
IT'LL. DID ASAL HI DID I SO I
GONZALEZ HI FRIENDS BECAUSE I
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. WHERE'D WHERE'D I A
STERN BY CAL SKI WAY CASKEY AYE
WIENER. THE OF SIX SO FAR WE'LL
PUT THAT IN THE LONG CALL WE
HAVE ONLY LET'S SEE WE HAVE
THREE REMAINING MEASURES NEXT
UP IS SB SIX FIVE FOUR BY
SENATOR MAN. LOVE CENTER MENACE
IS PRESENT. AFTER THAT WE HAVE
S. B. TWO SEVENTY BY SENATOR
ALSO AND THEN SB THREE TWENTY
ONE BY SENATOR ALSO AND I THINK
THAT COMPLETES OUR CALENDAR FOR
THE DAY. I SEE SENATOR MAN
WHO'S ENTERED THE CHAMBER.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY CENTER
MEN WERE READY FOR YOU THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH SHARON
BURKE AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON SB SIX
FIFTY FOUR- THIS IS A BILL.
THAT CREATES NEW PROTECTIONS
AND EXTENDS EXISTING SAFEGUARDS
FOR CHILDREN N FAMILY COURT-
PARTICULARLY THOSE ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE TESTIFYING IN
RELATION TO CUT CITY AND- AND
VISITATIONS SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL DOES TWO THINGS FIRST IT
GENERALLY REQUIRES. THAT FOR
CHILDREN ADDRESSING THE COURT
SAID ABOUT CUSTODY OR
VISITATION- THAT THE COURT. UP
DO NOT OPEN FOR SENATE TESTIFY
BEFORE THEIR PARENTS THE
PARTIES UNLESS IT MAKES A
DETERMINATION THAT THAT WOULD
BE IN THE CHILD'S BEST INTEREST
THAT CURRENTLY THE COURTS HAVE
DISCRETION IT. TOO I'LL HELP
ALLOW IN CAMERA TESTIMONY- BUT
MANY OF THEM DECIDE NOT TO DO
AND SO THEY HAVE TO FIND MAKE A
FINDING IT THAT'S APPROPRIATE-
AND I CAN BE VERY STRESSFUL AND
TRAUMATIC FOR CHILDREN. HAVING
TO TESTIFY IN FRONT OF THEIR
PARENTS AS TO WHICH PARENT THEY
WANT TO HAVE CUSTODY OBVIOUSLY
THAT CAN BE A DIFFICULT THING
IT CAN BE TRAUMATIZING- AND A
NUMBER OF FOLKS BELIEVE THEY
CAN CREATE LONG TERM EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS AND HARM. OFTENTIMES
FOR EXAMPLE CHILDREN WILL AGREE
TO TESTIFY IN FRONT OF A JUDGE
NOT KNOWING THAT THIS CAN
ENTAIL STATING THEIR CUSTODY
PREFERENCES IN FRONT OF THEIR
PARENTS. HI THIS CAN SPLIT FOR
FAMILIES AND I WAS JUST TALKING
TO- SOMEBODY IN THIS BODY.
ABOUT THIS AND THEY ARE
EXPRESSING TO ME THAT THIS IS
VERY TRAUMATIZING IT DOES
SPLINTER FAMILIES- AND SO I
THINK JEWELERS TESTIMONY CAN BE
VERY IMPORTANT IN THESE TYPES
OF SITUATIONS BUT- THEY SHOULD
BE- OUR EMPHASIS SHOULD BE ON
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE IN
SAFE ENVIRONMENTS- AND SO WHAT
THE FIRST COMPONENT THIS BILL
DOES. IS A SAID IS TO HAVE
JUDGES- IT GENERALLY REQUIRES
THE JUDGES- CREATING
ALTERNATIVE TO TESTIFYING IN
FRONT OF THEIR PARENTS- WHETHER
THAT'S IN CAMERA TESTIMONY OR
OR SOME OTHER OPTION. AND
GENERALLY ONLY ALLOWS JUDGES TO
FORCE CHILDREN TO TESTIFYING
FROM THEIR PARENTS IN THESE
MATTERS WHEN THEY DEEM THIS TO
BE IMPORTANT NECESSARY. AND
BENEFICIAL FOR THE CHILD'S
EMOTIONAL HEALTH. THE SECOND
THING THAT AS SIXTY FOUR IS THE
IT TAKES EXIST SAFETY MEASURES.
THAT ARE USED FOR CHILD CUSTODY
DETERMINATIONS AND EXTENDS AND
UNSUPERVISED VISITATIONS-
CURRENTLY JUDGES MUST CONSIDER
A HISTORY OF ABUSE. OR DRUG
ADDICTION WHEN PLACING CHILDREN
IN THE CUSTODY OF INDIVIDUALS-
AND SO IF A JUDGE DOES DECIDE
TO PLACE A CHILD IN THE CUSTODY
OF INDIVIDUALS. WITH ANY OF
THESE- TRIGGERS IN THEIR
BACKGROUNDS THE JUDGE MUST
CREATE A WRITTEN FINDING ON WHY
THAT IS THE CASE- AND THAT
ENSURES THAT RECORDS OF THESE
TERMINATIONS ARE CAPPED. THIS
CAN HELP SAVE LIVES IT HELPS-
AS FAR AS DETERMINING CUSTODY-
BUT UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW THE
SAME REQUIREMENT DOES NOT APPLY
TO UNSUPERVISED VISITATIONS.
EIGHT TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN STUDY
BY THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
JUSTICE FOUND THAT 47% OF
CONCEIVABLY LEADERS. CONTINUE
TO RECOMMEND UNSUPERVISED
VISITATIONS WITH PARENT. EVEN
WHEN THE REPORTS OF VIOLENCE IN
THAT HOME. HE'S ON SUPERVISORS.
CAN LAST DAYS AND TOO OFTEN PUT
CHILDREN IN DANGER. A TWELVE
YEAR NATIONAL STUDY SHOWS THAT
MANY CHILD HOMICIDE VICTIMS.
ARE MURDERED TRAGICALLY BY
DIVORCING OR SEPARATING PARENT
DURING COURT ORDERED. AND
SUPERVISED VISITATIONS WITH
THAT PARENT DESPITE THE FACTS
THE COURTS WERE OFTEN NOTIFIED
OF A HISTORY OF ABUSE. AND
EVIDENCE OF THREATS TO HARM
THOSE CHILDREN. SB SIX FIFTY
FOUR SIMPLY EXTENDS THE SAME OR
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS CURRENTLY
APPLY TO CHILD CUSTODY TO
UNSUPERVISED VISITATION- THIS
MINOR- BUT CRUCIAL CHANGE WILL
SAVE THE LIVES OF CHILDREN- SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTE
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY- KIM ROBINSON A FAMILY
LAW ATTORNEY. AND TRACY FELL
OVER THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
YELLOW COUNTY CASF. THANK YOU
CENTER MEN MISS ROBINSON ARE
YOU ON THE PHONE. MYSTERONS
ENDED MISS ROBINSON IS NOT
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE AS MISS
FATHER AVAILABLE. YES I'M HERE
UP IN THAT IS MISS FABRE MISS
ROBINSON. I'M SORRY- THIS IS
TRACY FATHER ALL RIGHT THIS
FATHER IF YOU GO AHEAD TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE. GOOD
EVENING CHAIRMAN AMERICANS
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TRACY
CALLER. AND I'M A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF YOLO
COUNTY CASA AN ORGANIZATION
THAT ADVOCATES FOR THE BEST
INTERESTS OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
OF CHILDREN. HEY WE UNDERSTAND
THE HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT OF
BRAINS AND BODIES OF CHILDREN
BETTER THAN EVER BEFORE WE KNOW
THAT TRAUMATIC STRESS IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD. AS A RESULT OF
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
OR ACES. HAS A PROFOUNDLY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF CHILDREN AND
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFE COURSE.
THE GROUND BREAKING ACES STUDY
PUBLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT BY DOCTORS AND PALLADIA
HI THERE PERMANENTLY AND ROBERT
HONDA OF THE PVC AND SUBSEQUENT
RESEARCH AROUND TRAUMATIC
STRESS IN CHILDREN. HAVE
DRAMATICALLY HIGHLIGHTED THE
IMPORTANCE OF REDUCING THE
EXPOSURE AND DOSE OF TRAUMATIC
STRESS CHILDREN EXPERIENCE. F.
B. FIFTY FOUR WILL ENSURE THE
COURT TAKE THIS KNOWLEDGE OF
THE NEGATIVE IMPACT OF
TRAUMATIC STRESS THE CHILDREN
INTO ACCOUNT WHEN TAKING THEIR
TESTIMONY IN FAMILY COURT. OR
WHEN MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT
UNSUPERVISED VISITATION IN
CASES WHERE EVIDENCE OF THE
EXTENT. ENSURING THAT CHILDREN
ARE NOT JUST PHYSICALLY BUT
ALSO EMOTIONALLY SAFE DURING
COURT PROCEEDINGS AND THE
SEPARATION OF THEIR PARENTS. IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THEIR
IMMEDIATE AND LONG TERM WELL
BEING. KAFER ADVOCATES WHOSE
COMPANY CHILDREN TO COURT HAVE
A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON THE
TOXIC STRESS THAT CHILDREN
EXPERIENCE WHEN APPEARING IN
COURT. EVEN WHEN SPEAKING UP
FOR THEIR NEEDS. IF IT MAY BE
PERCEIVED AS AGAINST THE WISHES
OR DESIRES OF THE- YES CHILDREN
ARE FREQUENTLY VERY WILLING TO
BE OPEN AND HONEST. ABOUT HOW
THEY FEEL OR WHAT THEY WANT
WHERE THEY FEEL SAFE. IT IS
TIME FOR THE ADULTS IN THE ROOM
TO CREATE THE RIGHT CONDITIONS
FOR THE CHILD RATHER THAN
EXPECT THE CHILD TO ADAPT TO
THE CONDITIONS. SET BY THE
ADULTS IN THE ROOM IT IS TIME
pTHOSE WHO WOULD ABUSE THEM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION THANK YOU MISS FABRE
DISMISS ROBINSON ON THE PHONE.
YES I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW-
WE CAN GO AHEAD MISS ROBINSON.
RIGHT THANK YOU I CHAIR ON
BURKE AND SENATORS I AM A
FAMILY LAW ATTORNEY WITH OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE. AND I HAVE MORE
THAN SYDNEY LEAVE MORE THAN MY
FAIR SHARE OF HIGH CONFLICT
FAMILY LAW CASES THAT INVOLVE.
ISSUES OF CHILD CUSTODY WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
ABUSE ALLEGATIONS- THIS BILL
WOULD DO TWO IMPORTANT THINGS
THE FIRST IS IT WOULD AMEND THE
FAMILY CODE SECTION THREE ZERO
ONE ONE. TO REQUIRE THAT COURTS
WHO ARE ALLOWING UNSUPERVISED
CONTACT BETWEEN A CHILD AND A
PARENT WITH A HISTORY OF ABUSE.
THE COURT HAS TO FIRST ISSUE
WRITTEN FINDINGS AS TO HOW SUCH
AN ORDER IS IN THE CHILD'S BEST
INTEREST HE AND- HELLO IT IS
NOT DETRIMENTAL TO THE CHILD'S
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE. THAT
CURRENT STATUTES OF FAMILY CODE
SECTION THREE ZERO ONE ONE
ALREADY REQUIRES COURTS TO MAKE
THESE KINDS OF WRITTEN FINDINGS
WHEN IT ISSUES ITS ORDERS FOR
CUSTODY. HEDGE LEGAL AND
PHYSICAL CUSTODY OF CHILDREN
BUT SURPRISINGLY THIS FILE THE
STATUTE IS SILENT ON THE ISSUE
OF UNSUPERVISED VISITS IN THE
CONTEXT OF- DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OR ABUSE SITUATIONS- SECONDLY.
THE BILL DOES- CREATE A FURTHER
PROTECTION FOR THOSE FEW
CHILDREN WH DO. PROVIDE
TESTIMONY TO THE COURT FOR ARE
INTERVIEWED BY THE COURT- IN
THE PREFERENCE WOULD BE FOR
CHILDREN TO BE INTERVIEWED IN
CHAMBERS WITH THE COURT
REPORTER PRESENT. OUTSIDE THE
PRESENCE OF THEIR PARENTS-
UNLESS THE COURT MAKES WRITTEN
pTHE CHILD'S BEST INTEREST TO
HAVE. THE CHILD'S PARENTS
PRESENT DURING THE TESTIMONY-
OVER IN MY MANY YEARS OF FAMILY
LAW CASES. CHILDREN DO NOT TELL
IT IS A SMALL MINORITY OF CASES
WHERE CHILDREN ARE BROUGHT IN
AND IN SOME INSTANCES IT IS
BANNED BY SEWER SPONTANEOUS
QUESTS FROM THE- FROM THE JUDGE
HIM OR HERSELF ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
ALL RIGHTS ARE BOB LET'S LET'S
TURN TO THE GALLERY C. KNOWN IN
THE GALLERY- HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE- HERE TO TESTIFY
LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE LINES
OF THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SIX FIVE FOUR.
PLEASE QUEUE UP NOW. MODERATED
WE CAN LAND ON ONE. ONCE AGAIN-
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
EIGHT ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
AND AT THIS TIME- LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ABOUT SEVEN IN OUR QUEUE
ALL RIGHT IF YOU'D GIVE US YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I IT'S CATHERINE
CAMPBELL WITH CALIFORNIA
PROTECTIVE PARENTS ASSOCIATION
AND I SUPPORT THAT. AND
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW GO TO NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
RETOOL MUNDELEIN SUPPORT AND IN
SUPPORT AND DISPEL. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO BE NUMBERS SIX
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TULISAN WITH LEGISLATIVE
COALITION TO PREVENT CHILD
ABUSE BILL SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOGLE THE NUMBER
SEVEN FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHELLE GARCIA MOTHERS OF LOST
CHILDREN IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIVE FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXUS NUMBER THREE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ACCORDING
BILLABLE IT IF THE SERVICE
REPORTS THE NUMBER AND WE WILL
BE HEARD. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
NEXT IN THE QUEUE IS NUMBER
NINE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK THAT TO ME- DR
GARLAND POWERS AND THEN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELL NOW GO TO
NUMBER EIGHT TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KILEY BALLANTYNE FROM
ADVOCATES FOR CHILD EMPOWERMENT
AND SAFETY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NEXUS
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS KATHLEEN
RUSSELL WITH THE CENTER FOR
JUDICIAL EXCELLENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU. WHEN I GO TO NUMBER
NINE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I JUST WANT TO SAY YOU
CAN'T SEVEN TWENTY FOUR BUT I
ALSO SUPPORT SIX FIVE FOUR.
THANK YOU. NEXUS NUMBER THREE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN THE
OPPOSITION. I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IF THERE'S SOMEONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
IF THERE'S A PRINCIPLE IF THERE
IS A PRINCIPAL IN OPPOSITION-
WILL PROVIDE THEM TWO MINUTES.
TO MODERATOR THREE ONE LINE.
AND WILLIAM IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN OPPOSITION THIS
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND AT THIS
TIME IT DOES LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN IN THE QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT. OUR SERVER NUMBER THREE
NINETY- THREE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THREE NINETY WE
CAN HEAR YOU. I WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER FOUR NINETY FIVE FOR
NINETY FIVE ZERO HAD. GONZALEZ
WHO OPPOSE THANK YOU NEXT. THE
NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR LIM
STEINBERG AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW GO
TO NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SIX-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
RACHEL I'M OPPOSED WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS HAVING A
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
PRESENT EXPERIENCE IN HIGH
CONFLICT AND RESIST REFUSAL
SITUATION THANK YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THE EMOTIONAL STATE
THE CHILD WITH THEM. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS GINGER
GRIFFIN WITH EXCEL FOUNDATION
AYE OPPOSED IN PART. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU NEXT CALL. NEXUS
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DEBORAH
TRAVELER WITH THE PARENTAL
ALIENATION LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE AND I AM OPPOSED IN
PART WITHOUT AMENDMENTS FOR A
PROVISION TO PREVENT COERCIVE
CONTROL OF THE CHILD THANK YOU
AND THEIR TESTIMONY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXUS NUMBER NINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
SAID NINE HI MY I'M HI MY NAME
IS AMERICA MARLIN I NORMALLY GO
WITH BEING BILLED SB SIX FIVE
FOR THE KIDS AND THEY NEED TO
BE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MENTAL
ANIMATION AND ABUSE IT WORKED
WE CAN GO HEART AHEAD INTO YOUR
THE CHILDREN. FROM THE JUDGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- NEXUS
NUMBER FIVE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. OKAY SO- I LOOKED UP-
SENATOR BEING- INFORMATION AND
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS MORE
PERSONAL THANK IF YOU NEED A
COLLAR THE COLLAR YEAH THE NAME.
AND YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION- NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY WOOD I AM THE PARENT
AND ALSO REGISTERED NURSE I'M
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER NINE NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS CARLIN POWERS
I RECOGNITION AND I'VE ALREADY
SAID I SUPPORT THE BILL I WOULD
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SORRY NOTE THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I'M
JULIE GRAYSON I'M A COUNSELOR
AND DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION AT
HAND TAP YOU HAVE ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL SIX FIFTY FOUR AND
I THINK FOR THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE EXPERIENCING LEN NATION ARE
BROKEN BOND WITH THE FIT LOVING
PARENT- THAT IS. A DUE PROCESS
CONCERN THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED ON THE HIGHEST LEVEL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT NEXUS
NUMBER THREE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THOMAS
SAVVY AND I APOLOGIZE THAT I'M
ACTUALLY FOR THE BILL CAN I
STILL MAKE A STATEMENT I KNOW I
WE'VE GOT YOUR NAME IN YOUR ON.
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXUS
NUMBER EIGHT NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GERALD
BEING DROPPED. I WANT TO MAKE A
POINT THAT ARE YOU NATION IT'S
ALL ABOUT I FEEL. I THANK YOU
ARE YOU TO. UPLOAD ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. PRESIDENT OF
THE CRIMES ARE GOING FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE- PLEASE CONTINUE. ANY
OTHER CALLERS ON THE LINE. AT
THE CENTER NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE ALL RIGHT IS CONTINUOUSLY
BRING IT BACK TO THE CHAMBERS
C. SURFBOARD JUST AS YOUR
MICROPHONE UP. YES I WOULD.
JUST LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIVE FOUR.
I'D HAD OPPORTUNITY TO CHAT
WITH THE AUTHOR AND- NORMALLY-
I WOULD WANT TO PROTECT THE
LEGAL LEGACY OF THE RIGHT TO
CONFRONT- AND LAST WEEK WE DEAL
WITH AN ISSUE. OF BIAS- THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES. AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE RIGHT TO
CONFRONT IS A CORNERSTONE OF
OUR OF OUR LEGAL SYSTEM. IT
DOESN'T ALWAYS REFLECT THE
REALITIES- AND WHEN YOU HAVE A
CHILD INVOLVED. AND BEING ASKED
TO DECLARE IN FRONT OF THEM
WHERE THEY WISH TO LIVE. BUT SO
DESTABILIZING AND SO TRAUMATIC
JUST AS WE DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE
LAST WEEK ON THOSE. INDIVIDUALS
WHO MIGHT BE- SUBJECTED TO A
SEXUAL VIOLENCE THAT THERE ARE
CARVE OUTS THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
FOR THE WELL BEING OF THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT ANOTHER LEGAL
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE ACCUSED TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AND- AND- BE
VINDICATED NECESSARY IN THE
PROCESS. BUT I WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR I THINK THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION- IN
WHEN I WAS IN WHEN I WAS YOUNG
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG BOY THAT I
WAS IN A- NOT TOO DISSIMILAR
SITUATION. AND I THINK WHAT
HE'S DOING IS THE RIGHT STEP
FORWARD I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISED- THEIR
EMOTIONS CENTER LAYERED MOVES
THE BILL- SENTIMENT BAKER
CLOSE. I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL AGAIN- AND I WOULD
EMPHASIZE WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL. WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT IS- TAILORED
AS POSSIBLE TO A VERY PRESSING
PROBLEM- AND I THINK- CENTER
BORDERS FOR HIS- CONVERSATION
WITH ME EARLIER- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALREADY THANK YOU COUNSEL YOU
CALL THE ROLL. THIS BILL SIX
FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR MEN WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR WHERE THE
MOTION IS DEEP PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HAMBURG HI I'M
BURKE AYE BORJAS AYE PORTIS AYE
CABALLERO. DID I SO THE REST SO
I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. JONES I
LAYERED HI THERE'D AYE STERN
WHITE HOUSE SKENEIDAE WAIT
CASKEY AYE WIENER. YEP EIGHT
ZERO SO FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL CENTER THE
RUSSELL SENATE ALSO SEE HER
STANDING IN THE BACK SHE GETS
OF THE AWARD FOR MOST DILIGENT
PARTICIPANT. I SEE SENATORS
ALL'S OBJECTING TO THAT SO.
YEAH THAT'S BECAUSE MY VISION
IS NOT WONDERFUL SO I CAN SEE
THE FRONT ROW MUCH BUT I COULD
SEE THE BACKGROUND ALL RIGHT
BECOMING ANYTIME SOON CENTER
THERE ALSO S. B. TWO SEVENTY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- I AM ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AS DESCRIBED ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS SB TWO
SEVENTY WILL ENSURE PUBLIC
EMPLOYER GONNA SAY SINCE.
RECEIVE ACCURATE AND TIMELY
BARGAINING UNIT INFORMATION
WHICH THEY ARE ALREADY ENTITLED
TO BY LAW. SO THAT THEY MAY
FULFILL THEIR LEGAL
REPRESENTATION DUTIES AND- MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE BARGAINING
UNIT AS A WHOLE. EVEN THOUGH
MANY PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FOLLOW
THE LAW UNFORTUNATELY MANY
EMPLOYERS FAIL. TO MEET THESE
MINIMAL LEGAL OBLIGATIONS. IN
THE EDUCATION SECTOR OUT OF
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TWO HUNDRED
FORTY TWO HAVE NOT SUBMITTED
THE MONTHLY NEW HIRE LIST AS
REQUIRED BY LAW SINCE THE START
OF THE CALENDAR YEAR. NO
CONSEQUENCES SB TWO SEVENTY
ESTABLISHES ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES WITH PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE EMPLOYER TO
CURE THE PROBLEM RESPOND AND
AVOID ANY INVOLVEMENT FROM PER.
THIS MEASURE CREATE NO NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS IT SIMPLY LOOKS FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING LAW.
IT PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY TO
EMPLOYERS SO THAT THEY MAY MEET
THE CURRENT LEGAL OBLIGATIONS.
THIS BILL GIVES PER OF THE FULL
AND COMPLETE A FORTY TO
DETERMINE WHAT SOLUTIONS WILL
WORK TO BOTH ENSURE COMPLIANCE
AND UNDERSTAND THE OBLIGATIONS
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS OF COURSE ARE
FACING RIGHT NOW DURING
EMERGENCIES HAVING ACCURATE AND
TIMELY INFORMATION IS
ESSENTIAL. WHETHER THE STATE
DESPITE FACING WILDFIRES MASS
SHOOTINGS OR PANDEMIC VIRUSES
WE IN THE PUBLIC ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA EXPECT OUR PUBLIC
SERVANTS. TO CONTINUE TO SERVE.
THE CRISIS IS NOT GOING AWAY.
AS FAST AS WE WOULD LIKE IT'S
AN EMPLOYEES COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING REPRESENTATIVE HAS
BOTH THE MORAL AND LIEU LEGAL
DUTY TO WATCH OUT FOR THE
WELFARE OF THESE EMPLOYEES WHO
IN TURN. WATCH OUT FOR THE
PUBLIC'S WELL BEING. IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER FOR
EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVES TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
BARGAINING UNIT FOR THESE
REASONS. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY BEFORE YOU- TO
BRING SB TWO SEVEN BEFORE YOU
ARE YOUR CHEN I VOTE. MY
WITNESSES WILL BE SANDRA BUT
IT'LL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND LIBERTY SANCHES FROM SEIU
CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHTY- SPIRO
IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE. FLOOR'S
YOURS. YES GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS STAND OVER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL- TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO OF THE
FDA'S REPRESENTED ELEAZAR HAVE
NOT SUBMITTED A MONTHLY NEW
HIRE LIST THE START OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR AND ANOTHER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN LEN FLAYED
HAVE YET TO SUBMIT THE FULL
BARGAINING UNIT WITH I WAS DUE
IN JANUARY. WE NEED THE
INFORMATION QUICKLY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR MEMBERS
AND ENSURE THAT THE VISION P.
P. ACCESS VIRUS TESTING
VACCINES WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS
PROTECTIONS AND. INFORM THEM OF
THEIR LAYOFF RIGHT. PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ONLY BE SUBJECT A
PENALTY IF HER BITTERMAN THEY
ARE IN. OF THE LAW AND ANY
PENALTIES COLLECTED GO BACK TO
THE STATE GENERAL FUND. SECURE
PERIOD INCLUDED IN THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW EMPLOYERS WHO
INADVERTENTLY VIOLATE THE LAW
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REMEDY ANY
ERRORS. AND THE ATTORNEY FEES
PROVISION ENCOURAGES PARTIES TO
SETTLE AT THE LOWEST POSSIBLE
LEVEL FIGHT THIS INCENTIVIZING
FOR WITH THE PEELS WHICH WAYS
PUBLIC AGENCIES MONEY. HAVING
THIS AND FOR HELPS KEEP OUR
MEMBERS SAFE SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO KEEP THE PUBLIC
SAFE. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS PERU.
MS SANCHEZ ARE OU AVAILABLE.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ABILITY SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE FBI YOU CALIFORNIA PROUD
BECAUSE LONG SERVICE MASTER IT
IS OUR- HOPE THAT THE RESULT OF
THIS BILL WILL BE THAT'S UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE CHARGES ARISING
OUT OF VIOLATIONS OF GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION THIRTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT NO LONGER HAVE TO BE
FILED AND THAT THE ATTORNEYS
FEES AND COSTS PROVISIONS OF
THE MEASURE. WILL NEVER HAVE TO
BE RELIED UPON THIS BILL IS
UNFORTUNATELY NECESSARY HOWEVER
BECAUSE IN THE SHORT TIME
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION THIRTY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT HAD BEEN ON
THE BOOKS SOME EMPLOYERS HAVE
SIMPLY BEEN UNWILLING TO COMPLY
WITH THE STRAIGHT. AND NOT
UNDULY BURDENSOME OBLIGATIONS
CONTAINED THEREIN FIFTY COME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR BUT THE LACK
OF COMPLIANCE ISSUE ONLY TO
EMPLOYERS ABILITY TO KERR
COMPLIANCE WITH IMPUNITY IN
OTHER WORDS NO ONE'S AFRAID OF
THE REPERCUSSIONS OF VIOLATION
BECAUSE THERE REALLY AREN'T.
EXCEPT THE COURT THE PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
UNIONS WHO ARE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED IN NUMEROUS WAYS THANK
YOU BYE ELECTIONS IF THE INTENT
OF LABOR PROTECTIONS THAT EVEN
AN UNLEVEL PLAYING FIELD THIS
BILL WENT UP WILL ENSURE THAT
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION THIRTY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT AFTER IN THE
EQUALISING MANNER THE
LEGISLATURE INTEND. THE BILL
ESTABLISHED ESTABLISHED AS A
FOXHOLE AND TRULY BALANCED
APPROACH TO REMEDYING THE
PROBLEM SINCE THE BALL
CONTINUED TO BE IN THE
EMPLOYERS WORK AND NOTHING
HAPPENS NO YOU L. P. NO
POTENTIAL. FOR ATTORNEY FEES
AND COSTS. YEAH THEY TO COMPLY
THE LAW WORK HERE. THE BILL
ALSO ENTER IT INTO READ. FIVE
FROM THE- TO CARE AND- A NEW.
IT TURNING OUT SHETHIS IS A
BILL FOR HOPEFULLY OPTIMISTIC
MOWBRAY ARE A HAVE TO BE USED.
BUT WITHOUT IT IMPACTING BELOW.
THOUGHT THEY WERE IMPORTING FOR
PUBLIC WORK. WHAT KIND TO BE
THAT'LL- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MS SANCHEZ. ON OTHERS SUPPORT I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY- TO
TESTIFY C. KNOWN IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATE LET'S TURN TO
THE PHONE LINE IF YOU'RE ONLINE
IN SUPPORT. OF THE S. B. TWO
SEVENTY PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. MISTER MODERATOR. IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
AND IF IN SOME OF SB TO SAY.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S CURRENTLY ABOUT SIX IN
THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER TEN FORTY
SEVEN- TEN FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE THOUSAND FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I WILL
MOVE TO NUMBER TEN FORTY NINE-
TEN FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER TO BROWN BOTH SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND EDUCATORS THE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXUS TEN
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
TEN FORTY THREE LINES OPEN. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO THE NEXT CALLER-
MOVED TO NUMBER TEN FIFTY
SEVEN- TEN FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL GROUP SHARES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF INTERFERENCE AND
THE UNITED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
BOTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SIX
OF THE NUMBER TEN FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO SEVEN
B. THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELL
NOT GONNA NUMBER SIX TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS A PLAN ON HOW TO
INSTALL A DOMESTIC WORKER THANK
YOU FOR THE EXPERIENCE THREE
TWENTY ONE MICHAEL THE PLAN
GIVES CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU. THE NEXT THREE
NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVED
TO NUMBER THREE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT THE
TWENTY FORCE GIVEN WOULD BE
HEARD- ARE YOU ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT OF IT S. B. TWO
SEVENTY. SURE OKAY NEXT CALL.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO SEVENTY PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME-
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WELL NOW IN
THE PROJECT TURNED OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND MR JASON SMELTZER ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC RISK
INNOVATIONS IS IN OPPOSITION
YEP TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- MY NAME
STRAIGHTENED SHELTER AND I'M
HERE TODAY TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF PRISM PUBLIC CREEK ANIMATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL FIRST I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WHY THE
AUTHOR SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS
TO BE FRUSTRATED BY PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO REPEATEDLY MORE
INTENTIONALLY. FAILED TO
PROVIDE THE REQUIRED
INFORMATION UNDER EXISTING LAW-
FRANKLY WE CAN SEE WHY THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT TO APPLY
REASONABLE PENALTIES NOT. GOOD
THAT I'LL OUT- WE WOULD ARGUE
THE SECURITY TO APPLY THAT
SITUATION THERE COULD BE A
REASONABLE- EXPLANATION FOR- UP
A REPORT NOT BEING FILED ONCE
OR TWICE A YEAR WE THINK THAT
SHOULD BE UNDER CONSIDERATION.
HOWEVER WE MUST OPPOSE- THE
PROVISIONS THAT AT THE TWO
SEVENTY THAT WOULD ESTABLISH
CIVIL PENALTIES FOR ERRORS-
FIVE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
ATTEMPTING TO REPORT GOOD FAITH
THE BOTTOM LINE AND WE DON'T
THINK PENALTY SHOULD BE APPLIED
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
ATTEMPTING. TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW. THE MET THE ENDEAVOR- THEN
THE THINK THE OLDER STANDARD TO
FIGHT DUBBER THIS IS FOR SURE
ALL SORTS OF IN THAT AND BODY
THAT THEY- UNDER THE BILL DATA
ERRORS ARE VIOLATION OF THE LAW
AND WE WOULD ONLY DELAY BECAUSE
DATA ERRORS TIMES IN THE YEAR
THAT MIGHT SEEM LIKE A LOT BUT
AT THE COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE HAS
DOUBLED THE BARGAINING UNITS
ACROSS MULTIPLE UNION YOU CAN
BE REPORT MONTHLY THERE COULD
LITERALLY BE. THOUSANDS OF
POTENTIAL DATA FIELDS THAT
COULD BE AN ACCURATE. WHAT THE
WHAT THEY AS WE CAN ALL. HAVE
THAT HAPPEN THREE TIMES ZERO WE
WOULD BE STUCK. TO THE OLD. BUT
WE DON'T THINK THE REASON- AND
WE THINK HELP YOU SHOULD BE.
NOW SITUATE. AGAIN WE ARE WE
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND WHY. DERBY
RESTORATION OF THE RELATE TO
FOCUS SIMPLY DON'T TRY TO
COMPLY WITH A LOT WILL
REPEATEDLY FAILED TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW. OF IT
UNFORTUNATELY AT THE BILL.
DRAFTED HAVE TO BE. OPPOSED IN
RETURNED ABOUT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISSPELLED SIR.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. MISTER
MODERATOR. ARE THERE OTHERS ON
THE PHONE OPPOSITION. HAMLEYS
ENJOY. UP PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT IN THE QUEUE ALL
RIGHT. IT ALONE NUMBER FIVE
SIXTY SIX- FIVE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. SO
INDIVIDUAL TEACHERS THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO NOT BELONG TO THE
UNION SO I OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL FORSTER
INQUIRED TO THE TEACHERS TO THE
UNION THANK YOU THANK YOU WE'LL
COUNT THAT AS THE SECOND
PRINCIPLE IN OPPOSITION. OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER FOUR THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HERE MEMBERS DILLON
GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
LIKE THE LINE MY COMMENTS THAT
JASON SMELTZER IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LEX'S NUMBER NINE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S A FAIR TO
CAD ON BEHALF OF THEIR RULE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES ON
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. MEXICO THE
NUMBER TEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. A TEN SIXTY SEVEN
AIRLINES OPEN. NEXT CALL ONLY
MOVED THE NUMBER. WILL MOVE IN
AN AMBER TEN SIXTY NINE TEN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HI GO AHEAD. HELLO GO
AHEAD SIR. ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE
THE NEXT CALLER. HELLO HELLO HI
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU GO HEAD SIR
YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION YOUR
POSITION. OKAY YOU CAN HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. YEAH OKAY
SO I'M CALLING ON THE MONEY
ERIC AND I'M CALLING FOR THE
FREE BRITNEY MOVEMENT ON SB
SEVEN TWO FOUR HAVE YOU GOT
CALLED ARE YOU ARE BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR THAT THIS IS
S. B. TWO SEVENTY. SO OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO THAT WAS YOU CALL IN
THAT PEOPLE THAN TO FOR- THAT
THAT BILLS ALREADY BEEN HEARD
SIR SO. IT WAS ON CONSENT BUT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SO I
REMOVED THE NUMBER SEVENTY
THREE. THE NUMBER THREE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT NEXT
CALDERON MOVES INTO. WHO MOVED
A NUMBER- TEN SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD TEN SEVENTY TWO.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
U. A. W. WESTERN STATES IN
SUPPORT. PARDON I HAD TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES RT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SENATOR IN
OPPOSITION- PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT
BACK TO CHAMBER I SEE NO
MICROPHONES REYES- CENTER
LAYERED MOVES THE BILL. SENATE
THE RUSSELL DO YOU CARE TO
CLOSE ESCROW BY AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MY
ACCENT YOU COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL HI THIS IS S. B.
TWO SEVENTY BY SENATOR DID I
SETTLED WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR LAYERED THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
UMBERG. AYE AMBER AYE BURGESS.
ZERO DID I DRESSED SO I CAN SEE
HI GONZALEZ I HER. HERTZBERG I.
LAYERED HI LAYERED ICE. QUAKE
OWSKI HI MY CASKEY AYE WIENER.
YES SIX ZERO SO FAR MEIGLE PUT
THAT ON CALL SO THIS IS THE
LAST BILL I KNOW THAT. THOSE
WHO ARE LISTENING WHO AREN'T
PRESIDENT CHAMBER WOULD LIKE US
TO HANG FOR A LITTLE LONGER BUT
THIS IS THE LAST BILL AND THERE
IS AT LEAST AS OF. THE PRINTING
OF THE ANALYSIS THERE WAS NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THOSE WHO WISH TO
HAVE THEIR VOTE RECORDED REPORT
TO THE CHAMBER. RIGHT SENATOR
ALSO GO AHEAD WITH S. B. THREE
TWENTY ONE WITH NO NO-
OPPOSITION ON FILE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CONSULTANT AND
ACCEPTING THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS REFLECTED ON PAGE
FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOMESTIC WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND TWO MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS DEPEND ON THEM AND
THEIR LABOR TO CARE FOR THEIR
HOMES AND THEIR FAMILIES. THERE
PRIMARILY IMMIGRANT. IMMIGRANT
WOMEN WORKFORCE THEY'RE
ESSENTIAL TO THE ECONOMY. AND
THEY DESERVE CONSIDERATION. FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETYISSUES JUST
LIKE ANY OTHER WORKING MAN OR
WOMAN. WE SHOULD NOT CONTINUE
TO EXCLUDE. THIS GROUP OF
WORKERS FROM BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTECTIONS. NOT DURING
THE PANDEMIC NOT DURING THE
WILDFIRES NOT IN EVERY DAY
WORK. WITH THEY PUT THEIR
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. PROTECT
OUR FAMILIES. DURING THE
WILDFIRES WHOLE HOUSEHOLD
DOMESTIC EMPLOYEES- BUT WERE
ASKED TO STAY BEHIND BYE BUYERS
GUARD HOLDS WORK IN SMOKY
CONDITIONS CLEAN UP TOXIC ASH-
SOMETIMES A HOUSEHOLD EMPLOYERS
FAILED TO TELL THEM. THAT THEIR
HOMES WERE THAT THEY WERE
WORKING UNDER WONDER-
EVACUATION ORDERS. THE PANDEMIC
HAS ONLY FURTHER MAGNIFIED THE
VULNERABILITIES AND DANGERS
THAT DOMESTIC WORKERS FACE. I
WAS OUR WORLD BUYERS GROW IN
FREQUENCY AND INTENSITY IN THE
PANDEMIC ROG GHOSTED OR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IT'S TIME FOR US TO TAKE THIS
STEP. B. THIS IS- CONTINUES TO
BE A LEGACY OF SLAVERY BECAUSE
THIS IS HOW AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN WERE TREATED- TO TAKE
CARE OF THE HOMES AND THE
FAMILIES- AND THIS IS JUST
CONTINUES THAT- TERRIBLE LEGACY
SO. I URGE AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF TODAY WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES DAISY LOPEZ MEMBER OF
THE GREEN DAY LABOR CENTER AND
NIKKI BROWN BOOKER MEMBER OF
HAND IN HAND THE DOMESTIC
EMPLOYERS NETWORK THANK YOU.
SHE DID I THINK JUST A MIXTURE.
OF THAT ALSO I THINK YOU SAID
YOU ACCEPTED THE MEMBERS DID I
HEAR CORRECTLY YES HE DID MISS
ARCHER THANK YOU- LET'S LET'S
START WITH MISS LOPEZ MS LOPEZ
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. I DIDN'T GET
ACTED EVENING ACTUALLY WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH NIKKI BROWN
BOOKER THE MONEY FIRST AND THEN
GO TO LOCAL. ALL RIGHT OUR ON
MY END MY NAME IS MEGAN ARE
FACTS. THE BOMBA HAD TO STEP
AWAY FROM THE HER. ABILITY ALL
MY LIFE AND I RELY ON PERSONAL
ATTENDANCE FOR CARE. I STARTED
EMPLOYING INDEPENDENCE WHEN I
LEFT MY PARENTS HOUSE I. NEED
TO GO TO COLLEGE. I NOW EMPLOY.
CONTENT ON A REGULAR BASIS. AND
THEY HELP ME DO THINGS LIKE GET
IN AND OUT OF BAD PREPARE MEALS
AND DRIVE ME TO WORK. USING
ATTENDANT CARE SERVICES HAS
MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR ME TO
BECOME A PROGRAM OFFICER. FOR
THE DISABILITY INCLUSION FIND.
ALEX THE LANDER PIECE WHICH
FUNDS DISABILITY JUSTICE
MOVEMENT BUILDING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY I THROUGH THE THIRD OF
THE NATIONAL. COMMITTEE ON HAND
AND HEART. THE NEED FOR CARE IS.
AND THE URGENCY TO RESTORE THAT
WORK CAN ACCESS QUALITY GIVING.
THAT PROVIDE HOW PROTECTION
WITH CLEAR GUIDANCE. NOBLEST
ABOLITION OF BY REGION COMPOSED
OF BOTH DOMESTIC AND WORK. TO
CREATE SPECIFIC. AND. BASED ON
THE FIRST HAND IT. I NEED
GUIDANCE TO ENSURE MY OWN THING
THE OTHER PERSON WHO NEEDS MY
TO PICK ME UP FOR EXAMPLE
ENSURING THAT DATA HAD AFTER TO
IMPROVE AND TRY ABOUT THE- WAY
TO DO SO IT'S INTEGRAL TO MY
PAGE. OUR HELP AND SAFETY IS
ENSURED. THEY FOLLOWED HER
THEMSELVES DO A LACK OF. MY OWN
FAITH IS ALL AT. EIGHT HOW
THANK YOU FOR ALL WORK AT WITH
AND THE JUDGE COOLEY THAT IS.
IN THE LEGACY PETITIONS. OF
BLACK WOMEN. SECOND TO IMPACT
OTHER WHEN OF COLOR AND
IMMIGRANT WITH TODAY. OTHER
BLACK WOMAN I BELIEVE THE TIME
COME TO RECTIFY TO STORE WRONG
WHICH HAS IMPACTED MANY LAW.
AND THIS BILL IS ONE IN PART
STEP GIVE THAT. IF THE COURT
THREE TWO ONE IT URGENT NEEDED
AND THE- IT WOULD PROVIDE OUR
LONG OVER. I NOW TO MAKE THE
DAY LOCAL. SHARE EXPERIENCE
FROM THE FRONT LINE AND SHE BE
UNSURE BY. ALL OF THE TRIAL.
COULD NOT WORKER COALITION.
THANK YOU. MISS LOPEZ. A LOT OF.
THE WEATHER IN FRONT OF A GREEN
ROOM IS EIGHTY PAYER IS YOU'RE
NOT EVEN THE MOTHER INCLUDING
LOT OF THE DAY. BUT SEVENTY
SUPPORTIVE THAT THE SENATE
INTERLOCAL. ME INTO THIS THAT
THE HE THAT GIVETH AND THE
OTHER SIXTY COULD NOT GONNA.
NEED A SERVING. ME SAID LAST
NAME INTO THE RECORD BOOKS
ALREADY. WRITTEN IN THE TO
CONSERVATIVE COOLEY. MEXICAN
PEOPLE BUT FOR ME THIS IS A
LIST THAT AMERICAN DISPOSAL.
BUT IT. LOOKS REALLY GOOD. IN.
NORTH SEATTLE CAN EXPLORE GOING
TO GIVE A- YEAH PROBABLY
NINETEEN FOUND THEM UP IN THAT
MY HEALTH AND- ARE WORK I HAVE
SHALL COME. OF MIAMI YOU'RE ME
TO A MASK. BUT NEITHER FOR THEM
ARE THEY TO MASKS THEMSELVES I
WORK OR HOME. THE SAME THING
HAPPENED WITH PROBABLY. THEY
REQUIRE ME TO TAKE CARE AND MY
RESULT BUT ARE NOT TO THEIR
WITH ME AND I DON'T KNOW I AM
EX. TO AN I ARRIVED. AND THE
VEHICLE WE- NEED TO GATHER SOME
NAME. PUNITIVE FOR THE SENATE
HE SAID. THAT THE ON THE LIST
AND JUST SEVEN. IN ITS
POLITICAL. INTERNAL WE EXPORT
LEBANESE UPTAKE ANALYTICS FOR
THEIR CONTINUE IN A MOMENT
THOUGH INSTANCES OF SIX WILL
SETTLE AND- FOCUSED BUT- THEY
COME WITH A MONITOR HISTORY
BEHIND THAT MONEY TWENTY NINE
ONE OF THE LAST SATURDAY DOES
NOT THE DENTURE. EVEN BEFORE
KOBE BRYANT FOR WITH HELP THEM
SAFETY OF DURING THE WEALTHY IN
CAL. WHAT CLEAN THAT WAS TO THE
ACTUAL OVER THAT BY. THE STOCK
PICKS AND COOKING I. HEADACHE
VOMITING. HEADACHE I'M BOB
BECAUSE THE TIME I YOU CLEAN
AND EVEN AFTER LEAVING IT TAKES
TWO TO THREE HOURS PER DAY. TO
OKAY- THING THOUGH THAT YOUR
RECORD. ITS ATTEMPT OLD IS FROM
COLONIAL TIMES. SETTLE THIS
THING. FOR VOTERS TO SEE THAT
WELCOME MAKE UP OF THE- BUT AS
SOON AS I DON'T THE MAGIC. SO
THAT THE BUT THEN IT. OTHER
PERSON THE COMES I FEEL LIKE I
HAVE KNOWN. BUT TO WORK WITH
HIM FOR YEARS EVEN THOUGH MY
COMES TO BE A GREAT. OUT OF
NEED I CAN'T HOME NOT WORK. BUT
IF I WERE TO BE THE ONLY CALL
ME RIGHT NOW I WORRY THAT I
WOULD FEEL. WITHOUT ANY.
CONSIDERING I'M INTERNET CAMERA.
THAT MISCONDUCT I MEAN ONCE
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT THE
CABINET THE CRIME- OCEAN. IN
SIX PERMITTED MITCHELL CAN'T
THINK A SEPARATE. EVERYTHING
YOU. OKAY IN IT AND IT THAT TO
YOU KNOW FIX POLITICAL SEVENTY
A LOT OF THAT I. THE
APPOINTMENT THAT YOU DON'T WANT
TO SET THE STATE WOULD BE THAT.
THE GENTLEMAN FROM SACKING THEN
SHARED THE GIFT THAT I WOULD
LIKELY THE CRAP OUT OF THOSE
THAT IS I WANT. THEY WILL
CREDIT AND THEN FOR ONE THING
THAT THE GOVERNMENT THAT THEY
HAVE THE CALL OF IT. HELLO WE
ALSO HAVE A NICE CHAT. DIRECTOR
OF THE WOMEN EMPLOYMENT RIGHT.
ON THE LINE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE ABOUT THE BILL. YEAH THANK
YOU GRASSES. SENIOR LOCUSTS ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE OF THOSE IN
SUPPORT ROM ONE TWELVE I SEE
NONE. LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES- MISTER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF THE S. B. THREE TWO
ONE THE BILL WITHOUT OPPOSITION.
AND THOSE ARE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THREE TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AND AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE ABOUT FORTY IN
THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WELL WHAT WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL PROVIDE THE OPPOSITION
THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME- WILL
WILL PROVIDE THE- NO MORE THAN
FIFTEEN MINUTES SO GO AHEAD BUT
SIR TO THEM UP. ABSOLUTELY
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER TEN
FIFTEEN TEN FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AND I
REMARRIED AND I AM AND I AM
MEMBER OF THE NEXT UNITED GOOD.
EVENING LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
TO ONE BECAUSE WORKERS THE
THIRD HEALTH AND DIGNITY ARE
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS EACH
PERSON'S SHOULD GIVE US THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION. AND
THEIR POSITION. THE NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER TEN SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TEN SIXTY FIVE THE
JUDGE. WELL MOVED TO NUMBER TEN
FORTY EIGHT- TEN FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE A. AT TEN FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINES OPEN. WHEN ASSEMBLY.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY SEVEN- TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
I LIVE IN THE WIRE I AM OUTSIDE
ABILITY CORPORATE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND A MEMBER OF THE TEAM
ADVOCATE FOR JESSE MAKE THE.
FORTY THREE THREE THREE ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER TEN THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE SEATTLE OF THE- LAST. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER TEN THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO LOOK
BETTER THAN THE NUMBER THIRTY
GOOD JOB OPENING AVAILABLE TO.
ORDER THEN I DON'T. KNOW THAT
YES THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER TEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TEN THIRTY. AGAIN
NUMBER ONE I'M NOT BY THE END
OF ENTERTAINMENT I'M I'M NOT.
WHAT WHAT WHAT DOES THAT THERE
IT MEANS YOU'RE NOT CONNECTED
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE TEN SEVENTY SIX HELLO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS AND
I MY **** I AM TWENTY LACHLAN I
AM FROM THE AMBULANCE I MAY CAN
GIVE IT IN I. THINK SB THREE
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER
TEN TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY MY
NAME IS AT SEVEN THIRTY I'M
CALLING FROM SOME PRACTICAL I
WOULD BE LIKE YOU THE WAY I AM
I REMEMBER COLLECTED MOVEMENT
I'M SUPPOSED TO IS V. THREE
TWENTY ONE EACH TIME. NOW THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. A NEXT IS
GOING TO BE NUMBER SIX FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE HARPER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORS AND STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THEY GIVE. THE NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER TEN SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAY IF NOT LET ME
DOWN BALLOT HE'S GOING TO A
HOLD OF AND ALL THAT SO MEMBERS
OF THE TO THE LITTLE SUNKEN IF
YOU'LL BE THERE FOR YOU BUT I'D
SAY THAT THAT MEANS YOU KNOW.
WHAT I FEEL. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT TO BE NUMBER TEN OH FIVE.
HAD. HI TEN OH FIVE ONE
THOUSAND FIVE YEARS YOUR LINES
OPEN. MY NAME- TWENTY SEVEN
NUMBERS WHICH ARE NOT THANK
SECURITY NUMBER IF YOU CAN I
CAN HAVE WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BEG FOR IT IT'S IS THE GOODNESS
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE. THAT
THANK YOU. KERN NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE TEN NINETY PLEASE
GET A. A TEN NINETY LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE TO NUMBER. TEN
NINETY ONE A TEN NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HI MY
NAME THE SAME OKAY B. NINETY
LINCOLN CHEER LOS ANGELES. I'M
NOT FOR THEIR- THANK YOU SEE
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER TEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MADDIE
SETTLEMENTS I LEAVING
HUNTINGTON PARK I AM A MEMBER
OF THE EXPENSE AND I SUPPORT IT
THE THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WILL MOVE TO NUMBER
TEN TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MYRTLE LEVINE I'M OF
THE NATION FROM SHEILA AND
SOMETHING ON THE WIDELY AND I
SUPPORT IS TO BE THE ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXUS GONNA BE
NUMBER ELEVEN OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ELEVEN OH FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVED IN NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY TO TEN EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DEANNA
I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND I'M
WITH THE LAST- AND IT SUPPORT
SB THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TEN FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
THAT MONEY TO TRAVEL FROM
FARMLAND I MEAN HOW CLEANER
NAME THEIR OLD WILL HEADED FOR
ME TO GET FEEDBACK I'M SUPPORT
IN BT. TWO ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER
TEN FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL TAKE DAILY THREE HOUR
LINES OPEN. CALLER GO AHEAD. I
SEE IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S MORE
THAN ONE PERSON IN SUPPORT
THERE. ALL RIGHT THE BILL THE
NEXT CALLER. WILL MOVE THE
NUMBER ELEVEN ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS- PRIYANKA
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL ALSO IF YOU
CAN GET SOME CLARITY ON SB
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR THAT WOULD BE
GREAT BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO CALL AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
IS GOING TO BE NUMBER TEN
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO
AHEAD. YEAH YOU CAN WORKERS
CENTERS AND GIGGLE AND- I
SUPPORT SB THREE BLOODY PROMOTE
SIGN. THANK YOU CALLER. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE THANK YOU-
NEXUS GOING TO BE NUMBER SO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE NOT
HELLO- THIS IS CLEARLY SHOWN
FROM THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
JEWISH WOMEN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
AREN'T SUPPORTED SB THREE
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU. AND NEXT
TO BE NUMBER TEN FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MERGING WITH IN HER AND I
LIVE IN ROSS NINE THE NUMBER OF
HAND IN HAND YOU CAN PLAYERS
NETWORK IS AND- TO HOUSE
CLEANERS AND I VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SOME A
NEXT REMOTE INTO LINE TEN
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GO
AHEAD CALLER ATTENDED. ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE THE NEXT CALL.
ABSOLUTELY NEXT TO THE NUMBER
TEN NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS VANESSA
BARBARA FROM THE CALIFORNIANS
DOMESTIC WORKERS COALITION AND
I SUPPORT SB THREE TWO ONE.
THANK YOU. M. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
ELEVEN OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ELEVEN OF SIXTY LINES OPEN.
PARDON SCHOOL NEXT CALLER. THE
NEXT CAR WILL BE NUMBER TEN
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CONSISTENTLY. YES. TEN SIXTY
TWO. HI MY NAME IS NOT A THAT
THE DAY THAT I'M MEMBER OF
SHEILA FOR LOS ANGELES AND I'M
SUPPORT MAY SB THREE TWO NINE
TWO TWO ONE. THANK YOU. CONNEX
WILL GO TO NUMBER FIVE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE SIX
TWO SIX NINE LUPIN- HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY SO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL IN CLEAR BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT ACTUALLY-
THANK YOU MAN DOUBLE IF I WERE
GOING THANK YOU LAURIE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT IS
GOING TO BE NUMBER TEN EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T KNOW
THE POLITICALLY THE- IN A NEW
MODEM LINES OPEN. BY NEXT CALL
PLEASE. I WILL MOVE TO NUMBER
TEN OH ONE TEN OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AN EIGHTY
SEVEN YEAH OUR MEMBERS ARE
LOCATED WE NEED A FIFTY ONE I
EVEN WORK IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I'M THE MASSIVE AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORTER IN THE THREE
TO ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WILL BE TEN FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I I'M RABBI
JIM KAUFMAN I LIVE IN BAND I
AND- I EMPLOY A DOMESTIC WORKER
AND ALSO FACILITATE THE HIRING
OF CARE GIVERS FOR MEMBERS OF
MY CONGREGATION- AND I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF HAND IN HAND AND BY-
AND I THINK ALL EMPLOYERS
SHOULD BE SUPPORTING SB THREE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU REVIVED.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT TO THE B. TEN
THIRTY NINE- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SYLVIA HERNANDEZ FROM SANTA
CALIFORNIA- WORKING WITH THAT-
ORGANIZED AND WORKERS WITHIN
THE NORTHWEST MAGNOX WE ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORT INTO THE.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OF THE
NUMBER TEN SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TEN SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE- WILL MOVE TO NUMBER
TEN- OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
FACT THE HARD THE CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKERS COALITION IN
SUPPORT SB TWENTY THREE TO ONE
THANK YOU. AND NEXUS GONNA BE
NUMBER TEN FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT TEN FIFTY FOUR LINES
OPEN. WHAT ARE. THE NUMBER IS
V. D. FRANCISCO. REPRESENTABLE
THEY ARE NOTHING IN COMPARISON
I'M NOT SHOCKED HYLARANA
MYSTICA YEAH FOR YOUR LIFE IN
THERE BUT IT MAY BE ONE OF.
GARCIA THANK YOU. WELL NEXT TO
THE NUMBER TEN EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS NATALIE ABOUT THE THAT I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CLINIC NUMIC
OPPORTUNITY CENTER AND I
SUPPORT SB THREE TWO ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. A NEXUS IN THE
NUMBER TEN THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT TEN THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINES OPEN. HI NEXT CALL. THE
NEXT IN A B. NUMBER TEN FORTY
TEN FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY YEARS HAYLEY CURRIER AND
MY FAMILY ARE AND CLEARS UP
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA AND I SUPPORT SB
THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SORRY MANY MACHINA PAUL
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER A CO
SPONSOR SB THREE TWENTY ONE I'M
CALLING IN STRONG IS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SMALL MINIMAL
LOCUST MOMENTUM THAT IS REALLY
THE LESSEN OPEN UP ALL YOUR
LIFE SURVEYS THAT IS ALSO WE'RE
LOOKING GOING TO UP ON A BUT AT
THE HEART OF THE THAT. THANK
YOU. MONTEREY WE'VE GONE
THROUGH MINUTES NAY SECONDS AND
SO- LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITE IS
THERE ARE OPPONENT ON THE LINE.
I'M LOOKING AROUND THE GALLERY
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
IN OPPOSITION IS NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION. HAMLEYS ONLY IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO HERE IN OPPOSITION. I WILL
GO TO LINE FIVE SIXTY SIX OF-THIS ORDER CAN YOU CAN YOU
ESTIMATE HOW MANY ONLINE
OPPOSITION. HI CHAU JUST ONE IN
OPPOSITION ARM- ALL RIGHT LET'S
LET'S GO TO THAT PERSON. OKAY
ONE MOMENT HERE HI OF LINE FIVE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY I
STATED BY THE COURT EARLIER BUT
I THINK AS AN EMPLOYER OR
PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYER WE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN WILL BE
BECOME A VIOLATOR OF THE LAW
UNION MA'AM CLEAR HIM ARE YOU
ARE YOU ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY
ONE. I SUPPORT THE SPIRIT BUT
I'M ALL RIGHT THANKS. SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT MISTER MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE TWENTY ONE. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NONE IN OUR QUEUE-
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER I SEE. MISTER HERTZBERG
CENTER HERTZBERG MICROPHONES UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR I GETTING FRIENDLY
QUESTION FOR THE FRIENDLY.
AUTHOR PAGE SIX OF THE ANALYSIS
IT SAYS. THAT THIS MEASURE WAS
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL TO THE BILL
TWELVE. FIFTY SEVEN PASSED BY
BOTH HOUSES THE LEGISLATURE. BY
WIDE MARGINS AND WHAT IT SAYS
IS NO OPPOSITION THERE'S ONE
PERSON WHO'S OPPOSITION
MATTERED BECAUSE THE VETO THIS.
INDICATING THAT OF FOLKS WHO
HAVE A DUTY TO CREATE INJURY
PREVENTION PLAN- AND THAT THE
INVESTIGATION BY LETTER WOULD
PROCEDURE WAS TOO BURDENSOME.
AND THAT FOR HOMEOWNERS AND
RENTERS HAS BEEN WORKABLE AND
RAISES SIGNIFICANT POLICY
CONCERNS. I'M SURE I'M JUST
TRYING FOR JUST FR THE RECORD
TO GET SOME CLARIFICATION IF I
COULD ASK THE- AUTHOR FOR
QUESTION TO SEE. IF YOU KNOW
LOOK IT'S OUR- IT'S OUR ABILITY
IF WE WANT TO KEEP SENDING
STUFF DOWN I SENT THE
CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY ACT ACT
DOWN. THE GOVERNOR FIVE TIMES
FORGOT. IT SIGNED I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT. OUR THE
LEGISLATURE VERSION OF THE
POWER OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
SHOULD BE QUESTIONED I'M JUST
QUESTIONING WHETHER THERE'S
BEEN ANY DISCUSSION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO. YES
MISTER CHAIR YES WE ARE AND IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE BELIEVE THAT
ONE WE HAVE TO CONTINUE UNTIL
WE CHANGE THIS LAW FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THOSE UP PRIMARILY
WOMEN. WE ALSO MADE SOME
CHANGES HERE THAT WE HOPE
ADDRESSES THE- THE ISSUE
PARTICULARLY OVER THE PRIVACY
AND HOW THE AN INVESTIGATION
COULD BE. CONDUCTED WE HAVE WE
BELIEVE THAT- AND- THAT WOULD
AVOID UNWARRANTED INVASION OF
PERSONAL PRIVACY- SO WE BELIEVE
THAT WE- ADDRESS SOME OF IT-
THERE MAY BE OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE STILL ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MIND BUT-
WE'RE GONNA KEEP ON. OF MAKING
THE CASE BECAUSE THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO WOMEN THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO I THINK AS YOU
HEARD THE VOICES OF EMPLOYERS
HOUSEHOLD EMPLOYERS WHO WANT TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. WHO KNOW
THAT THEY CAN DO THE RIGHT
THING AND THEY WANT HELP IN
DOING THE RIGHT THING SO THE
COMBIATION OF ALL THOSE IS
WITH MOTIVATED AND INSPIRED US
TO KEEP ON- MOVING FORWARD WITH
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THREE
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS I SEE NO
MICROPHONES UP CENTER LAYERED
MOVES THE BILL- SIR THERE ALSO
D. CARE CLOSE THANK YOU AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK.
YOU MR. ALL RIGHT. THE MAN
CHIEF COUNSEL IS WOULD YOU CALL
THE- YES- THIS IS S. BILL THREE
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR DID US
SOME OF THE MOTION BY SENATOR
LAYERED. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG HI
NUMBER HI BORGES'S. YOUR JUST
NOT VOTING NO NO NO SORRY-
BORDERS NO. CAPITAL HI DEBBIE
AT ALL I DID ASAL. DID I SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE JONES
THE WHOLE NO JONES NO LAYERED
BY LAYERED I STERN. BY CAL SKI
HI WHITE HOUSE SKI AYE WIENER.
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX YOU HAVE
SEVENTY TWO RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON CALL THAT
WAS THE LAST BILL- WE INVITE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
ARE- HAD NOT BEEN PRESENT HERE.
TO PRESENT THEMSELVES IN THE
CHAMBER WE'RE GONNA LIVE CALLS
HERE IN ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS.
AND THEN- AND THEN WE'LL SEE
WHERE WE ARE I KNOW IT'S
QUICKLY APPROACHING THE HOUR OF
SEVEN AND WE GET OVERTIME AFTER
SEVEN. BUT I THINK WE SHOULD
TRY TO AND BEFORE THAT BY THE
WAY THAT'S A JOKE. SO AND I
THINK CHAIR SO LET'S LET'S DO
THIS LET'S SPLIT CALLS RIGHT
NOW FOR THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENT AND THEN LET SOME.
LET'S SEE. WHERE THE OTHER
MEMBERS ARE SO. CHIEF COUNSEL
ESTRADA WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
LIVE CALLS PLEASE. AT BEGINNING%
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
HERTZBERG I WOULD LIKE TO BURKE
HI STERN WIECKOWSKI Y. CASKEY I
WIENER. SO YOU HAVE NINE TWO
ZERO RIGHT NOW OKAY WE'LL PUT
IT BACK ON CALL OKAY. MOVING TO
SB SIXTEEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I BORGIAS.
NO PORGES SNOW HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. JEFF THIS
IS SENATE BILL SIXTEEN FILE
ITEM. ONE JONES NOT VOTING. K.
SIX YOU HAVE SEVEN TWO ONE
RIGHT NOW. BACK ON CALL OKAY
GOING TO THE NEXT ITEM S. B.
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR PAN WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING- YOU HAVE GOT
TO DANCE OKAY- BURKE HI AMBER
GUY. PORGES NOT VOTING. STERN
WIENER. SIX THAT SEVEN TWO ONE
RIGHT NOW. WITH SEVEN CALL BACK
ON CALL YES PLEASE NEXT BILL IS
S. B. FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
ALLEN. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
JONES JONES NOT VOTING STERN.
WIENER. THAT'S EIGHT ZERO WITH
SOME FOLKS NOT VOTING. WE NEED
A BACK ON CALL AND- NEXT ITEM
INTERVENORS WITHIN EARSHOT-
WE'D ASK HIM TO PRESENT HIMSELF
SO. OKAY THANK NEXT BILL IS SB
THREE THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR AT
LEAVE THAT WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D BURGESS. GORGEOUS NO
DATA SO. DEPRESSED SO I JONES
JONES NO STERN WIENER. BACK ON
CALL AT. SEVENTY TWO- THE NEXT
ITEM UP IS SB SIX THIRTY THREE
BY SENATOR LEE MON WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I BRIDGES. WE'RE
JUST NOT VOTING CAVEAT ALL.
CABALLERO I JONES JONES NOT
VOTING STERN WIENER. WIENER HI.
THANKS YOU HAVE EIGHT TWO ZERO
AND EVERYONE HAS FOUND FOR THAT
BILLS OUT. EIGHT ZERO. THE NEXT
BILL IS SB SIX FIVE OR BY
SENATOR MAN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I COPY AT ALL. WE CARRY
IT OUT I STERN. WIENER WIENER I.
THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO AND TO
EVERYONE'S VOTED TWENTY ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM
IS S. B. TWO SEVENTY BY SENATOR
DID ALSO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE BURGESS. PORTIS NO
CABALLERO HI COVEY IT'LL I
JONES. JONES NO STERN WIENER
WIENER I. YOU HAVE EIGHT TWO
EVERYONE HAS VOTED EIGHT TO THE
BILLS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS S.
B. THREE NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR JONES WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING NO. CUBBY AT ALL. NOT
VOTING NOT VOTING DID I SO. DID
I SO NO. STERN WIENER WIENER NO
THAT BILL HAS. TWO TO THREE
FIVE SIX TWO TWO SEVEN THE BILL
FAILS. THE NEXT ITEM IS SB
THREE TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR DID
ALSO. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
STERN WIENER IF YOU MOVE WIENER
AYE ONE TWO THREE FOUR.
SEVENTEEN THAT'S EIGHT TO AND
EVERYONE HAS VOTED THAT THE
BILLS OUT. EIGHT TO TWO. YOU
WANNA GO BACK TO SEIZE ME. LET
ME YEAH WITHOUT OBJECTION A
CHAIR RECOGNIZES CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
ASKED FOR RECONSIDERATION THREE
ALL RIGHT WITH WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED CENTER BOARD JUST DIED
IN HERE CENTER BOARD UC'S
MUFFLED ALL RIGHT- LET'S GO
DOWN THE REST OF THE LIST. ALL
RIGHT- STARTING WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
SENATORS WHO HAVE NOT YET
VOTED. THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE STERN. WIENER WIENER I.
MORE ANYTHING THAT'S TEN TO
ZERO AND EVERYONE HAS VOTED
JUST JUST AS A HEADS UP I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE LINE
THAT- ARE ARE THERE TO
TESTIFIED SB SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
SB SEVEN TWENTY FOUR WAS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH WAS UP
HERE- JUST VOTED OUT. JUST A
MOMENT AGO. AND SO WE WILL ONCE
WE- GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE
MORE TIME WE WILL BE A JERK. IN
OTHER WORDS WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
TAKING ANYMORE TESTIMONY ON THE
PHONE. NO THE MONEY IT. DAVID I
THINK OR ACT IS. THERE ARE I
THINK CALENDAR ADOPTED. TEN
ZERO. OKAY NECKS- SB SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER. THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE STERN. WIENER WIENER
AYE THAT'S. EIGHT TO ONE AND
EVERYONE HAS VOTED EIGHT TO ONE
THAT BILLS OUT. THE NEXT BILL
IS S. B. SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
PAN WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
STE BORJAS. STERN WIENER WIENER
AYE THAT'S. EIGHT TO ONE IN
EVERY ONE OF THOSE OUT OKAY.
THE NEXT BILL IS SB FORTY FOUR
BY SENATOR ALLEN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I. JONES STERN WIENER
WIENER I. THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO
NINE ZERO THE BILLS OUT. THE
NEXT BILL IS SB THREE THIRTY
ONE BY SENATOR IT LEAVE IT WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I. STERN
WIENER. WIENER I. THAT'S EIGHT
TO THE BILL'S NOT EIGHT TO. AND
JUST. ONE ONE ONE SECOND. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU TO STAFF THANK YOU TO
MEMBERS THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO
CALLED IN SENATE JUDICIARY.
COMMITTEE IS A JOURNEY.